RIGHT. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE AND
WELCOME TO BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
THREE IT'S GOOD TO SEE. ALL OF
YOU HERE TO THE HEY WE'RE HAVING
AN IN PERSON HEARING IN THE
STATE CAPITAL. WE'RE IN ROOM
FOUR FORTY SEVEN AND THE
PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA TODAY
WILL BE APPEARING REMOTELY. AND
THOSE WHO ARE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN PERSON MAY DO SO WHEN WE
OPENED PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END
OF THE HEARING. AFTER THOSE IN
COMMITTEE AND THE COMMITTEE ROOM
HAVE SPOKEN WILL OPEN IT UP TO A
TELEPHONE TESTED TESTIMONY. THE
PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE SHOULD
ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET SO IF
YOU WANT TO. PROVIDE TESTIMONY
BY PHONE. THE PHONE NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN YOU'LL NEED AN
ACCESS CODE THAT NUMBER IS ONE
THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR FOUR SEVEN
AGAIN ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR
FOUR SEVEN. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE APT
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE. TWO
ZERO NINE NINE. AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. ALTHOUGH
IF YOU COMMENT WILL HAVE UP TO
ONE MINUTE TO SPEAK. HI WHERE
IT'S AT TODAY WE'RE NOT PLANNING
ON TAKING ANY VOTES. AND WILL
BEGIN WITH OUR THREE DISCUSSION
ITEMS BUT- HI IT WILL ENACT
CONNECTION WITH THOSE WILL ALLOW
THE PANELISTS TO ALL THE
PANELISTS TO GIVE THEIR
TESTIMONY AND THEN OPEN IT UP TO
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. AFTER THE DISCUSSION
ITEMS COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY ASK
QUESTIONS. OR MAKE COMMENTS
ABOUT THE NON DISCUSSION ITEMS
THAT'S THE- A NON PRISON TATIAN
CALENDAR AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
AGENDA. SO AFTER THOSE- AFTER WE
FOR A COMPLETED OUR DISCUSSION
ITEMS. IF YOU WISH COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CAN ASK QUESTIONS OR
MAKE COMMENTS ABOUT THE NON
DISCUSSION ITEMS AND OF COURSE
WE WILL DOWN AND WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT. SO WE ARE GOING TO
BEGIN. WITH ISSUE ONE ON PAGE
EIGHT OF THE AGENDA ITEMS TO BE
HEARD. THE FIRST ISSUE IS-
RELATED TO ZERO EMISSION THE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE PACKAGE.
AND I BELIEVE- MISTER SIEGEL
YOU'RE GOING TO BEGIN. OUR
DISCUSSION. WELL GOOD MORNING
CARE MEMBERS- THIRD DRAG OUR
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ALL LIKE E
BEGIN THAT DISCUSSION AND THEN
I'LL PASS IT ON TO MY COLLEAGUE
CRAIG PEOPLE UP THE AIRPORT AND
ANDREW COOL FROM THE ENERGY
COMMISSION THAT OPERATOR
ELABORATE ON THAT WITHIN THEIR
RESPECTIVE DEPARTMENT I'LL JUST
GIVE A LITTLE BIT OF AN OVERVIEW
HELLO- THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT COMMITTED THREE POINT
NINE BILLION DOLLARS OVER THREE
YEARS OR THEIR OWN MISSION YOU
CALL CALIBRATION AND INCLUDED
pRANGING FROM CLEANING UPGRADED
TRUCK TRANSIT AND- BUT THE- TO.
EQUITABLE ALLOCATION OF YOUR
VEHICLE IF I AND RAIL ALL
COUPLED WITH INFRASTRUCTURE AND
INCENTIVES OR IN STATE
MANUFACTURING NOW THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO INVEST AN
ADDITIONAL SIX POINT ONE BILLION
ONE TIME OVER FIVE YEARS WITH A
FOCUS ON COMMUNITY THERE ARE
MOST IMPACTED BREAKING THAT HOLD
BACK INVESTMENT AND BILLION
DOLLARS OVER SIX YEARS NOW. EVEN
CONTINUE TO ADVANCE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE HM HELP INCREASE PRIVATE
SECTOR COMPANY AND ALTHOUGH AND
IN BURKE IN MARKET ALLOWING THAT
THEIR MISSION INDUSTRY
CAPITALIZE ON A WHOLE ALWAYS A
FOCUS ON DRIVING. INVESTMENT THE. WORK THAT YOU CARBONATE ASIAN
UP HELP BOTH POLLUTING. MAY HELP
IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH AND ALSO
HELP REDUCE THE- DEPENDED ON ALL
VIEW. NOW NO BUDGET PROPOSAL V.
THAT. IN DIFFERENT BANDS
ELOQUENT CAMINO. ECHOING FIVE
CAMINO. HEALTH AND AT. TO THE
BENEFIT OF BEING. AND ALSO MORE
DOUBLE THE MONEY PARKED IN FOR
THAT DUTY- ACCELERATE. I'LL BE
THE BEST ALTHOUGH HI FACT
DIRECTLY COLLECT THE A MISSION
YEAH MARKET DEVELOPMENT STRATEGY
. WHICH ORGANIZED THE EFFORTS
THE PEOPLE UP IN MARK WHICH ARE
. EQUAL TEMPERATURE AND THEIR AT
WORK. SO WITH THAT TURN IT OVER
TO LIKE GREG PERSONAL AT THAT
CALIFORNIA'S PERSON TELL A
LITTLE BIT MORE ON THEM THAT THE
PUT IN THE.
TRANSFORM THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR AND PROVIDE PRIORITIZE
IMPECCABLE TRANSITION. I
ENSURING THAT THESE INVESTMENTS
SUPPORT ACCESS TO CLEANER
TECHNOLOGY FOR LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS BEYOND VEHICLE
OWNERSHIP THIS PROPOSAL PROVIDES
OPPORTUNITIES TO REINVEST IN
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE LONG
SYSTEM ACTIVE INVESTMENT YOUR
COMMUNITY BASED MOBILITY
PROJECTS TO LIFT UP OUR PRIORITY
POPULATIONS EXPANDING
TRANSPORTATION CHOICES INCLUDE
BICYCLING WALKING AND TRANSIT
HELP TAKE CARS OFF THE ROAD. NOW
AS YOU MOVE THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS THIS YEAR AND YOUR CAR'S
OWN PUBLIC PROCESS WE EMBRACE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE OUR
JOURNEY TO UNDERSTAND GROWER
RELATIONSHIPS WITH HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
TRIBAL NATIONS RECOGNIZING THAT
IN ORDER TO REALIZE THE JUST
TRANSITION FOR ALL YOU MUST
ENGAGE IN DIFFICULT BUT
NECESSARY CONVERSATIONS. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ALONE CARP
HELD OVER TWENTY PUBLIC MEETINGS
AND DOZENS OF INDIVIDUAL
MEETINGS TO SEEK INPUT FROM
STAKEHOLDERS UNDER ANNUAL
FUNDING PLAN THE PARTICIPATORY
WAY WE HELP COMMITTEE LISTENS
LISTENING SESSIONS AND HEARD
FROM RESIDENTS CONDITIONALLY
BEEN UNDERSERVED MACINNES THE
OVER YEARS OF DISINVESTMENT
TAKES INTENTIONAL EFFORT ON OUR
PART TO DO BETTER WE'RE BUILDING
PROGRAMS THAT SPECIFICALLY MEET
THE NEEDS IDENTIFIED BY
COMMUNITIES AND COMMITTED TO
DOING MORE IN THE SPACE. MORE
BROADLY CARD STANDS READY TO
IMPLEMENT THE FUNNY PROPOSED IN
THIS BUDGET WE'VE ALREADY MADE
GREAT PROGRESS IN IMPLEMENTING
THE FUNDING APPROPRIATED BY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET WITH
OVER SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ALREADY ALLOCATED TO EXISTING
PROJECTS CERTAIN CALIFORNIANS
MOST OF THE REMAINING FUNDING
ANTICIPATED BE FULLY ALLOCATED
TO PROJECTS THAT OF THIS YEAR.
LET ME GIVE YOU AN OVERVIEW. OF
CARDS PORTION OF THIS PACKAGE.
LOWS ALL ACTION. INCLUDES IN
ADDITION TWO TWO DOLLARS TO K.
AREA BOARD. WHICH WERE VERY
GRATEFUL AND WILL MORE THAN
DOUBLE THE FUNDING TARGETED FOR
HEAVY DUTY ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY ADVANCEMENT. IT WILL
SPEND INVESTMENTS FOLKS AND
PASSENGER VEHICLES AND HIS
FELLOW CONSIDER LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS. AND LIFT UP AND MOST
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES THE COMMUNITY BASED
MOBILITY PROJECTS ULTIMATELY
STRENGTHENING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PARTNERSHIP. AND AMPLIFY THE KEY
PRIORITIES IDENTIFIED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
DELIVERING THE BOTH EQUITY AND
SCALE AHEAD OF THE OF THE HIGH
POINTS NOW. FIRST I'LL TALK
ABOUT THE LOW INCOME ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE INCENTIVES
THERE TWENTY FIFTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS SEVENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS APACHE JARRATT AND
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND. IN CONTINUED
SUPPORT FOR LOW INCOME CONSUMER
PURCHASES INCLUDING THROUGH
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL IN FINANCING
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM SUPPORTING
NEW VEHICLE PURCHASES FOR LOW
INCOME CONSUMERS AND OTHER ACNE
PROJECTS FOCUSED ON LOW INCOME.
VEHICLE OWNERSHIP. SECOND
THERE'S A ZERO INCOME MISSION
MOBILITY PART OF THIS PACKAGE.
THIS IS FOUR HUNDRED NINETEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
FOR FOUR YEARS. TO SUPPORT ME TO
STAY IN A WHOLE COMMUNITY BASED
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROJECTS
EXPAND CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS THEREBY REDUCE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED INCREASE ACCESS
TO ZERO EMISSION MOBILITY IN
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. IS LOCALLY DRIVEN
PROJECTS RESPOND DIRECTLY TO
CRITICAL MOBILITY NEEDS
IDENTIFIED BY COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. AND RESIDENTS
WORKING ON THE FRONT LINES LISTA
PARA POPULATIONS. THESE PROJECTS
ALSO CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT THE
ACTIONS INCLUDED IN THE
LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED LOW
INCOME BARRIER STUDY FOR
OVERCOME BARRIERS TO CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION ACCESS FOR LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS. IN FURTHER
BUILT UPON THE VISION ADVANCE
THE CLIMATE ACTION PLAN FOR
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS.
INCLUDES LEGACY PROJECTS LIKE
CLEAN MOBILITY OPTIONS AND
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
EQUITY PROJECT INCLUDE ABILITIES
IN SCHOOL. AND PROJECTS THAT THE
SELECTED COMMUNITY BASED
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS ASSESSMENTS
CAPACITY BUILDING TEMPLE SYSTEMS
OUTREACH. AND WORKFORCE TRAINING
THE DEVELOPMENT. WITHIN THIS FOR
YOU PROPOSAL ANY BUT PROCESS
SEES CARBON HOUSE CONSIDER. UP
PRO. THE COUNCIL OF CAL'S.
CONSENTED BY THE REWARD.
AGENCIES FOR REVIEW. PROJECTS
FOCUS ON EXPAND TRADE. CHOICE
REDUCE MILES TRAVELED IN LINE
WITH THE STATE'S CLIMATE IN
EQUITY GOALS SEVERAL EXPANSION
PROJECTS INCREASED VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED IN. OPPOSITION TO THE
SCHOOLS. ALSO PROJECTS COULD
INCLUDE TRANSIT ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION BACK FROM ABILITY
SERVICES CARSHARING VANPOOLING.
IN BANKS AND OTHER. INNOVATIVE
INVESTMENTS TO REDUCE DEPENDENCE
ON DRIVING. I NEXT PART OF THE
PACK. FOCUSES APPROPRIATELY
NVDIMM DUTY HEAVY DUTY AND OFF
ROAD- ZEROCHAN VEHICLES THIS
WOULD INCLUDE FIVE HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND OVER FOUR YEARS THE PLAY
THOUSAND RIDGE TRUCKS IN
APPROXIMATELY SIXTEEN HUNDRED
TRANSIT BUSES. REDUCING HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLE POLLUTION AND
ACCELERATING ELECTRIFICATION BY
FOCUSING ON THE SOURCES WHICH
POST PARTICULARLY HACKS
MOTORISTS TO COMMUNITIES THAT
PARTICULARLY READY FOR THE
SERVICE IN TRANSITION. IT ALSO
INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME FUTURE OF SUPPORT I'M FOR
ZERO EMISSION CLEAN TRUCKS BUSES
AND OFFERED EQUIPMENT PRESS
ARRANGING CLASSES INCLUDING
CONSTRUCTION AGRICULTURE AND
FINALLY TWENTY FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND IT FOR
FOUR YEARS. THE CITY CONTINUAL
PORT ELECTRIFICATION A
LEVERAGING BOTH BATTERIES AND
FUEL CELLS AND OF COURSE THE
BILL IT PROGRAM IN CLOSE
COLLABORATION WITH THE CC IN OUR
OTHER PARTNERS. FINALLY THERE'S
AN EMERGING OPPORTUNITIES
COMPONENTS OF THIS PACKAGE
CONSISTENT WITH A LONG TIME
FOCUS ON INNOVATION. THIS
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR IN
GENERAL FUND WOULD INVEST IN
DEMONSTRATION OF PILOT PROJECTS
AND I CURTAIN SECTORS SUCH AS
MARITIME AVIATION LOCOMOTIVES
AND OFFERED APPLICATIONS TO
NUCLEATE CHANGE. COLLECTIVELY IS
INVESTMENTS COORDINATED CLOSELY
WITH THE CC AND ALL PARTNERS
WILL HELP MAINTAIN CALIFORNIA'S
ROLE AS THE HUB OF THAT MARKET
CREATION INNOVATION GRADING WORK
RESTRAINT IN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES BOOK
CELEBRATING ZEROCHAN SOLUTIONS
THE TOUGHEST REACH SEGMENTS THE
TRANSPORTATION ECONOMY. IN MANY
WAYS THIS IS WHAT GOVERNMENT CAN
BEFORE AND OF COURSE SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE PROVE THIS FUNDING.
DEEPLY LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE EXTENSIBLE
PROCESS BERMAN CHANGES ARE
CONSIDERED. AS MANY KNOWS ANY
DECISIONS THAT STAFF POSES THE
BOARD MAKES WILL COMPLY WITH
LEGISLATIVE GUIDANCE WHAT THE
STATUTE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
ABOUT YOUR BILL LANGUAGE. BEYOND
THAT OUTCOMES CANNOT BE
PREDETERMINED YOU MUST WORK
TRANSPARENT WITH THE PUBLIC
INCLUDING EQUITY STAKEHOLDERS
INDUSTRY COMMUNITY ON A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS UNDER HIGH
TRANSPARENCY AND OPEN GOVERNMENT
LAWS. I WOULD WELCOME THE
LEGISLATURE DISTRICT
PARTICIPATION IN THE MONTHS LONG
PUBLIC PROCESS THAT GOES. INTO
DEVELOPING A FUNDING PLAN
FIFTEEN TRANSPORTATION SENTENCE
WHICH REFERENCE OF THIS GROUP
FUNDING SPENT. IN THE- I JUST
THEIR STAFF ON A BRIEF AND
FUTURE CHEN. LOCATION MARKET.
ARE ELSE. PLEASE CONTACT WHICH
LEFT AFTER WILL BE HAPPY MAKE
THAT HAPPEN. WITHOUT A CLOSE AND
IS ONE OF THE THANK YOU. THE
EXCITING DISCUSS WHAT CAN DO TO
GET THIS IS FOR MOMENT I REALLY.
BEING HERE PASSED OVER TO
MICHAEL. AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION THANK. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS HANNAH
RUSSELL AND THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF THE FILM TRANSPORTATION
DIVISION AT THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR
THEIR MISSION CRITICAL PROPOSAL
WITH YOU TODAY. I WILL FOCUS ON
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH COMPLEMENT
THE CARBON BUT IT OCCURRED
ABOUT. THE ENERGY COMMISSION
CARP HOW DISTANT ROLL WHICH ARE
COMPLEMENTARY TO ONE ANOTHER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOCUS IS ON
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE BUILD OUT
BOTH ELECTRIC AND HYDROGEN. WE
HAVE A RIGOROUS ANALYSIS WITH
PUBLIC AND STAKEHOLDER AND BUT-
WE ALSO HELP ENABLE VEHICLE GRID
INTEGRATION. BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE GOOD CITIZENS OF THE GRANT.
ADDITIONALLY WE MAKE INVESTMENTS
IN FUEL PRODUCTION. FOR
TRANSPORTATION PURPOSES. IN FACT
EARLIER THIS YEAR WE WANTED TO
RENEW AWARD. BERMAN NOVEMBER. IN
HYDROGEN PRODUCTION. THE VIDEO
CARD POKER ON VEHICLES OF THE
VEHICLE THAT YOU'RE- WE'RE
EXCITED TO OUR PARTNER WITH THE
RESEARCH. BUT I HELP THE HELP
FRANCISCO BEEN NOT STATE
AGENCIES. ARE WELL AS THE MARK.
THIS YEAR BY BILL THE LOCK YEAR.
BUT IT REALLY FROM ON EQUITIES-
PARTY COMMUNITY. CALIFORNIA MUST
INVEST IN EQUITY TREND THAT. TO
FOR THE EVERYONE CAN BE THE AIR
AND COMMUNITY I'M NOT LIVE WITH
POLLUTION OF THOUGHT QUOTE. IT
OVER PROVIDE NEAR TERM BENEFITS
. BY CREATING ST JOBS AND
REDUCING YOUR POLLUTION BUT ALSO
LONG TERM BENEFITS AND WE
TRANSFORM. I'M INDUSTRY TIED. TO
DEPENDENCE ON FOSSIL FUELS. I
CALIFORNIANS WILL. THE LOWER
OPERATING THE MISSION CRITICAL.
RELATIVE TO GAS. AN ENTRY IN OUR
PROGRAM REMAIN HIGH AND THEY'RE
ALL OVER SINCE. ALL STARTED
LOCKED FUNDING TO GET YOU AN
EXTRA PROGRESS. WE CONDUCTED
EXTENSIVE PUBLIC OUTREACH WITH
THAT UPDATED THE CREEK
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM ABOUT THE
PLAN AND HELD PUBLIC MEETINGS
INCLUDING THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ADVISORY GROUP. AND
SEVERAL WORKSHOPS TO APPEAR
STAKEHOLDER INPUT. WERE ABLE TO
FIND DOWN A FIFTY FOOT LOCATIONS
WHICH ARE OVERSUBSCRIBED PUTTING
IN PART TO EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
WORK THAT FITS POLLUTION WHICH
TARGET ANIMATION AND LYFT DUTY
AND MEDIUM TO HEAVY DUTY.
ANOTHER TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
PROJECTS JOINTLY WITH CAR AND
ADDRESS TRUCK PLEASE. SIXTEEN
MILLION FOR PROJECT THE TRANS
BUTTON AND A PROXY TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION FOR MEDIUM DUTY
HEAVY DUTY PLANNING BLUEPRINT.
WE'VE ALSO PUT PEOPLE TO FUND
NEW SOLICITATION WE LOST A
SOLICITATION FOR HIGH MILEAGE
POPULAR VEHICLE TARGETING THOSE
SUCH AS A LEFT IN THE RIVER AND
ALLOW FUNDING WE WERE IN TO EVEN
MORE MONEY THE ACCOUNT. WE
STATES WITH THE FOR COMMUNITIES
TO PLACE OUR AND HERE. AND ALSO
A MORE FAMILY HOUSING FOR. TO
PUSH HARDER THOSE WHO DIDN'T
LIVE IN A AND CON. WE OFTEN USE
THEM ON. TO LAUNCH SEVERAL
GRANTS. SHE WOULD LIKE TO THE
BLOCK GRANT ONE OF PARTNER WITH
THE AT THE ONE OF CAL START.
TOTALING UP FIVE MILLION. AND A
MEDIAN HEAVY DO BAKRI. THEY WERE
CALLING. WHICH IS HAD FIFTEEN
BOTH LAST YEAR'S MY- FOR ABLE TO
ADD A TWO NINETY WELL. CONNECT
RETURN TO THE OVERVIEW OF DOWN
TO. OF COURSE. VOCAL AGAIN
THERE'S A REALLY FOR I COULD
FOCUS AND- BUT ACCESS DETAIL.
AND WE BUILD ON TO. GIFTING
PROGRAM. BUT ALSO PROPOSED NEW
TO TRY GOT. A LOOK AT TO
LEVERAGE. ABOUT YOU'RE NOT
FUNDING OR- AND WILL THE PRIVATE
. MAY OTHERWISE BE ABOUT. AND WE
KNOW THE LACK OF INTEREST STILL
THE BIG BARRIER WE HAVE TO.
ARNOLD SHOWS ME ABOUT POINT
MILLION. BY TWENTY FOR THE LIKE
THE FACE. AND ABOUT HOW FIFTY SO
THOUSAND MORE THAN MEDIUM TO
HEAVY DUTY THE S. BUT WITH GOOD
PLANNING THE VEHICLE WILL BE. AT
THE PROGRESS. THEY HAD
BENEFICIAL NEW LOW. TO MAKE THE
GRADE MORE EFFICIENT WHAT'S NOT
GIFT. BECAUSE FOR ALL BREAK.
COULD HELP NEVER KNOW ALL AND
PROVIDE ON SITE WITH THE. SIX
THEN FIFTY OF THE TO BILL
DOLLARS. AND ON THE LADY FIVE
FOLKSY THREE MILLION FOR
EQUITABLE OUT HOME CHARGE
DECEPTION TO IT ONE FOCUS MORE
UNIT DWELLINGS APARTMENTS CONDOS
AND ONE FOURTH FOCUS PRIORITY
COMMUNITY LOOK AT HOME. AND WE
ALSO WITH HUNDRED NO AND FOR.
BOB JUNE VESTED. STATEWIDE
NETWORK OF HIGH POWERED BY
CHARGER. AT CHARGING NOTHING THE
LOWEST BECAUSE LOOK GREAT FAMILY
AND THE MOST. WE ALSO KNOW- MOST
LIKELY WE'RE NOT GOING TO ABLE
TO RUN A HOME CHARGING FOR. WHO
REALLY NOW DONE BACK TO THE SHIP
FAMILY WILL MOVE US TOWARD. AND
THEN ON THE DAY HEAVY DUTY SIDE
WHEREAS FOR ABOUT A BILL DOLLARS
FOR BOTH A- INFRASTRUCTURE AND
HIGHER. KNOWING THAT THE ARE
ALSO EQUITY IN. MEDIUM TO HEAVY
EMISSION TRIP REPORT PLAN LOW
BETWEEN. SO WE WANT TO CUT. DO
YOU POLLUTION AND IF YOU. AND TO
GIVE A SORT OF UPON FUELS. BUT
THE PROPOSED BUDGET FOR THE
FACT. TWO HUNDRED MILLION GRADE
TRUCK AND- HUNDRED MAIL FOR. AND
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FOR A BROAD
. ARRAY OF NEAR MEXICO BE A NOT
QUITE INCLUDING BETWEEN. AND I'M
- AND HOW FIFTY MAIL.
TEMPERATURES IN THE COURT TO
HEAR. AND AGAIN I WANT. IN THE
MEAT DID YOU HAVE DUTY. BOTH A
LOT AND HYDROGEN WILL BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS. AND WE KNOW
WE HAVE TO MAKE TO THE HAD IT
FOR THE VEHICLE BEING THE- AND
IF ALL TRANSLATE TO GET
INSTINCTS THAT THE UPS. AND THEN
FINALLY WE'RE ASKING A HUNDRED
DOLLAR. TO FUND INTO. PREVIOUS
MARINE WELCOME. AND ALSO INTO IN
VEHICLE GRETA. AND THESE THAN
HOW ON COMMITMENT TO MAKING THE
END OF A PIPER. AND BREAKING
THOSE JOBS INVESTMENT HELLO.
WELL THE ROBOT PUBLIC. KALRA
GAVE METAL ABOUT. LEVERAGING
WORK OF THE PRIVATE MARKETING
STATES. THIRTY TWO CARBAPENEM
ABSOLUTELY THE PLAN WHAT YEAR
FINE. MORE EAGER TO COULD
BRINGING OUR UNIQUE. TO TACKLE
THE CRIME CRISIS. IN APPROVAL
HEALTH IN OUR COMMUNITY. AND
EVEN TIED COLLECT THAT MARC.
DEVELOPMENT DRIVE LED BY THAT
WOULD ORGANIZE OUR EFFORTS
ACROSS A- PRIVATE DOCTORS UP.
I'M GOOD WITH THAT OKAY THANK
YOU AND WE LOOK FOR IF YOUR
QUESTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DO WE HAVE- COMMENTS FROM ALEJO
. MISTER BROWN YES GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURKE GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING ROSS BROWN
AT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- SO AS YOU HEARD FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION- IT IS PROPOSING-
SIX POINT ONE BILLION DOLLAR
PACKAGE OVER FIVE YEARS FROM A
VARIETY OF FUN SOURCES FOR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. ABOUT THREE
POINT NINE BILLION FROM LAST
YEAR ARE YOU GET A TOTAL OF TEN
BILLION AND THE FIGURE BEGINNING
ON PAGE TWELVE OF YOUR AGENDA
KIND OF BREAKS ALL THAT SPINNING
OUT INTO DIFFERENT CATEGORIES. A
HIGH LEVEL MOST OF THE FUNDING
WOULD GO TO- EXISTING PROGRAMS
BUT THERE ARE SOME NEW PROGRAMS
FOR EXAMPLE A- ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUS
PROGRAM WHICH I KNOW WAS HEARD
IN A DIFFERENT SUBCOMMITTEES I'M
NOT GONNA FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON
THAT. YOUR TODAY- THREE HUNDRED
MILLION EQUITABLE AT HOME
CHARGING PROGRAM WHAT YOU HEARD
ABOUT. AND THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
THREE MILLION FEDERAL FUNDS FOR
THAT. FEELING INFRASTRUCTURE-
OVERALL ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF THE
NEW FUNDING WITH SUPPORT HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES AND OFF ROAD
EQUIPMENT- AND- SO I'M JUST
GONNA GO THROUGH THAT'S KIND OF
AT A HIGH LEVEL SORT OF
DESCRIPTION OF THE- THE PACKAGE.
WHEN I GO THROUGH WE REALLY
STARTED NOW OFFICE OF THE
PACKAGE A FEW WEEKS AGO. POSTED
ON OUR WEBSITE AND ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AND MY WALK
THROUGH A FEW OF THE KEY POINTS-
FIRST- I THINK JUST AS- A- BIG.
PICTURE OF THE LEGISLATURE WE
REALLY JUST HAVE TO CONSIDER.
THE PROPOSAL MIX OF SPENDING IS
CONSISTENT WITH ITS PRIORITIES-
AND WHICH PROGRAMS KIND OF
ACHIEVE ITS PRIORITIES FAST SO.
TIGHTLY WHAT IS THAT BUDGET
ALLOCATIONS FOR MOBILE SOURCE
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS ARE GOING TO
DEPEND ON. HOW IT PRIORITIZES
DIFFERENT POLICY GOALS SO FOR
EXAMPLE. MANY OF THESE PROGRAMS
HAVE A GOALS OF ONE OR MORE OF.
KIND OF THE FALL OF FOLLOWING
THINGS. HOW GAS PRODUCTION. NEAR
TROPICAL WORKS UNBLOCK- TECHNO.
TYPE ADVANCED TO KIND OF A CHEAP
LAW TERM- KEIICHI AIR POLLUTION
REDUCTION GOALS. AS WELL TRAINER
QUALITY BENEFITS ACCRUING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND SO
AS WE OUTLINED IN MORE DETAIL IN
OUR ANALYSIS THE DEGREE TO WHICH
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS TO CHEAT EACH
OF THESE GOALS- CAN DIFFER
PRETTY SUBSTANTIALLY BETWEEN
PROGRAM AND THERE ARE SOME
INHERENT TRADE OFFS AND SO A LOT
OF. SPENDING DECISIONS WILL
DEPEND HOW YOU PRIORITIZE THE
GOAL SO. OPERATIVE TO THE EXTENT
NEAR TERM GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS ARE PRIORITY- THE
AVAILABLE INFORMATION SUGGESTS
THAT. BUT THE PROGRAM'S PROPOSED
THAT EACH THAT HEAVY DUTY
VOUCHERS ARE ONE OF THE MORE
COST EFFECTIVE MOBILE SOURCE
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS. OVERALL KIND
OF AT THE AT THE PACKAGE A LOT
OF THAT KIND OF NEAR TERM
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION COSTS
ARE. RELATIVELY HIGH ESPECIALLY
COMPARED TO SOME OF THE OTHER
REGULATORY PROGRAMS THAT THE
STATE HAS RATHER AN INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS AT THE STATE HOUSE SO I
WOULD JUST HAVE TO KIND OF WHAT
IT'S LIKE WANT TO KIND OF KEEP
THAT IN MIND WHEN THINKINGABOUT
ITS- OVERALL PACKAGE AND
PRIORITIES. EXTENT NEAR TERM
REDUCTIONS AND LOCAL AIR
POLLUTION ARE LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITY OPTION ANY KIND OF SOME
OF THE OTHER STATE PROGRAMS-
LIKE HEAVY DUTY RETIREMENT
REPLACEMENT PROGRAMS WHICH ARE
NOT PART OF THIS PACKAGE BUT A
PART OF THE- OVERALL BUDGET.
GOING FORWARD- SUCH AS KERR
WEITERER FARMER SB SIX SEVENTEEN
WHICH I'LL DISCUSS I THINK AT A
LATER ITEM. OTHERS ARE APPEAR TO
BE KIND OF MORE COST EFFECTIVE
WAYS TO ACHIEVE. OF LOCAL AIR
POLLUTION REDUCTIONS- TO THE
EXTENT LONGER TERM GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTIONS IN AIR POLLUTION
REDUCTIONS ARE A PRIORITY THAN
THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
FOCUS ON KIND OF EFFORTS TO.
ADVANCED TECHNOLOGIES IN ADVANCE
CAN OPEN THAT TECHNOLOGIES- IN
THIS CASE THE LEGISLATURE COULD
TARGET FUNDING TO PROGRAMS. AT
TECHNOLOGY IN THE EARLY STAGES A
MARKET OF. FOR EXAMPLE. PRIORITY
IN. FOR HEAVY TO. PILOTS AND IN.
WORKED FOR. HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
AND OFF ROAD EQUIPMENT THEY'RE
KIND OF IN THE- EARLIER STAGES
THE MARKET DEVELOPMENT. AND
FINAL A KIND OF IF THE
PRIORITIES A TRAINER
IMPROVEMENTS MOSTLY TO.
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THE LEGISLATURE
COULD TARGET FUNDS TO THE
PROGRAMS THAT REDUCE BOTH
PRODUCED RIGHT HERE UP
POLLUTANTS COST EFFECTIVELY- AND
WHERE THE VAST MAJORITY OF
SPENDING BENEFITS LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
AGAIN- ARE THIS PACKAGE BUT I
KNOW YOU LET'S GUESS LATER ON
SORT OF A B. SIX SEVENTEEN
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS THEIR-
CREDIT. RATING HIGHLY ON KIND OF
BOTH OF THOSE METRICS AND SO- WE
CAN BE THERE IS KIND OF A FEW OF
THE KIND OF BIG PICTURE THINGS
TO THINK ABOUT WHEN THINKING
ABOUT HOW TO PRIORITIZE YOUR
GENERAL FUND RESOURCES ON MOBILE
SOURCE PROGRAMS AS WELL AS YOUR
FUTURE A PACKAGE. THE SECOND-
BLOOD. WE THINK MY TO. IN A
GROUP. AT THAT BUDGET HEARINGS
HERE TODAY ON THE DETAIL OF THE
NEW PROGRAMS THAT ARE BEING
PROPOSED. APPLE THE EQUITABLE AT
HOME CHARGING PROGRAM FOR LOW
INCOME AND MODERATE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. OUR PROGRAM TARGET
RENTERS- HOW OLD DENTURE
BENEFICIARIES BE NOTIFIED OF
AVAILABILITY OF THE FUNDS. AND
HOW THE PROGRAM DIFFERENT FROM
OTHER STATE PROGRAMS THAT
SUPPORT INFRASTRUCTURE FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS FOR EXAMPLE
THAT THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
PROGRAM. AND SO WE THINK SOME OF
THAT ADDITIONAL DETAIL COULD
HELP THE LEGISLATURE BETTER
EVALUATE. THAT THE MERITS OF THE
PROPOSED NEW PROGRAM. THIRD I
CAN DRINK FLUIDS THREE ARE NAY
THREE NO FOUR AB TRUCKING.
THROUGH FEDERAL FORMULA PROGRAM
THROUGH THE FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE. THERE'S
ALSO AN ADDITIONAL THREE BILLION
DOLLARS NATIONWIDE AND FEDERAL
GRANT FUNDING FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
THROUGH A COMPETITIVE PROGRAM
AND THE DETAILS FOR THESE
FEDERAL PROGRAMS ARE REALLY BEEN
RELEASED YET- BUT WE DO
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE DIRECT
THE ADMINISTRATION TO REPORT-
THIS SPRING ON ITS PLAN FOR
ENSURING THE STATE FUNDING FOR
THE CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE WILL
COMPLEMENT THIS NEW FEDERAL
FUNDING. SO IT'S GOING TO FOR
EXAMPLE DESCRIPTION OF HOW IT
BUT ALL THE STATE FUNDING CAN BE
USED TO LEVERAGE FEDERAL FUNDING
THROUGH A STATE MATCH FOR
EXAMPLE OR HOW IT ALL BUT
ADMINISTRATION IS PLANNING ON
USING IT TO FILL IN THE GAPS AND
FEDERAL FUNDING. AND IF THERE'S
ANY SPECIAL DETAIL ON KIND OF
THESE TYPES OF QUESTIONS WE
THINK ABOUT A SIGNIFICANT DELAY
I'VE BEEN TO DIFFERENT STATE
FUNDING UNTIL MORE DETAILS ARE
AVAILABLE IN THE ADMINISTRATION. DEVELOPS A CLEAR STRATEGY. AND
FINALLY- I WOULD RECOMMEND
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER. OFFICERS
WHAT KIND OF THE MULTI YEAR
FUND- A PRO IT ADMINISTRATION
HAS PRESENTED THIS YEAR SO THIS
PACKAGE INCLUDES OVER. THREE
POINT ABOUT. THIRTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN OUT HERE GENERAL FUND
COMMITMENTS- AND REALLY THERE
ARE JUST. WE THINK THEY'RE JUST
KIND OF SOME IMPORTANT TRADE
OFFS FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER SO ON THE ONE HAND. THE
COMMITMENTS ARE THESE KIND OF
MULTI YEAR COMMITMENTS CAN
PROVIDE MARKET CERTAINTY AND
MAKE IT EASIER. A TWELVE MAKE IT
EASIER FOR DEPARTMENTS TO
DESIGNER MINISTER PROGRAM SO FOR
EXAMPLE- THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE
KIND OF MARKET CERTAINTY TO
BUSINESSES CONSIDERING LONG TERM
INVESTMENTS SUCH AS
TRANSITIONING PLEASE TO ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES. AND ALSO
THERE COULD BE GREATER CERTAINTY
ABOUT HOW FUNDING CAN HELP OUR
STATE DEPARTMENT'S GOING TO
DESIGN PROGRAMS IN WAIT A WAIT
THAT AVOID. STRUCTURE IN SUCH AS
WAY PLUS. AND THE OTHER HAND HOW
THE POTENTIAL TO READ LETTERS
OVER HAVING MULTI COMMITMENT
BECAUSE- A NEW PURPLE DOESN'T
HAVE TO COME BACK TO YOU I DON'T
HAVE TO BE SUBMITTED IN FUTURE
YEARS FOR THE- FUTURE OF YOUR
FUNDING- WE DO THINK THERE ARE
WAYS TO KIND OF ADDRESS THIS
OVERSIGHT ISSUE BY. ENSURING
THAT THERE ARE KIND OF REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO YOU- GOING
FORWARD AND SO YOU CAN HAVE GOOD
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THE
FUNDING IS BEING ROLLED OUT HOW
SUCCESSFUL IT IS. I THINK THE
OTHER COMPARATIVELY IN IT IS. A
KIND OF OUT YOUR GENERAL FUND
PRESSURES AND SO YOU'LL JUST
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THAT AS PART
OF A LARGER BUCKET BUDGET
PACKAGE- I WILL. IN MY- THERE
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU AND COMMITTEE
HOUSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I THINK THAT TECH INCLUDES
ALL OF THE PRESENTATIONS WE HAVE
THIS MORNING WILL MOVE ON TO
QUESTIONS BUT BEFORE WE DO THAT
WILL TAKE ROLE. AND WELCOME.
ARCHER MISTER CHANG HI EVERYBODY
. BLOOM HERE THAT IT. FRIEDMAN
YOUR MULLIN PATTERSON RIVAS
SMITH HERE CHANGE. THERE. ALLOW
ME THAT'S THE FIRST QUESTION-
WHAT ARE WE DOING TO ASSURE
RELIABILITY OF- ALL THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WERE
SPENDING A LOT OF MONEY ON- AND
WILL- SURELY START TO-
OBSOLESCENT NEED MAINTENANCE IN
THE FUTURE WITH THE PLAN FOR
THAT. THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
IT IS AN EXCELLENT QUESTION AND
I RECALL- THEY WILL CAME UP LAST
YEAR TOO AND RIGHTLY SO WE'VE
GOT TO START TAKING ACTION ON
THIS ALREADY- SPENT THE FIRST
PART OF THAT YOUR- RETIREMENT A
LITTLE BIT INTERNALLY AND TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO TACKLE THIS
PROBLEM AND THEN WE HELD A
WORKSHOP- ABSOLUTE TRACK OF TIME
EITHER THIS WEEK OR JUST LAST
WEEK. WE REALLY WANT TO DO A
COUPLE THIRTY THROUGH THE
PROCESS. WE WANT TO ONE DEFINED
WHAT RELIABILITY REALLY NEED.
ANOTHER BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
LAST YEAR. WE'RE GONNA TRACK THE
RELIABILITY OF THE INVESTMENT
FOR THE GENERAL FUND. WE WANT TO
GO BROADER NOT WE ALSO WANT TO
SEE WHAT WE COULD POTENTIALLY DO
BURKE. FUNDED INFRASTRUCTURE
UTILITY FUNDED INFRASTRUCTURE.
EVEN PRIVATE INFRASTRUCTURE. THE
FIRST ONE TO GET A SENSE OF HOW
DO WE DEFINE IT. THROUGH A
PUBLIC PROCESS. AND EFFECTIVELY
HOW DO WE TRACK IT. WE
DEFINITELY WANT TO FIND THE
BALANCE WHERE WE CAN DO IT I
BROUGHT FASHION WHERE WE DON'T
MAKE A REALLY COSTLY. ON THE
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND PRIVATE
MARKET TO PROVIDE. THAT DATA. WE
KNOW WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO WITH
THAT. SO WE'RE GONNA GO THROUGH
THAT PROCESS THAT HERE AND
HOPEFULLY- START GETTING A
BETTER SENSE OF HOW WE CAN AGAIN
TO FIND IT AND TRACK IT. I WILL
PAY FOR THIS LOCATION WE WANT TO
LIVE HERE. WE'RE REQUIRE
REQUIRING NINETY SEVEN PERCENT.
BUT. IN THE LAST. THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS. FRIEDMAN HI GOOD
MORNING AND I WANNA BE- PROBABLY
THE MILLIONTH PERSON TO
CONGRATULATE OUR CHAIR- THIS
MORNING ON BECOMING A GRANDDADDY
I DON'T THINK HE SAID AFTER
MILEY UNDER THAT MASK SINCE I
WALKED IN THE IN THE ROOM AND
THE HIDING MY SMILE SHE- SO GOOD
I. LATER I PROMISE THANK YOU
VERY HAPPY FOR YEARS I'VE GOT
SOME QUESTIONS AND THEY'RE
REALLY FOR WHOEVER WANTS TO
ANSWER ON THE PANEL- THE FIRST
ONE IS. A YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I HAVE A LITTLE
CONCERT FIRST OF ALL I'M I'M
REALLY THRILLED OF- THE GOALS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE GOVERNOR'S-
DESIRE TO REPLACE INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINES WITH ZAPS AND
I. I THINK IT'S THE RIGHT MOVE
THIS IS THE MOMENT WE SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH GAS PRICES WERE.
EXPERIENCING WITH THE REST OF
THE WORLD AS HAD TO DEALWITH
FOR A LONG TIME WHICH IS VERY
HIGH GAS PRICES AND VOLATILITY
THAT'S NOT GOING TO CHANGE- IT'S
YOU KNOW BEEN. GIVING PEOPLE THE
RELIEF OF MOVING INTO A VEHICLE
THAT DOESN'T. RELY ON FOSSIL
FUELS IS A HUGE GIFT TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND WILL
YOU KNOW LONG RUN BE MUCH
HEALTHIER FOR COMMUNITIES FOR.
FOR AIR QUALITY FOR EVERYTHING
ELSE SO THIS IS THIS IS THE
MOMENT AND I'M GLAD TO SEE THAT
WE ARE SEIZING IT. I DO WONDER
ABOUT THE- DECISIONS THAT WE
MAKE IN TERMS OF WHICH THEY HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO FIND I AM
CONCERNED THAT WE MAKE A LOT OF
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT WHERE TO PUT
CHARGING STATIONS FOR INSTANCE
AND HOW PEOPLE ARE GOING TO USE
THEM- DO THEY PREFER TO HAVE IT
IN THERE YOU KNOW IN THEIR
APARTMENT BUILDING OR OR AT
WORK. OR AT TARGET. I RETAIL
NEUTRAL AT. LARGE STORE. THAT
THEY GO TO A LOT- DO THEY YOU
KNOW IT IF WE PUT IT IN AN
APARTMENT BUILDING WHAT HAPPENS
THEN TO. YOU KNOW IS THE
BUILDINGS CAN IT CAN THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORTED. DO
THEY TURN AROUND AND CHARGE THAT
RESIDENT A LOT OF MONEY TO USE
IT- DOES A BIG DO WE CREATE
STRANDED ASSETS- YOU KNOW HOW
MUCH OF THE SHOULD BE PUBLIC HOW
MUCH SHOULD BE PRIVATE- ALL OF
THOSE SORTS OF QUESTIONS SO MY
QUESTION IS. YOU'RE CERTAINLY WE
CAN'T ANSWER ALL OF THOSE BUT WE
CAN THINK A LOT ABOUT THEM AND
HAVE A STRATEGY SO MY QUESTION
IS. WHAT HOW O WE DEVELOP THIS
ROAD MAP WHO'S SORT OF IN CHARGE
OF MAKING THE DECISIONS. DO WE
HAVE A ROBUST GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS THAT INCLUDES THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO. MOVE THESE
CHARGERS INTO MORE AGGRESSIVELY
ARE WE LISTENING TO THEM
DIRECTLY ABOUT THEIR NEEDS OR
ARE WE MAKING ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT
WHAT WOULD BE THE MOST
CONVENIENT TO THEM. OR WHAT
WOULD SPUR. THEIR SWITCHED TO US
HAVE SO- THAT'S MY FIRST
QUESTION IS HOW ARE THESE HOW
ARE THE CITING. AND THE FUNDING
DECISIONS BEING MADE AT THE
STATE LEVEL. AND AT THE END AND
DO WE FEEL THAT A CONFIDENT
ENOUGH THAT IT'S A ROBUST ENOUGH
GROUP OF. PEOPLE AND DO WE HAVE
METRICS SO THAT WE CAN COURSE
CORRECT QUICKLY IF WE DECIDE
THAT WE ARE. PUTTING A LOT OF
MONEY INTO INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
NOT IT BEING UNDER UTILIZED.
THAT THAT'S NOT A GREAT
QUESTION- PART OF OUR ANALYSIS
THAT THAT GOES INTO THAT IF IT
FROM THE TOOL OF THE LEGISLATURE
GIVEN OUT THOUGH. AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN HAS BEEN A REALLY
POWERFUL TOOL FOR US. AND ALSO
SENATE BILL ONE THOUSAND AND HOW
WE SITE INFRASTRUCTURE. AND WE
ALWAYS WANT TO FIND A BALANCE
WE'RE NOT BEING OVERLY
PRESCRIPTIVE BUT ALSO GIVEN SOME
DIRECTION. BOND SO WHETHER KELLY
B. I. P. PROGRAM FOR INSTANCE.
WE USE MODELING TO TARGET WITH A
LARGER CAPS ARE. FROM WHERE WE
SEE VEHICLE- PROLIFERATING AND
THAT ALSO WERE EXPECTED TO COME.
IN WITH A LOWER LEVEL OF
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO WE TARGET
GAPS IN THAT WAY- YEAH ONE THING
I'VE LEARNED IS THAT NO ONE HAS
ALL THE ANSWERS TO THOSE. AND WE
NEED TO EMPOWER THE PRIVATE
MARKET. ATTENTION WE WANT TO
MAKE A HAND UP TO THE PRIVATE
MARKET. WE ALSO WANT TO SET.
TARGETS SO FOR OUR FUNDING WE
HAVE A 50% MINIMUM FOR A LARGE
NUMBER NOT THAT THE MUST GOT
DOCTOR LOW INCOME. SUBSIDY 50%
ON THE MEDIUM DUTY HEAVY DUTY
SIDE. HERE BUT FOR THE. PLANNING
PROCESS GOES. WE'LL OF WORKSHOPS
. WE TAKE A LOT OF INPUT- I
THINK AS WE MOVE. TO FULLY HAN
PERCENT VERY MUCH. WE ARE THAT
RISK OF STRANDED ON. DOES AT
MINIMUM BECAUSE WE KNOW EVERY-
WHO. OR OPERATES CAR. IS GOING%
TO NEED. A PLACE TO CHARGE. WITH
AT HOME CHARGING THE THING THAT
I REALLY LIKE ABOUT IT IN OUR
SYSTEM AND DATA SHOWED THAT. IS
THAT- IF IT'S CHEAPER FUEL COSTS
FOR MOST PEOPLE. THE RESIDENTIAL
TERRAPIN RATES ARE CHEAPER THAN
THE- COMMERCIAL INDUSTRIAL HAVE
DEMAND CHARGES. SO WE REALLY
WANT TO BE ABLE TO MAKE. IT
CHEAPER FOR FOLKS TO DO IT
INCLUDING THOSE M. U. D. RENTERS
- BOTH HOMES AND APARTMENTS. WE
ALSO IT'S MORE CONVENIENT IT IS
LIKE A CELL PHONE ON THAT PHONE
WHEN YOU PLUG IT IN AT NIGHT.
YOU HAVE IT ALL DAY TOP RATE AND
I WORRIED ABOUT FINDING A PLACE
TO FUEL. IS ALSO WHAT MARGARET
FRIENDLY. WE TO DEPLOY LOW TWO
CHARGE. FOR THE STUDY INSTEAD OF
TO RELY HEAVILY ON. FIVE
STARTERS. WE KNOW WE NEED BOTH
OF THOSE- BUT REALLY WANTED. AT
HOME TARGET ONE MORE WHERE THAT
MAKE SENSE. AND WE HAVE A-
WELDER PASTA. PART OF IT IS
DESIGNED. WHICH ALLOW PARTIES.
TO IMPLEMENT ON OUR BEHALF
BECAUSE WE WE'RE NOT ALL THE
AND- SEVEN SEVEN. THAT MAY BE.
TO DATE ORDER. I THE VA. FOR
OTHER PARTY HELP THE PLAN THAT
FUNDING. THANK YOU I'M- I'M ALSO
WONDERING WHETHER YOU WHETHER-
CARB OR- YOU KNOW I WHO WERE OR
ANY OF THE OTHER AGENCIES ARE
LOOKING AT REMOVING SOME OF THE
BARRIERS TO COMMERCIAL CHARGING
AND SO I HEAR A LOT FROM VARIOUS
CHARGING COMPANIES THAT ARE
LOOKING TO INSTALL CHARGING
STATIONS AND THEY BRING UP A LOT
OF BARRIERS THAT WOULD THAT ARE
PREVENTING THEM FROM- FROM DOING
INFRASTRUCTURE WORK THAT WE WANT
YOU KNOW FROM THE FROMTHE
PRIVATE SECTOR SIDE AND I'LL
JUST NAME A FEW OF THOSE- ONE OF
THEM I'VE HEARD IS. HAS TO DO
WITH THE- NEED TO UPGRADE-
SUBSTATIONS A LOT OF TIMES I ONE
OF THEM TALKED ABOUT HOW THEY
NEED TO A SUBSTATION UPGRADE FOR
A LARGE CHARGING STATION THEY
WANTED TO FIND ON THEIR OWN TIME
MAYBE EVEN USING SOME STATE
INCENTIVES- BUT- THE UTILITY
THAT THEY WERE DEALING WITH.
SAID THAT THEIR TIME LINE TO
GIVE THE APPROVALS WAS TWO
YEARS. SO THEY'VE BEEN WAITING
NOW FOR OVER A YEAR THEY SAID
THERE'S NO. YOU KNOW. NO IDEA
WHEN THEY'RE GOING TO ACTUALLY
HAVE THE SUBSTATION OPERATED.
AND SO FORTH YOU KNOW THAT'S A
HUGE BARRIER- TO EVEN TO ROLLING
OUT THE FUNDING THAT WE WANT-
ANOTHER ONE TALKED ABOUT HOW-
EVEN THOUGH DURING THE DAY. THE
PRICE FOR THE POWER IS NOMINAL
WE'VE GOT YOU KNOW A TON OF
RENEWABLES ON THE GRID AND YET
THEY'RE BEING CHARGED PEAK
PRICES. IN THE MIDDLE OF THE DAY
ARE FOR THE POWER THAT THEY USE.
AND SO THEY HAVE TO PASS THAT
ALONG TO THEIR THEIR USERS. SO
I'M WONDERING WHETHER WE'RE IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE ALL OF
THE VARIOUS UTILITIES WHO ARE IN
SOME WAYS THE GATEKEEPERS THE
ELECTRICITY THAT WE'RE USING FOR
THESE VEHICLES. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR POLICIES ARE ALIGNING
WITH OUR GOALS YOU KNOW AND ALSO
THROW INTO THAT. THE POSSIBILITY
OF ALL THESE EV'S BEING USED AS
GRID RESILIENCY YOU KNOW. WITH
THE POSSIBILITY WITH TECHNOLOGY
ALLOWING THEM TO FEED ENERGY
BACK INTO THOSE PRIVATE
RESIDENCES WHEN POWER'S BEEN TO
BEEN- TURNED OFF BECAUSE OF
WILDFIRE OR OTHER OR HIGH WIND
EVENTS. AT THE END THE
RELUCTANCE AND SEEMS OF THE
UTILITIES TO OVER TO HELP.
PEOPLE TO INSTALL BATTERY
STORAGE TO DO EXACTLY THAT SO
WHAT WHERE IS THE UTILITY TIÞN
AND HOW RECEPTIVE HAVE YOU BEEN
TO HELPING TO BE IN DISCUSSIONS
TO REMOVE THE BARRIERS TO.
FURTHER YOU KNOW FURTHER
DEPLOYMENT OF ALL OF THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE. I KNOW THAT WAS
A BIG QUESTION WITH A LOT OF
EXAMPLES BUT THIS IS THE KIND OF
THING I HEAR ALL THE TIME. FROM
COMPANIES THAT ARE TRYING TO DO
CHARGING IN SAYING WE HAVE THE
MONEY WE HAVE THE CAPITAL WE
CAN'T. BUILD THESE RIGHT NOW
THERE'S JUST TOO MANY BARRIERS.
TIMELINE'S PERMITTING COST OF
USE NOT HAVING- DEMAND PRICING
ALL OF THAT. I BELIEVE THAT-
DIRECTOR CAR BUT- I KNOW THE
ENERGY COMMISSION- HOW LONG THIS
CONVERSATION THE CORRECT I DO
WANT TO TAKE THE PLUNGE. I THINK
THAT MAKES THE MOST SENSE I CAN
JUMP IN WITH ANYTHING ELSE. OKAY
GREAT- AND I CAN SPEAK A LITTLE
BIT PLEASE TELL THE FACT TO
OFFEND A LEVIN YEARS- AT A
CALIFORNIA TELL THE BEFORE
JOINING STATE SERVICE. AND YOU
KNOW YOU'RE RIGHT I THINK THERE
IS A REAL CONCERN ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT THE UTILITIES ARE ABLE
TO DEPLOY THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
AHEAD OF IT- I WORRY MORE
FRANKLY ON THE MEDIUM DUTY HEAVY
DUTY SIDE. BUT ALSO WHEN YOU
HAVE A LARGE BANK VIDAK HERDERS.
SOME OF THAT PLANNING HAPPENS
NATURALLY YOU KNOW BE IT FOR
ANYTHING. NO NEED CITY
DEVELOPMENTS THE APARTMENT THE
CONDO REALLY ANYTHING. BUT WE
FIGURED POCKETS WE NEED TO GET
HAD ABOUT. WANTING. TO-
DEPRESSION AND DOING. HAVE WE
STARTED AGE. A THANK. PRETTY
EARLY DAYS THE IT AND WE'RE
WAITING A POLICY REALLY TRY TO
FRAME IT AND SEE HOW IT FITS.
WITH OTHER RAPPERS. WE WANTED A
LITTLE OF AN EARLY WARNING
SYSTEM. SO WE KNOW WE'RE THE
VEHICLES ARE COMING WHERE THE
CHARGING STATIONS ARE COMING.
AND HOW WE CAN COMMUNICATE WITH
OUR HYPER DEMAND FORECASTS. AND
OTHER- IF YOU SEE HOW TO FOR
CAPITAL PROJECT- AND HOW CAN WE
REALLY LOOK AT THE DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEM. YOU CAN BY AND LARGE A
LOT OF THE CONCERNED WE'RE
HEARING COULD NOT SO MUCH THE
STATEWIDE SYSTEM. IT REALLY THAT
DIFFERENT DISTRIBUTION CIRCUIT.
WHICH MIGHT BE NEARING CAPACITY
LIMITS. ON WHAT THEY THOUGHT
THEM DOWN. YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT YOU KNOW WE ALSO HAVE THE
INTERCONNECTION AND PLUMMETING.
OUR TWO THINGS THAT CAUSE DELAYS
AND COSTS BOB BECAUSE- ANOTHER
SOMETHING WE'RE LOOKING TO GET-
OUR ARMS WRAPPED AROUND A LITTLE
BIT BETTER- BUT IT TOOK A LOT OF
MONEY THAT ALREADY OCCURRED BUT
I THINK WE GET SHARPER. SHARPEN
OUR PENCILS. ON THOSE SPECIFIC
DISTRIBUTION OR PETER AND TAX-
BUT EVERY CONDUCTOR IN THE WIND. OR SUBSTATION- PIECES. I KNOW
. ON THE RATE. ALL THREE OF THE
LARGE I USE HAS IT. THAT I
BELIEVE THE P. HAVE THE PER. THE
NEW- RATED NINETY. ONE OF THEM.
THAT I MITIGATE REDUCING DEMAND
FOR A PERIOD OF TIME. BUT THE
DEMAND FOR OF COME BACK AND
OVERTIME. AND THEN ON THE LAST
COMPONENT- ABOUT BI DIRECTIONAL.
THAT'S SOMETHING ELSE WE'RE
LOOKING TO TACKLE WE THIS IS I
HEARD THAT ONE OF THE TELL THE
I'VE HEARD IT ON THE SIDE OF IT
AS WELL. IS THAT THERE ARE
UTILITIES ARE HESITANT TO
CONNECT. SOME BI DIRECTIONAL
CHARGER AND LEFT IT ON THE
EQUIVALENT. OF THE SOLAR
INVERTER LIST. AND THAT WAS
SOMETHING CREATED FOR SOLAR-
SEVERAL YEARS AGO TO MAKE SURE
WE GOT. OLDER INTERCONNECTS
OKAY. SO I WOULDN'T FEEL THE
TRANSPORTATION WERE LOOKING TO
CREATE A COROLLARY TO THAT
PROVIDE DIRECTIONAL PARKER. WHAT
SPECIFICALLY THE INVERTER ON A
CHARGER SO WE CAN DO BI
DIRECTIONAL FUNCTIONALITY- I
BELIEVE TEACHING YOU HAVE BEEN
PRETTY PROGRESS MILITARIA. DAY
IN FLORIDA JUST HAD AN
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT THEY'RE GONNA
GAPS- FORD F. ONE FIFTY-
LIGHTNING. OUT THERE TO HELP
MITIGATE THE PF YET THE BAND.
BECAUSE THE GREAT THING ABOUT
ELECTRIC VEHICLE THAT I THINK
YOU KNOW IT BECAUSE OF THE
QUESTION ABOUT. IT THAT THE IT
COULD PROVIDE ONSITE RESILIENCY
IN A WAY THAT A GAS VEHICLE
NEVER CRIED. YEAH A FORD F. ONE
FIFTY. SIX SEVEN YEAR EIGHTY
KILOWATT HOUR CAPACITY BATTERY.
COULD PROVIDE ENERGY FOR THREE
DAYS. AND OTHER EVENTS SO THAT
REAL THE TOPIC TODAY IS NOT THE
FUTURE OF THE BANK. BUT THEY'RE
STILL BARRIERS. WE WANT TO
TACKLE. AND ADDITION TO THAT BY
DIRECTIONAL WILL LOOK TO CREATE.
ONE OF OUR SISTER- IT'S FUNDING
COULD BE A CALL THE BILL. FOR
THE TASTE. I BELIEVE THAT SOME
OF CORPORATE OF THAT WE'RE
DOING- YOU KNOW EVERYTHING YOU
CAN THINK TO MAKE THAT. AND
MORE. AND ALWAYS OF MORE I OF
HOW TACKLE BARRIERS. I THINK
THAT REALLY COVERS FIELD FOR.
GIVEN HOW. ON EDUCATION IT'S ON
ALL OF THESE FRIENDS THANK YOU
THE ALL I'LL ADD. ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS THAT WE WERE WORKING AND
WITH SUCH WITH FLEETS HEAVY DUTY
FLEETS WOULD YOU WORK WITH THEM
TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE ALSO
WORKING ON INFRASTRUCTURE
PLANNING AND CONNECTING WITH
FOLKS SAID WE HAVE A REALLY GOOD
PARTNERSHIP ACROSS. THIS FRONT
AND WE'VE BEEN. REALLY GRATEFUL
FOR ALL THE SAID STATEWIDE
PLANNING EFFORTS THAT EDUCATION
YOU TO THE COMMISSION TYSON
OTHERS ARE CONTRIBUTING. THANKS
FOR BACK. OF THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF CHAIR BLOOM AT THE
FIRST THING I'D LIKE TO SAY IS A
HEDGE ADD SOME COMMENTS HERE
LATER BUT I'M GONNA DO THIS NOW
THEY FOLLOW UP ON THE CHAIR OF
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEES-
ACTUALLY QUESTIONS- AND- I WANT
TO ADD TO THOSE IN MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE PORCH THE
PORCH- SOME OF THE PORT PEOPLE
I'VE TALKED TO DON'T HAVE A LOT
OF CONFIDENCE THAT WHEN THEY
ELECTRIFY THE WHOLE PORT THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE ENOUGH-
DELIVERY OF POWER- FROM. FROM
THE GRID- FOR WHAT THEY NEED-
AND- SO THINK OF ALL OF THE
POSSIBILITIES SAID- WE JUST
HEARD DARE YOU KNOW WHICH WAY
ARE WE GONNA BE ABLE TO FEED
POWER BACK IN THERE SO MANY
THERE'S SO MANY COMPLICATING
THINGS HERE I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE- THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION- INVOLVED IN MAKING
SURE THAT- WE HAVE A COORDINATED
PLAN- BUT THAT LEADS ME TO ONE
OF MY CONCERNS AND THAT IS WHEN
YOU HAVE DIVIDED RESPONSIBILITY
OF THE CPUC HERE. YEAH THIS
ENERGY COMMISSION YOU HAVE THE
ADMINISTRATION WHEN YOU HAVE
DIVIDED RESPONSIBILITY THERE'S A
IT REALLY IS HARD TO HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE ACCOUNTABILITY TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE A COORDINATED
PLAN GOING FORWARD- AND WE HAVE
DIVIDED RESPONSIBILITY BY THE
NATURE OF THE LIVES OF THE WAY
WE'VE SET UP- DEMOCRACIES IN THE
COUNTRY AND CRITICALLY WHAT WHAT
WE HAVE HERE- IN CALIFORNIA AND
IT REMINDS ME OF THAT OF THE
CLASSIC- WHEN I WAS DOING MY
STUDENT TEACHING AND S. AS IN A
STUDENT TEACHER ASKED TO SAID.
SO HOW DO YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'RE
PREPARED ENOUGH AND THE RESPONSE
WAS YOU YOU'RE NEVER YOU CAN
NEVER HAVE TO COMPLETE OF A PLAN
AS MUCH TIME AS YOU HAVE AS MUCH
ENERGY AS YOU CAN PLAN AND KEEP
PLANNING THEIR IT THERE'S MORE
TO IT THAN AND I WOULD OFFER-
THAT WHEN WE. NEED A CONCERTED
EFFORT- OF EVERYBODY COMING
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
PLAN AND THE PLAN WILL HAVE TO
BE AN ADAPTIVE MANAGEMENT PLAN
AS THINGS CHANGE. BUT I AM
CONCERNED THAT WE DON'T HAVE ALL
OF THE- ALL OF THE COORDINATION
THAT WE NEED TO GO FORWARD AS
ROOM AS FOR MAKING THESE BIG
INVESTORS. SO WITH THAT- OVERALL
I WANT TO COMPLIMENT- THE
ADMINISTRATION THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND CARB- FOR THIS
PRESENTATION I THINK THAT'S IT
THIS IS A VERY GOOD START. A
VERY GOOD COMPLEMENT TO THE
EFFORTS THAT HAVE HAVE HAVE
ALREADY BEEN MADE- GOING
FORWARD- I HAVE MANY QUESTIONS
HERE. BUT I DON'T NEED LONG
ANSWERS TO ALL OF THAT SO WHAT I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THERE
USUALLY JUST SHORT
CLARIFICATIONS SO- AND- I WOULD
APPRECIATE IF WE CAN KEEP. OF
THE ANSWERS AS BRIEF SO THAT- I
CAN GET THROUGH THESE QUESTIONS
AND- I'M GONNA BE ON- I'M ON
PAGE. TEN OF THE- FOR A- OUR ON
PAGE OF THE OF THE DOCUMENT-
THERE'S A REFERENCE TO- THE
THREE HUNDRED KILOWATT OR HIRE A
DIRECT CURRENT FAST CHARGERS
AND- I'VE BEEN CALCULATING-
BASED ON THE- THE INFORMATION ON
ON PAGE FOURTEEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FIVE THOUSAND DC
FAST CHARGERS- THAT WORKS OUT
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A CHARGE IS THAT WHAT-
THE ENERGY COMMISSION THINKS IS
THE- COST OF THE THREE HUNDRED
KILOWATT OR HIGHER- DC FAST
CHARGERS. I BELIEVE OUR PORTION
WILL BE SOMEWHERE IN THE EIGHTY
TO A HUNDRED THOUSAND PER
CHARGER WERE ALSO LOOKING TO
FIND- GREAT MEDICATION EFFORT
FOR THAT IT COULD BE- SOME OF
THAT DELTA FUNDING COULD GO
THROUGH TO THINGS LIKE CONSERVE
ENERGY STORED ALL THE AUTOMATED
LOAD MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THERE ARE
OTHER THINGS TO BALANCE THE LOAD
FOR YOU TO HAVE A REALLY HIGH
GREAT IMPACT BUT THE PTSD PEAK
WOULD BE ABOUT 829-200-1000
DOLLARS PER CHARGE. FOR THE.
THREE HUNDRED KILOWATT FAST
CHARGERS. SEKARANG AND WE EXPECT
THE PRIVATE. SIDE PICK UP THE
REST SO JUST TO. THE LEVEL TWO
CHARGERS HAVE BEEN A AND HAVE
BEEN GETTING A AN AVERAGE
INCENTIVE OF A HUNDRED THOUSAND.
SO HOW WOULD WE BE GOING TO
THREE HUNDRED KILOWATTS WITHOUT
IT COSTING MORE. SO THE LEVEL
TWO CHARGERS IS ABOUT FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER CHARGER ON
THE PUBLIC SIDE ABOUT TWELVE
THOUSAND TOTAL WHEN YOU FACTOR
IN THE PRIVATE INVESTMENT THERE-
RIGHT NOW ARE FIFTY TO SEVENTY
FIVE K. W. CHARTERED WHAT
PUTTING IN ABOUT. FIFTY TO
SEVENTY THOUSAND HER PARTNER FOR
ABOUT ALL RIGHT THANK YOU- MY
NEXT QUESTION IS- THE THREE
HUNDRED NINETY MILLION IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE PAGE GENERAL FUND
TO DEPLOY INFRASTRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT ONE THOUSAND- DRY AGE
TRUCKS AND SIXTEEN HUNDRED
TRANSIT BUSES. IN SOME PLACES
THERE'S A REFERENCE TO THIS ALL
B. THESE ALL BEING ELECTRIC ARE
THESE TRANSIT BUSES GOING TO ALL
BE ELECTRIC. OR IS IT GOING TO
BE- TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL IN TERMS
OF THE SIZE OF TRANSIT BUSES.
OUR INVESTMENTS ARE GENERALLY
TECH NEUTRAL SO WE TALK ABOUT
THE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES YOU
MEAN BATTERY AND FUEL CELL.
THURMOND INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE
PERPETRATED FROM THE- I COULDN'T
UNDERSTAND THIS TWO ANSWERS JUST
IN TERMS OF CLARITY COULD CALL
SAY THAT AGAIN SO WHEN SOMETIMES
PEOPLE USE ELECTRIC AS A
SHORTHAND FOR BATTERY. BUT
THAT'S NOT THE INTENTION HERE SO
THIS IS FOR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES WHICH COULD BE BATTERY
VEHICLES OR FUEL CELL VEHICLES
BOTH HER ELECTRIC IN THE FOURTH
FOR THE BUSES AND FOR THE
DRAYAGE TRUCKS YES THANK YOU
THANK YOU OKAY- AND THEN THE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION IN THE
GENERAL FUND FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
FURS HAVE TRUCKS BUSES AND OFF
ROAD EQUIPMENT. COULD COULD
SOMEBODY JUST TO BRIEFLY
ELABORATE HOW WILL THAT BE IF
WILL THAT BE ALLOCATED BASED ON
GRANT FUNDING- LIKE MANY OF THE
OTHER PROGRAMS. AND THIS IS THIS
IS FROM THE ENERGY COMMISSION'S
SEGMENT OF THE PRESENTATION SO.
YES THAT'S CORRECT- COMPETITIVE
GRANT FUNDING THAT CAN GO UP TO
ELECTRIC AND HYBRID GREAT THANK
YOU AND THIS IS A UNDER THE CARB
AND C. E. C. SEGMENT THERE IS A
STATEMENT THERE. JUST TWO
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND FOR EMERGING OPPORTUNITIES-
AND THEN IT MAKES A REFERENCE AT
THE VERY END OF THAT- FIRST
PARAGRAPH SAYS. AS WELL AS
SUPPORT VEHICLE GRID INTEGRATION
AT SCALE. COULD SOMEBODY CLARIFY
WHAT VEHICLE GRID INTEGRATION AT
SCALE MEANS. BUT CERTAINLY- SO
THAT WOULD GO TO THE ENERGY
COMMISSION PORTION OF IT AND-
WE'RE SEEING SOME REALLY GREAT
IN THE VEHICLE GRID INTEGRATION.
THAT COULD BE ANYTHING FROM
REDUCING THE POWER OF THE
TURKEY. AFTER THE MATCH NOT
ALWAYS AND I EXCUSE THEM AND ASK
YOU TO START OVER AGAIN I'M NOT
ABLE FALL THAT YOUR HAVE YOUR
MOUSE IS NOT MATCHED UP WITH
YOUR SECOND IF YOU COULD. JUST
SPEAK A LITTLE MORE SLOWLY I
THINK THAT'LL HELP- I APOLOGIZE
ABOUT THAT- SO VEHICLE GRID
INTEGRATION IS. INTEGRATING NEW
VEHICLE LOAD WITH THE GRAND IN A
RESPONSIBLE MANNER. A LOT OF
TIMES PEOPLE THINK ABOUT BI
DIRECTIONAL FOR THAT. IT CAN
ALSO BE A SIMPLER THINGS LIKE
RATE DESIGN. FOR REDUCING THE
LOAD OF A CHARGING STATION. IN
RESPONSE TO A GREAT SIGNAL. SO
THAT INVESTMENT WILL GO TO
LARGER SEGMENT WTHIN BGI. ONE
SEGMENT WOULD BE TO HELP PUSH
OUT- SMART CHARGER BIDIRECTIONAL
CHARGERS. AND METERING
EQUIPMENT. THE OTHER PORTION TO
GO TOWARD- HELPING STAND UP AND
THE POWER OF THE THIRD PARTY
AGGREGATORS. CHIU THAT MAKE A%
VERY SEAMLESS CONSUMER
EXPERIENCE. CAMINO THE PEOPLE
WILL NOT ADOPT THIS UNLESS
THERE'S GOOD AUTOMATION. AND A
GOOD CONSUMER EXPERIENCE. THE-
VEHICLE GRID INTEGRATION. THANK
YOU I I'LL FOLLOW UP WITH YOU-
MORE ON THAT OUR OF YEAR- FOR
THE- ON PAGE THIRTEEN FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR SEVEN FOR STRUCTURE
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION.
EIGHTY THREE MILLION FOR AND IN
TERMS OF FEDERAL FUNDS- THE THIS
IS. THIS GOING TO BE
INFRASTRUCTURE ON THE
INTERSTATES- AND- DO WE HAVE
PLANS YET IN TERMS OF HOW WE'RE
GOING TO ALLOCATE THIS ON THE
INTERSTATE IN ON THE
INTERSTATES- AND IN TERMS OF
MOVING FORWARD. YES WHERE THE
SHORT ANSWER IS WE'RE STARTING
TO BE A LONGER ANSWER IS WE JUST
GOT FEDERAL GUIDANCE ABOUT A
MONTH AGO OKAY AND WE'RE WORKING
BANERJEE COMMISSION AND CALTRANS
THE CALIFORNIA WILL SUBMIT A
PLAN TO THE FED LATER THIS
SUMMER BUT THE INTENT IS TO
FOCUS ON THE OFFICE YORK FEEL
CORRIDORS. THANK YOU AND- IN
TERMS OF- THERE DESERVES
REFERENCE ON PAGE SIXTEEN IN
TERMS OF- SOME OF THE FUNDING-
AT THE VERY TOP OF THE PAGE
MIGHT BE PILOT PROJECTS. SOME OF
THE FUNDING MIGHT BE FOR
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROGRAMS-
AND- ALSO- IT ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION EXETER. THIS IS A
QUESTION OF FACT I THINK
PROBABLY FOR A COMBINATION OF
CARBONI ENERGY COMMISSION- AND
ANYBODY ELSE IT MAY HAVE THAT
BUT ON THE TEN FREEWAY NOW AS
WE'RE GOING DOWN YOU KNOW WE SEE
THAT MASS TRANSIT. EFFORT THERE
WITH THE TROLLEY IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE- IN IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
LANES. DO WE HAVE ANY ANALYSIS
OF HOW WELL THAT IS WORKING-
I'M- BUT I'M VERY COMMITTED AS
MANY OF US ARE HERE TO TRYING TO
IMPROVE PASSED TRANSIT. I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN WE
MAKE THOSE INVESTMENTS WE
ACTUALLY YOU'RE MAKING AND THEN
AND THINGS THAT ARE GOING TO
WORK- MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THERE'S CONCERNS ABOUT THAT AND
IS THERE ANY ANALYSIS BEING DONE
AS TO. THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THAT
AND WHAT ARE THE LESSONS LEARNED
FOR US TO MAKE MASS TRANSIT-
OTHER OUR OTHER MASS TRANSIT
INVESTMENTS OF THIS ARE THERE
AFFECTED. YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THE TROLLEY SPECIFICALLY
ALTHOUGH YOU KNOW ASKED ABOUT
THAT AND MATCHING CALTRANS
ACOSTA MANAGEMENT SITES ON THE
GENERAL POINT WE DO TRACK REALLY
CLOSELY HOW THESE TRANSPORTATION
VESTMENTS WORK IN PRACTICE SO
YOU KNOW HOW DOES THAT CHANGE
COMMITTEE BEHAVIOR AND WE SEE
WHO'S EXCEPT FOR A- AND THAT IS
THE FOCUS. OKAY THANK YOU. OF
THE- L. A. O. IS BROUGHT UP THE
CONCERN ABOUT- THE FOUR YEAR
FUNDING- UP FRONT- TWO THINGS
THAT- JUST LIKE TO PASS ON TO
THE CHAIR HERE OF THE COMMITTEE
I. I'VE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
SUGGESTION THAT- AT LEAST TEN
MILLION DOLLARS OF THE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX MILLION FOR
LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS- SHOULD BE
FOR TO FUND BATTERY REPLACEMENT-
BECAUSE- I THINK THAT- MY
EXPERIENCES SOME LOW INCOME
PEOPLE ARE VERY ATTRACTED TO
BUYING THESE CARS BECAUSE OF
THEIR LOW OPERATION- AND IT'S
THE BATTERY THAT. IS THE ONE
THING IT BUT THEY CAN BY USED-
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND IF THEY
CAN REPLACE THAT BATTERY SO I
THINK THAT COULD BE A GREAT
INVESTMENT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. YEAH I'D LIKE IT IF
I COULD JUST INNER JACKSON TO
MENTION MY NAME- I AGREE WITH
YOU AND AS THE OWNER OF A- TWO
THOUSAND FOR. A PRIUS THAT JUST
KEEPS ON ROLLING-I KNOW THAT IT
A CERTAIN POINT- THAT BATTERY'S
GONNA NEED TO BE REPLACED AND
IT'S AN EXPENSIVE. A PROPOSITION
FOR ANYONE BUT PARTICULARLY FOR
A LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS YEAH
GREAT THANK YOU- AND- THEN MY-
OTHER QUICK QUESTIONS AS BEST AS
I CAN MAKE THEM HERE- IS THERE
WILL THERE BE A PART OF THE
PROGRAM OUTSIDE OF WHAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW WILL BE PART OF THE
PROGRAM THAT WILL TRY TO GET THE
OLDER MORE POLLUTING VEHICLES
OFF OF THE ROAD- WITH OUR- WITH
OUR INCENTIVE PROGRAMS. A YES
SIR SO MANY OF THE THAT LIKE THE
VEHICLES YOU ARE SCRAPPING YOUR
OLD VEHICLE IF YOU GET INTO AN
EASY SO THAT HELPS DRIVE
TURNOVER AND MANY OF OUR OTHER
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS HAVE SIMILAR
COMPONENTS THAT SCRAPPAGE
REQUIREMENTS CAN VARY BY PROGRAM
IS THAT I ALWAYS COMPONENT THAT
OFTEN IS IN THE TRIED MAKE PASTA
VESTMENTS BOTH THINKING ABOUT
WAYS TO. HELP PLEASE TURN OVER
AND HAVE PEOPLE AT STUFF THANK
YOU AND I THINK THIS QUESTION
JUST FOR CC- N. AND THAT IS UP
UP TILL NOW WE'VE ALREADY
ALLOCATED STATIONS COULD JUST
WHAT IS THE CRITERIA THAT HAVE
BEEN USED FOR CHOOSING THE
LOCATION OF THE STATIONS BOTH
THE HYDROGEN REFUELING STATIONS
AND- THE ELECTRIC. CHARGING
STATIONS- OF FOR THE ELECTRIC
FEELING STATIONS WE OFTEN USE
OUR AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN
ANALYSIS PRIOR TO THAT WE USED A
TOOL CALLED EVR CROW. CHU TARGET
GAPS IN INFRASTRUCTURE NETWORK
OKAY BUT WE ALSO WILL DESIGNED
FOR PATIENTS THAT TARGET AREAS
LIKE RURAL. OR ENTITIES AS WELL.
ON THE HIDE ON THE HUNDRED SIDE-
WE ALSO USE A LOT OF DATA AND
ANALYSIS. WE ACTUALLY PARTNER
WITH CARBON THEY HAVE A TOOL
CALLED THE CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE TOOL WHICH IS A
PRETTY NEAT ARCGIS MAPPING
SYSTEM THAT SHOWS WHERE ALL THE
TROUBLE. HUNDRED FIFTY THIRD.
AND WE- THE ARE SPLIT. YOUR
TARGET IN TWENTY FIFTH. WE
ENCOURAGE THE- PROPOSED A THE
COR MARKET AREA. LEADING FEELING
UP THE STRUCTURE AND THEN OUR
TWENTY NINETEEN BUT THE PATIENT
WHO DID SOMETHING SIMILAR WE
DONE FIVE ELIGIBLE AREAS WHERE
APPLICANTS TO PROPOSED STATION
LOCATIONS. THANK YOU OF A AND-
PRETTY CLOSE TO FINISHED HERE- I
HAVE- THERE'S FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS SUPPORT
ELECTRIFICATION- I NOTICE- ON
PAGE THIRTEEN THERE'S A
REFERENCE TO- PORCH AND THERE'S
NO FUNDING. DOLLARS IN THERE-
UNDER THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO PACKAGE A SO
ARE WE NOT COUNTING THE FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS SUPPORT
ELECTRIFICATION- AS PART OF- THE
EFFORTS THAT WE PUT UNDER
SUMMARY OF APPROVED AND PROPOSED
A- OKAY THAT'S- THAT'S BECAUSE
IT'S DESERVE PACKAGES
SPECIFICALLY RIGHT OKAY I'VE
NEVER NEVER MIND I'LL WITHDRAW
THAT QUESTION. AND THEN FINALLY
I DO HAVE- CONCERNS ABOUT TRYING
TO EXPAND THE HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE- AND- THE TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE INTERSTATE
QUARTERS THE FREIGHT QUARTERS-
HAVE HYDROGEN SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
BUY FOR EACH- AS THEY MOVE
FORWARD- WITH THAT WITH THESE
DECISIONS AND STUFF. AND SO- I
JUST WANT TO. LET THE ENERGY
COMMISSION NO I'VE I WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT-
PLANNING FOR THE FUTURE WITH
THOSE HYDROGEN WITH THE HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED THANK YOU CHAIR
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR DID YOU
WANNA. THE QUESTION AND NOT AT
ALL THE SOUND IN THIS ROOM- JUST
APPEARS TO ME THAT YEAH I CAN'T
I CAN'T COME WORSE- WITH EVERY
SUCCESSIVE MEETING THAT WE HAVE
YEAH I UNFORTUNATELY WHAT
HAPPENED WITNESSES BACK IN THE
BUILDING AND I THINK THAT I
THINK THAT WOULD BE GREAT ADULT-
IF WE NEED TO WE SHOULD MOVE TO
ANOTHER. IF IT'S POSSIBLE I KNOW
THAT THERE WERE JUGGLING SOME
NEW- MEETING ROOMS MAYBE WE CAN
MOVE THIS HEARING TO A DIFFERENT
ROOM AND IF YOU ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR HERE.
THANK YOU MISS CHAIR SO. JUST A
- COUPLE. ONE WAS. I KNOW IT'S
NOT AN ITEM DIRECTLY ON THE
AGENDA THE JUST ON THE CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATE PROGRAM I KNOW
THAT WE DID THAT FUNDING OVER
THE LAST- THAN LAST YEAR IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET- AND OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS. BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING WAS THE INCOME
GUIDELINES WERE CHANGED A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO COULD SOMEONE FROM-
ERR THEIR BOARD JUST KIND OF
WALK US THROUGH WHAT THOSE
CHANGES ARE WHAT THE THINKING
WAS. YES MISTER CHAIR SO THESE
ARE CHANGES THAT WERE VETTED IN
THE FUNDING PLAN PROCESS OVER
THE LAST YEAR IN APPROVEDBY THE
BOARD IN NOVEMBER. AND THEY'RE
KEY TO LIVING WITHIN OUR MEANS
WITHIN CEDAR PT GIVEN THE THREE
YEAR ALLOCATION TO IT. BUT THE
BOARD APPROVED AND WHAT IS A
FACE DOWN BASED UPON CONTINUED
SUCCESS IN THE SALES SO AFTER
THE MILLIONS HE WAS SOLD WHICH
JUST HAPPENED- BEGINNING TO FACE
DOWN BOTH- VEHICLE PRICES THE
CAPS THREE OLD ONE PROGRAM. IN
INCOME LEVELS AND SO IN ESSENCE
THE PROGRAM GETS MORE FOCUSED ON
SOMEWHAT LOWER PRICED VEHICLES
AND SO MUCH MORE FOCUSED ON
LOWER INCOME INDIVIDUALS. OVER
THE COURSE OF THE LIFE OF THE
FUNDING AND THOSE TRIGGERS YEAH
BOARD APPROVED HAD BEGUN TO KICK
IN WITH. THE RESULT THAT MILLION
VEHICLE SALE. GOOD COULD YOU ARE
US WERE THE INCOME IS AND NOW-
WHAT THE- VEHICLE PRESS STAR.
SHARE SO THE PHASE ONE CHANGE-
TOOK- FOR SINGLE FILERS WHAT I
BELIEVE IS A HUNDRED FIFTY K.
GROSS ANNUAL INCOME CAP TO ONE
THIRTY FIVE K. THE FOR HEAD OF
HOUSEHOLD FOLKS IT WENT FROM I
BELIEVE TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND TO
ONE SEVENTY FIVE. JOINT FILERS
THAT WENT TO I THINK TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND FOR THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. AND THIRTY CAP AND
WENT TO A BELIEVE FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND. DOLLARS FOR SMALLER
VEHICLES THERE'S A FACE TO
CHANGE WHICH WON'T TAKE EFFECT
UNTIL FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY
THREE THE BOARD LEFT TIME FOR
BOTH LEGISLATIVE FOR BOARD
REVISITING THIS. NICENESS IS
ALWAYS CHALLENGING. IS THAT THE
ONE POINT TWO FIVE MILLION.
EAGLE NOW THAT WOULD AND I
BELIEVE. AND THEY'RE WITH ME ANY
FIGURES. BRING THEM CAPTAIN
AHEAD TWENTY CAT ONE TWENTY K.
M. OR STANDARD FILERS FOR HAD
HOUSEHOLDS AND BELIEVE IT GOES
TO ONE SIXTY K. JOINT FOLLOWERS
ONE EIGHTY FIVE- AND AT THAT
POINT AGAIN HYBRIDS WILL COME
OUT. AND REBATE AMOUNTS TO GO
DOWN BY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS SO AGAIN THIS IS AN
EFFORT. TO THINK ABOUT I THINK
THAT'S WHERE THE BOARD WAS GOING
WITH THIS AND THROUGH THE PUBLIC
PROCESS OBVIOUSLY CONSIDERED A
LOT OF FEEDBACK MANY DIFFERENT
FOLKS. TO TRY TO FOCUS A LIMITED
POOL OF FUNDS. ON SOMEWHAT LOWER
INCOME CALIFORNIANS TO THE
DEGREE THAT WE NEEDED TO MANAGE
THAT AND THAT. IS IMPORTANT IN
RELATION TO SOME BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE THAT MAKE CLEAR THAT WE
SHOULD FOCUS I'M NOT GETTING
REQUIREMENTS AND FOR LOWER
INCOME FOLKS. SO THAT'S WITH
THINKING COMES FROM- IT'S ALL
LAID OUT IN SOME DETAIL THE
FUNDING PLAN. AND IT'S AN EFFORT
AGAIN TO LIVE WITHIN OUR MEANS
WHILE MAKING THE PROGRAM
FOCUSING AT- AND EFFECTIVE LANCE
FOLKS WHO MAYBE HAVE SOMEWHAT
LESS MEANS AS SALES INCREASED.
GOT IT DID DID YOU- YOU
MENTIONED YOU LOWER THE CAP ON
THE. VEHICLE SO AS WELL. YES
THAT'S RIGHT SO IT ENOUGH FIVE
DOLLAR A BELIEVES THE CURRENT
AND A SURPLUS. FOR THE SOME OF
THE SMALL VEHICLES. I THINK
ABSENT SIXTY K. FOR LARGER
VEHICLES THAT ARE WORKING ON
THAT ONE. I SEE OKAY. AND SO DO
WE DO WE EVEN KNOW HOW MANY.
VEHICLES ARE. THE QUITE A FEW I
DON'T HAVE THE MODEL NUMBER FOR
ME IN MY HAD- BUT I'LL CHECK THE
STAFF ON THE- OKAY. AND THEN DO
DO WE ARE. DO WE CONTINUE TO- A
SUPPORT PLUG IN HYBRIDS AS WELL
OR IS IT WE DO. HAVE A HYBRID TO
COME OUT AFTER ONE POINT TWO
FIVE MILLION IN THIS BORDER
VISITS THAT POINT THAT PRESENT
THEY REMAIN ELIGIBLE. IT WHAT'S
WHAT'S THE LOGIC- FOR PLUG IN
HYBRIDS. WELL I THINK THE
THINKING HERE IS THAT AS WE MOVE
INTO EVEN HIGHER SALES CLASSES
PLUGINS BECOME LESS OF A LARGE
CHUNK OF THE OVERALL. SALES
FLEET SO WHEN WE LOOK FOR
INSTANCE JUST PROJECTIONS WERE
MANUFACTURERS ARE GOING. THAT
REMAINS. TO THE POINT IS FOR
SOME FOLKS BUT HE NEEDS BECOME
MORE DOMINANT SO IF YOU GET A
HIGHER SALES WE EXPECT TO BE
THERE BE MORE IN THE MODELS. I
WITHIN THAT PRICE CAPS SAID
THREE CHOOSING ON EMISSIONS.
MAKES MORE SENSE TO FOCUS ON.
THESE YEAH BUT WHAT WHY EVEN
HAVE A PLUG IN HYBRID ME SEEMS.
WITH WITH. PASS GOT IT SORRY
CONTRACT. LITTLE DOES QUESTION
WHY WHY EVEN PLUG IN DOES SEEM
TO BE- DOESN'T SEEM TO I DON'T
KNOW WHY WE HAVE ANY INCENTIVE
DOLLARS GOING TOWARD-
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO USE GAS.
OP ED- IS AN EARLY STAGE MEASURE
THIS LETTER MOVING AWAY FROM IT
THIS MADE SOME SENSE DEPENDING
ON THE STATE OF THE OVERALL
CHARGING FRAMEWORK TO THINK FOR
INSTANCE ABOUT PERFECT WELLER'S
MIGHT HAVE LESS ACCESS TO IN
HOME CHARGING THAT FLEXIBILITY
CAN MATTER IN SOME USES ALL NOTE
THAT COVERS REGULATORY WORK SAID
THE BASKING CARE ACT YOU PACKAGE
WE'RE MIGRATING STANDS YOUR PLUG
IN HYBRIDS TO ESSENTIALLY MAKE
THEM. MUCH MUCH CLOSER TO PURE
EV'S SAY YOU USE THE GAS ENGINE
PROBABLY REALLY SPECIALIST USES
A LIMITED CIRCUMSTANCES SO
CERTIFIED ANSWER ONE. TWENTY TO
MAKE THOSE CARS BETTER PERIOD
THE TWO THERE ARE SOME USERS
THINK APART WHETHER IT'S THINK
OF FOLKS RURAL COMMUNITIES AND
LIKE YOU MAY HAVE LESS ACCESS
YOU STILL GET THE BENEFITS IT
AND SO DO WE DID YOU INCREASE
THE MILE- REQUIREMENT FOR BUT
THE BATTERY SIZE BECAUSE YOU
HAVE SOME PLUG IN HYBRIDS WITH
PRETTY SMALL BATTERS. SO THAT
WILL THAT SUPPOSED TO BE DONE IN
THE NEXT PASSING CARS TO PACKAGE
I'M REGULARLY. SO LEFT THE WHOLE
FLOOR. A SORRY CAN I. SO IT'S
ALWAYS AREYOUR THANK. YOU CARDS
STAFF. WE AT ITS NEXT ROUND OF.
RACE WHICH INCLUDE. NEW RAISE
STANDARDS PLUG IN HIGH. TO GROW
THAT ISSUE. SO THE ANSWER IS NO.
AT YEAH IN THE IN THE C. A. R.
P. THAT'S AN IMMEDIATE FOLK
THAT'S THEY ARE WILL FALL OUT
SHORT THE SALES INCREASED. AND I
BELIEVE THAT WE RAISED RANGE
CAPS FOR PLUG IN HYBRIDS TO GO
AFTER THE REALLY LOW ONCE IN THE
PAST YEARS SAID WE HAVE MADE
SOME EFFORTS THERE. YEAH BUT I
GUESS- BEAT UP TO MAKE THIS
POINT FOR YEARS I DON'T KNOW WHY
WE'RE- REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO TO BUY CARS. AND THEY
WERE STILL SUBSIDIZING GAS CARS
. GOT IT WE CAN TAKE THAT ON
BOARD A PROJECT FEEDBACK. YEP
YOU'VE TAKEN THE FEEDBACK FOR
NUMBER YEARS AND DONE NOTHING
ABOUT IT. YEAH I GUESS THE BIG
CHANGE IS THAT WE ARE DROPPING
THE FROM THE PROGRAM AT WITHIN
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
FOR THE VEHICLES AND THAT WAS
WHERE THE BOARD LANDED AT SO
THEY HAVE TAKEN SOME ACTION. BUT
OBVIOUSLY IT SOUNDS LIKE THIS
AND FOCUS AND PERHAPS EVEN TAKE
QUICKER ACTION THE CURRENT
PROCESS FRAME OF THE FUNDING
PLAN. IS TO TAKE SEVERAL MONTHS
THE BOY WILL NEXT YEAR BECAUSE
OF THIS FOR THE END OF THE YEAR.
I GOT ON THE DARTMOUTH WAS
RECEIVED YOU'RE YOU'RE COMING
THROUGH KIND OF GARBLED SO
SORRY. BUT I WAS SAYING WAS AND
BOY DID DROP THEM FROM THE
PROGRAM. AND ITS SALES CAPS
COLLAPSED I THINK IT'S AGAIN AT
ONE POINT TWO FIVE MILLION
VEHICLES THE PLUGINS WILL BE
OUT. SO THEY DID HEAR THAT AND
THAT WAS THE CHOICE THEY MADE I
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT. I'M WHEN
THEY NEXT VISIT THIS TOWARD THE
END OF THIS YEAR AND- IF NOT MAY
EITHER BE A SELF PROBLEM GIVEN
INCREASING SALES. OR A SEEM TO
BE SELF PROBLEM I'M GETTING THAT
FEEDBACK AND GIVEN THEIR CALL IN
DECEMBER OKAY GREAT THANK YOU- I
JUST. WAS CURIOUS ABOUT THE
EQUITABLE AT HOME. CHARGING
INCENTIVES- WHAT'S WHAT'S THE
HOW HOW WAS THAT GOING TO BE
STRUCTURE IN ITALY- SUPPORT
INCENTIVIZING- MULTI FAMILY.
DWELLINGS FOR CHARGING AND
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT BUT JUST
CURIOUS WHAT WHAT YOUR- WHAT THE. THINKING WAS BECAUSE JUST
LOOKING AT THE- NUMBER STATIONS
YOU WERE LOOKING. AND AT THEM.
DIDN'T SEEM LIKE WE WERE GETTING
VERY MANY STATIONS FOR THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WE'RE
PUTTING INTO THE PROGRAM. YES
SIR AND PLEASE LET ME KNOW IF MY
IDEA OF NOT COMING THROUGH
CLEARLY- THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION. NEITHER OF YOUR
AUDIENCE COMING THROUGH VERY
CLEARLY- I'LL DO THE BEST I CAN
I AGAIN I APOLOGIZE- SO THE OUT
OF HOME EQUITABLE CHARGING THREE
HUNDRED MILLION TOTAL. AND HOW
TO SEGMENT WITHIN IT THERE'S A
MULTI UNIT DWELLING APARTMENT
AND CONDO SEGMENT PHILOSTRATUS
PURPOSES WE'RE THINKING TWO
HUNDRED MILLION. OF THAT THREE
HUNDRED MILLION WILL GO TO DOT
BAGMAN. AND FOR THAT ONE WE
EXPECT TO GET TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND LEVEL TWO CHARGERS.
ASSEMBLY TWO THOUSAND LOCATIONS
FOR THAT. ON THE SINGLE FAMILY
HOME INFRASTRUCTURE WERE
ALLOTTED PURPOSES WERE MODELING
OUT ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION
OTHER THREE HUNDRED MILLION WILL
GO THERE LOOKING BY ABOUT FIFTY
THOUSAND FIVE ZERO LEVEL TWO
CHARGERS. I WANT TO NOTE THAT ON
THE SINGLE FAMILY HOME THAT
MEANT THAT WILL BE EXCLUSIVELY
FOR PRIORITY COMMUNITY W. LOW
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. WE ACTUALLY RAN
THROUGH ANALYSIS IN A REPORT WE
PUBLISHED EARLIER THIS YEAR THAT
SHOW THAT WHILE PEOPLE FAMILY
HOME THAT HAVE THE GREATEST
ACCESS. TO CHARGING THERE'S
ACTUALLY A PRETTY BIG DELTA FOR
THOSE IN THE LOWEST INCOME
SEGMENT. UNDER FIFTY THOUSAND
AND WE CAN ACTUALLY MAKE
INVESTMENT THAT TAKES THAT
NUMBER- ON MY ONE FROM THE SOUTH
I BELIEVE FROM 25% ACCESS FOR
THAT GROUP UP 240% ACT THE FLAG
GROUP. JUST GIVE ME VERY
TARGETED. YEAH THAT'LL THAT'LL-
THOSE PROGRAMS CARP IT HAS
KICKER. FOR TWO CHARGER THROUGH
ANOTHER. AS WELL AS LOCAL MISTER
FOR ME. HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE
EITHER LOW OR LIVE IN A
DIFFERENT COMMUNITY SO REALLY
NEED A HIGH NEED IN THAT SEGMENT
WHILE GRADES SO I TOTALLY
SUPPORT THE MISSION BEHIND BOTH
PROGRAMS ONE FOR MULTI FAMILY AS
WELL AS FOR. SINGLE FAMILY BUT A
TYPICAL LEVEL CHIU CHARGER TO
INSTALL IS ABUT A THOUSAND OR
MAYBE IF YOU REALLY WANT TO.
CHOOSE THE PRICE FIFTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS- FOR THAT MATH TWENTY
EIGHT. THOUSAND LEVEL TWO
CHARGER SHOULD ONLY COST ABOUT
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS SO
I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE UT
WHAT THE OTHER. HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY MILLION OR WHAT THE
HUNDRED THE. OTHER HUNDRED
SEVENTY NINE DOLLARS GOING
TOWARDS. GREAT QUESTION- SO ON
THE FINANCIAL AND WORKS COPING.
EXCUSE ME FOR INTERRUPTING BUT
MAY I ASK YOU TO TURN YOUR VIDEO
OFTEN IT MAY HELP BECAUSE THAT
THERE'S A CLEAR LACK OF SYNC
BETWEEN. THE VISUAL AND THE- AND
THE AUDIO. THANK YOU FOR AND
AGAIN I APOLOGIZE FOR THA IS IT
IS IT BETTER. WELL WE'LL SEE.
WE'LL JUST USE OUR AIR. THEIR
DAUGHTERS AND I. OKAY I'LL DO MY
BEST TO GO A LITTLE BIT SLOWER
ON THE SINGLE FAMILY HOME LEVEL
TWO CHARGER BURST OPEN THAT OUT
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
INSTALLATION AND THAT WOULD
INCLUDE YOU KNOW APPROXIMATELY
FOUR TO FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
THE L. TWO CHARTER BUT THEN
ABOUT FIFTEEN HUNDRED TOWARD
PAEL UPGRADE ADDING A CIRCUIT
OR DOING OTHER THINGS THAT NEED
TO HAPPEN. ON THE MULTI FAMILY
HOME. AND IT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE THIS IS ALSO A LEVEL TWO
CHARGER FOR COPING OUT ABOUT
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
CHARGE REPORT. AND WHAT'S REALLY
INTERESTING ABOUT THIS. IS A LOT
OF THE CLOCK IS ACTUALLY NOT THE
CHARGER ITSELF. IT WILL WORK IN
THE ENGINEERING TO HAVE TO GO
AROUND IT. EVERY FOOTPRINT EVERY
SITE IS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
THEY'RE ALL IN ENGINEERING
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT. THE
OFTENTIMES THINGS LIKE SHRINKING
LAND ON CONDUIT AND WIRE PANEL
UPGRADE POSSIBLY OTHER THINGS.
ARE REALLY THE BULK OF THE COT.
AND THAT THE BIGGEST DRAW
BECAUSE- ISRAEL LENT. THE TRENCH
TO BE DONE SO DEPENDING ON WHAT
THE POWER SOURCES. AND WHERE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS CAN HAVE A
STRONG IMPACT TO THE COST OF
THAT. INTERESTINGLY WHILE COOLEY
TWO THOUSAND FOR A LEVEL TWO
CHARGER ALL AND IN SINGLE FAMILY
HOME WHERE THINK IT'S MORE LIKE
SEVEN THOUSAND PER LEVEL TWO
CHARGER. IN AND YOUR DATE. AT
THE FOR THE MULTI FAMILY UNIT
DWELLINGS I GUESS WOULDN'T WIN
TO GET SOME. LEVEL OF SCALE
BECAUSE YOU WERE NOT DOING ALL
THAT WORK AND JUST PUTTING ONE
OR TWO CHART YOU'RE PUTTING IN A
NUMBER OF CHARGERS- SO WOULDN'T
THAT PRICE. COME DOWN BELOW.
SEVEN THOUSAND THAT SEEMS FAIRLY
. FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT. YEAH IT
DOES BUT THAT DOESN'T FACTOR IN
THAT ECONOMY OF SCALE YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE YOU'RE
EXACTLY RIGHT YOU WOULDN'T WANT
TO DO A TRANSFER ONE CHARGER
SOMEWHERE YOU WOULD DO IT
FRIENDS TO TEN OR FIFTEEN OR
TWENTY CHARTER BUT YOU STILL
HAVE THAT FIXED BECAUSE OF THE
TRANSUNION CONDUIT. AND LAYING
DOWN THE WIRE. OKAY EVEN EVEN
WITH YOUR MATH I'M ONLY GETTING
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. I PULLED UP SO. ONE
HELLO MY CALCULATOR OUT TO
SEVENTY THOUSAND TIMES TWENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND CHARGERS.
I COULD I COULD BEGIN MY MATH
WRONG BUT- NOW I CONFIRM THE
EARLIER ON YOU HAVE ME WORRIED
THAT I GOT IT WRONG BUT LET ME.
I THINK YOU JUST TAKE A LOOK AT
IT AND I THINK IF YOU GO. I CAME
TO. SORRY SIR I CAN TWO HUNDRED
AND NINETY MILLION OKAY SEVEN
THOUSAND I'M JOHN TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND CHARACTERS OKAY. SO- I
WOULD JUST MAKE SURE YOU. REVIEW
THE SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
CHARTER. COST TO LEE AND I WILL
NOTE WE ALWAYS TRY TO SCALE THAT
DOWN THAT THE PUBLIC PORTION OF
THE INVESTMENT IS NOT EVEN THE
ALL AND THAT THE PRIVATE SECTOR
WOULD WOULD PICK UP AND WE
ALWAYS WANT TO REDUCE OUR SHARE
OF IT- BUT YEAH 100% CORRECT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO DRIVE THE CAR
DOWN ON THE PUBLIC SHARE. AND
YOU DO YOU CONTINUE TO BE A
STUBBORN DOCUMENT. OKAY THANK
YOU- AND THEN JUST GO BACK TO
AND I KNOW MY COLLEAGUE ALREADY
ASKED ABOUT SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE GENERAL
FUND FOR EMERGENCY
OPPORTUNITIES- WHITE WHY ARE YOU
ASKING FOR THREE YEARS FOR THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION. AND DOES IT
DOESN'T COME WITH A LOT OF
DEFINITION AS TO WHAT THIS-
PROGRAM IS GOING TO BE DOING.
UNAFRAID TO DO FOR THAT OVERALL
DESIGN IT CAN STEP IN ON
ANYTHING ON PROGRAM THANK YOU
WHICH IS THE GENERAL FUND FOR
EMERGING OPPORTUNITIES THAT ONE
. IT ALREADY JUST KIND OF GIVE
A- AT THE BOND- A MULTI YEAR I
THINK. I'LL GET OVER. A CARPET
YOU TALK ABOUT THE DETAILS OF
WHAT THAT PROGRAM IS. KIND OF
THE OVERALL LIKE NORMAL YEAR
STRATEGY REALLY WHAT WARNING.
DURING THIS RECENT COMMITMENT-
TOWARD MEETING OUR CLIMATE
TRANSPORTATION GOALS AND ONE
LARGE PART REALLY TRYING TO.
SEND A GOOD SIGNAL THE DRIVE
MORE PRIVATE SECTOR COMPETITION.
AND THE BY HAVING BUTTE MULTIAIR
BET THAT WORK WORK AND MORE ABLE
TO ACHIEVE THAT- AND THEN HOW TO
TURN OVER TO CARPET. WE TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT IT WOULD
BE FUNDED WITHIN THAT- MERGING.
OPPORTUNITY COMPONENT. SECOND
SPEAK TO THIS AND JERRY RIGHT
IT'S PROBABLY. THE THINKING. IS
INTENSE. SO WE'VE HAD PRETTY
GOOD SUCCESS EACH YEAR PUTTING
OUT. I AM LOOKING SCALE REQUEST
FOR EDUCATION AND
EXPERIMENTATION IN HARD TO REACH
SECONDS I'LL GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE. AND SINCE THEN EMAIL
LOCOMOTIVES YOU WANT GETTING
SIXTEEN SWITCHERS ONLINE THEY'RE
ONE OF THESE GRANTS OR IN A
SOMEWHAT PARALLEL PROCESS AND I
JUST DOWN THERE YESTERDAY IN
WILMINGTON. AND WE FIND IT THAT
REALLY USEFUL EXTERNAL PROJECT
THAT BROUGHT IN TEN FUEL CELL
TRUCKS AND FOR THE FIRST TIME AT
COMMERCIAL SCALE AND STATIONS
THAT HELP PEOPLE LEARN. TO THE
GOAL HERE IS IN THE SENATE- TO
REACH SEGMENTS WHETHER ITS
LOCOMOTIVES MARINE WHERE WE FOR
INSTANCE HAVE RECENTLY. HELPED
COMMERCIALIZE YOU KNOW DOWN THE
SEA CHANGE THE FIRST. IN THE
FIRING OF THE BANK. ISRAEL
INTEREST IN A BROAD HOT CAN HELP
FOLKS GET IT LOGICAL. IN ALL
THESE AREAS SO THAT AND IN EACH
CASE THIS ISN'T JUST SPIT
BALLING WHAT ONE DOES IS PUTS
OUT OF THE HOUSE MORE DEFINED
FELICITATION TO FIND THE PUBLIC
PROCESS AIMED AT. THE PARTICULAR
AREAS THAT WE NOW NEED
ENGINEERING ADVANCEMENTS. IN THE
EARLIER QUESTIONS WE NEED TO
LEARN ABOUT LOGISTICS AND WITH
THE EXPERIENCE AND TRIED.
DRIVING GOOD- PRESENCE THERE AND
THAT'S DISTINCTLY DIFFERENT THAN
SOME OF THESE OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT ARE MORE FOCUSED EITHER
EQUITY OR AT SCALE. THIS IS A
CHANCE FOR THE STATE TO DO WE
ACTUALLY QUITE SUCCESSFUL AT
WHICH IS GREAT NEW TECHNOLOGIES
AND LEARN FROM THEM SO THAT IS
THE THINKING AROUND IT UP NOW I
FOUND EDUCATION WANTS TO SPEAK
IN THAT SEGMENT ABOUT. THANK YOU
I THOUGHT YOU COVER THAT WELL
THANK. SO I GUESS THE ONLY
QUESTION IS THERE A REASON WHY
YOU NEED A THREE YEAR RUN
WAIVERS IS JUST COMING BACK
EVERY SINGLE YEAR. ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU'RE BUT IT'S A- WHITE
SWAFFORD DEMONSTRATION PILOT
PROJECTS. WHEN DO I FIND ITS
THINKING ON THAT THEY WILL SAY
AS A PRACTICAL MATTER I'M NEEDS
MOST OF THESE PROJECTS HAVE BOTH
PURPOSE BUILT AND REQUIRE A FAIR
AMOUNT OF LOGISTICAL SUPPORT
DESIGN SEVEN CLARITY ON SEVEN
OVERALL RUNAWAY. THEIR CASH YOU
REALLY HELP GET THIS ALL THE WAY
DOWN AND MAKE SURE FOLKS WERE
ALL THE WAY THROUGH PLANNING AND
PERMITTING PROCESSES AND
INCENTIVES FOR THE MORE
INNOVATIVE PIECES DESIGNED
PROPERTIES SEVEN HEAVY DUTY
SPACE ESPECIALLY FAT FOLKS YOU
KNOW THERE AND BUILDING NEAR THE
TRACKS IN VERY DIRE WE DO HAVE A
LOT MORE PURPOSE BUILT COMPONENT
SAYS ONE REASON WHY HAVING THIS
OUT THERE MORE IS VALUABLE BUT
I'M LIKE AND I DEFERRED THE
MATURATION OF PARTICULAR-
CHOICES OKAY GREAT WELL PERHAPS-
ON THE ON THE ON THE NATURAL
DOESN'T REALLY MAKE SENSE TO.
HAVE YOUR THREE YEAR FUNDING
STREAM FOR PILOT PROJECTS OR
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS BUT- IF
YOU COULD AT LEAST PROVIDE
EXAMPLES OF PAST PROJECTS. TO
THE STAFF WE COULD WE COULD TAKE
A LOOK AT IT. SHOW THAT- JUST GO
BACK TO- CREE- THE CLEAN VIA
SYSTEM PROGRAM CLEAN CAR FOR ALL%
. CAN YOU GIVE US A SENSE OF HOW
THAT'S HOW THAT'S BEEN GOING.
YEAH IT'S GONE I THINK REALLY
WELL AND CONTINUES TO EXPAND SO
IF GO THROUGH WHERE
DANN AND COUPLE OF OR IT'S GOING
SO I'M SORRY. I'M SORRY WHEN YOU
THOUGHT YOU. IT IS A REALLY
SEVERE LAG IN IN THIS IN THE
DELAY THERE'S A DELAY I NEED YOU
TO SLOW DOWN LIKE HALF GO HALF
THE SPEED BECAUSE- IT'S JUGGLING
ALL OF YOUR WORDS TOGETHER AND
I'M ALL I COURSE OR ANYTHING
YOU'RE SAYING. THEY MIGHT HAVE.
HELLO GRADING THAT THE
CREATIVITY OF THE HELP. LET'S
TRY TURNING OFF YOUR- THANK YOU.
THAT COULD HELP HER- I'M GETTING
SOME ODD NUMBERS THAT WITH THIS
RESTORATION. LET ME KNOW IF THIS
HELPS AND THE PLEASE INTERACTIVE
IT DOESN'T SO. I'M ON THE
FINANCING ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
ABILITY TO DATE WITH ALLOCATED.
ABOUT SIXTY SEVEN AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS TO THAT'S ABOUT
JUST SHY OF FORTY EIGHT HUNDRED.
VEHICLES WHICH HAS BEEN QUITE
POSITIVE. ON CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
THINGS AT ABOUT A HUNDRED NINETY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS SO FAR ABOUT
TWELVE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
VEHICLES ON EVERTEC- AND WORKING
TO EXPAND THE PROGRAM. OVERALL
TO JUST TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT
OF A BIGGER PICTURE COMCAST FONG
METICULOUSLY OBVIOUSLY ROLLED
OUT. IN SPECIFIC VENUES RATHER
THAN- STATEWIDE AND ONE OF THE
HOPES FOR THIS BUDGET PACKAGES
TO. AND BEGIN TAKING THAT INTO
IT A STATE WIDE. ON PROGRAM
WHICH I THINK WOULD BE QUITE
USEFUL SO THAT SEVEN. OF WHICH
KIND OF HAVE A HAPPY DAY GET IT
ANY PARTICULAR PIECES OF IT. DO
YOU DID YOU GET A SO OR NOT
ENOUGH TRACK. PEOPLE WERE NEW
ARE YOU CARS. TO THE CLEAN CARS
FOR ALL. YOU KNOW I'M I BELIEVE
IT'S PRIMARILY THE TRAFFICKERS
FELLOWSHIP MISSTEP AND THAT FOR
ANY PARTICULAR BREAKDOWNS. I'M
SORRY. IT'S PRIMARILY WHAT DO.
COULD YOU SAY WITH WHAT WE'VE
SEEN BOTH REASON PEOPLE BUY NEW
AND I THINK THIS EXCITEMENT
THERE WE'VE ALSO SEEN USED
VEHICLE PURCHASES AND THAT'S
TRUE IN BOTH OF THE PROGRAMS I
DO NOT HAVE IN MY HAD A
PARTICULAR BREAKDOWN IN A FIFTY
FIFTY OR SIXTY FORTY ON IT BUT I
CAN CHECK AND- THE OTHER WAS A
CURE SUGGEST THAT PEOPLE ARE.
LOW INCOME JUST WONDER HOW THEY
CAN AFFORD NEW CARS. YEAH AND
OBVIOUSLY SOME FOLKS CAN'T
ESPECIALLY THESE PROGRAMS BUT I
THINK THE USED VEHICLE MARKETS A
REALLY BIG DEAL AND I WAS NOTE
PARENTHETICALLY. THAT ON THE
REGULATORY SIDE A LOT OF WHAT
CARDS DOING ITS NEXT ROUND OF
RAGS IS MAKING SURE THAT NEW CAR
STATE DURABLE THINKING INDICATE
THINGS LIKE BATTERY LIFE TO
CONSUMERS. SO TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THE USED VEHICLE MARKET FOR
HE'S- ON HIS BOTH GROWING AND
RELIABLE IN ADDITION TO THE
INCENTIVE PIECES. GOT GOT ENDED
FOR THE CLEAN VEHICLE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM YOU MENTIONED THE SIXTY
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION. AND
HOW MAY IT WHAT THAT RESULTED IN
TERMS OF- I THINK I'VE MISSED
WHAT YOU SAID BERMAN NUMBER
VEHICLES. ONLY A PROBLEM IS
PERMANENT AND THAT AGAIN THAT
WAS ABOUT I THINK. TO PLAY IN
THIS BIG A LITTLE BIT OF PROCESS
SINCE EIGHTEEN. THAT I'VE THOU
SEVEN AND NINETEEN AND MINOR.
OKAY MADE IT TO TWENTY BUT NOW.
OKAY AND THAT AND NOT THE JUST
JUST OUT OF CURIOSITY- BECAUSE I
DON'T HAVE ALL THE DETAILS FOR
THAT PARTICULAR PROGRAM IN FRONT
OF ME- THERE ARE. IS IT JUST
BECAUSE THE THERE'S A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT DELTA BETWEEN THOSE
TWO PROGRAMS IS JUST THE
STRUCTURE OF THE INCENTIVE. WHAT
SMALLER DOLLAR AMOUNTS RIGHT- SO
JUST ENTER TO SAVE TOTAL
ALLOCATION SO I THINK THAT
PROBABLY A LOT OF THAT. THE
SMALLER DOLLAR AMOUNTS FOR THE
CLEAN CARS WELL YEAH I MEAN
ALLOCATED FINANCING ASSISTANCE
HAD JUST SHY OF SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION. CONTRAST BROADHEAD
AROUND A HUNDRED NINETY ONE
MILLION ALLOCATED TO IT THAT'S
PROBABLY MOSTLY DRIVING THAT I'M
SORRY SUGGESTED HUNDRED NIGHT.
AT NINETY ONE MILLION OKAY GOT
YEAH ONE NINETY ONE SO THAT'S
ONE ONE GOT IT THAT MAKES SENSE
THAT MAKES MORE SENSE. YEAH
OKAY- GREAT I WOULD JUST SAY
OVERALL I THINK YOU KNOW I'M I'M
- PERSONALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
HAVING LIKE A LONGER RUNWAY-
HAVING SOME. A GREATER CERTAINTY
FOR THESE PROGRAMS BY THAT WE DO
WANT TO TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT
SOME OF THESE- LIONS LIKE A ****
ABOUT THE EMERGING OPPORTUNITIES
TRADITIONALLY UNDERSTAND- FOR
THE ONES THAT HAVE BEEN EXISTING
I THINK IT DOES MAKE SOME SENSE.
OF SOME OF THESE NEWER PROGRAMS
NOT SURE IF IT DOES MAKE SENSE
TO DO A THREE YEAR- FUNDING
CYCLE- FOR SOME OF THESE NEWER
PROGRAMS BUT DO APPRECIATE- A
VERY AGGRESSIVE PACKAGE ON ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AND REALLY
PUSHING PUSHING THE ENVELOPE SO
THAT WE CAN TRANSITION. OUT OF
OUT OF- ALSO FEEL TRANSPORTATION
SO VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO WE HAVE
A MISTER SMITH FOLLOWED BY MISS
FRIEDMAN AND MISTER BENNETT WITH
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IN- THE FOR THE
PUBLIC GIVEN ON CLOUD NINE SINCE
MONDAY SO CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN
FOR THE GREAT CHILD HOPEFULLY
GET TO SEE HIM RESEARCH I'M NOT
PLANNING ON COMING DOWN ANYTIME
SOON I. BUT MARK THE BACK END OF
YOUR CHEER ME FOR BEING LATE BUT
I'M BACK INTO THE TRANSPARENCY
OR ACCOUNTABILITY. AND HOW ARE
YOU GOING TO BE TRACKING THESE
PROJECTS AS WE MOVE ALONG- DO WE
GET AN UPDATE NEXT YEAR THAT. WE
EXPENDED X. AMOUNT OF DOLLARS OR
BILLION DOLLARS. WERE IN
CONSTRUCTION ON SO MANY WE HAVE
SO MANY COMPLETED. BUT IN IN
THAT ISSUE. WILL WE GET AN
UPDATE. CERTAINLY WE'RE ALWAYS
HAPPY THAT THAT YOU'LL- THAT WAS
EASY SO WE WILL GET AN UPDATE IN
EARLY MARCH OF NEXT YEAR WHERE
WE'RE STANDING WITH ALL THIS OF
MONEY THAT'S BEEN EXPANDED. YEAH
WE'RE ALWAYS HAPPY TO COME BACK
AND BE CLEAR ON WHERE THINGS
STAND AS INDIA. THE THING MY
OTHER COLLEAGUES ARE CONCERNED
WITH IN I'LL GET WITH THE ER BUT
THESE PROJECTS. WE STARK
CONSTRUCTION IT MIGHT TAKE A
YEAR BEFORE THEY GET FINISHED IN
THIS PROJECT I KNOW WE'RE TRYING
TO PUSH IT. WE DID A PROJECT ON
MONDAY FOR A COLLEGE. TO ABOVE
FORTY I ARDOR WROTE RELIEVE THAT
SITUATION- MAYBE WE CAN HELP YOU
OUT ON CERTAIN PROJECTS TO GO
THAT. IN ANOTHER. PART WITH THE
FUELING STATION YOU PULL IN YOU
GET GAS AND FIVE MINUTES AND
YOU'RE ON YOUR WAY. THE
FEELINGS. THE LACTIC FILLING
STATION. YOU HAVE TO STAY THIRTY
MINUTES TO TWO HOURS THE
FOOTPRINTS GOING TO BE ABOUT
FIVE TIMES LARGER THAN THE
EXISTING. SHIP YOU KNOW DOUBLE
GO GAS STATION. ARE WE TAKING
INTO CONSIDERATION. THIS GREATER
SIZE THAT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
TAKE ON WHEN YOU PUT IN THESE
CHARGING STATIONS. GOOD MORNING-
I'LL TAKE THAT QUESTION. SO IT
VARIES QUITE A BIT DEPENDING ON
THE TYPE OF CHARGING STATION-
THE LEVEL TWO YOU DON'T HAVE TO
THAT ABOUT THE CURRENTBUT TO
YOUR POINT THOSE YOU TAKE LONGER
TO CHARGE. THEY'RE GREAT FOR A
LONG LONG TIME LOCATION BLAKE.
WORKPLACES THE HOME IT'S A
REALLY UNDER THAT MODEL YOU'RE
NEVER REALLY BE THINKING ABOUT
HAVING TO CHARGE IT IT'S ALWAYS
HARD FOR YOU. BUT THE DC FAST
CHARGERS AND HOT IN THE HYDROGEN
STATION. CANNOT HAVE A LARGER
FOOTPRINT- IF THEY'RE MOVING
MORE AND MORE TOWARD. THE RIGHT
WAY TO GET THOSE DEPLOYED
QUICKLY WE KNOW PERMITTING AND
INTERCONNECTION YOUR PROBLEM.
AND WE ARE LOOKING TO GET HIGHER
POWERED PAST CARTER'S OUT THERE
WHICH GET YOU CLOSER TO A FIVE
TO TEN MINUTE CHARGE. AS OPPOSED
TO A TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY FIVE
TO FORTY MINUTES HARD. TO
DEFINITELY- APPRECIATE THAT
CONCERN. AND WE'RE TRYING TO
TALK ABOUT IT WHILE. THEM WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO DO SO. WHILE WE'RE
CHARGING VEHICLE. TO GET A LIKE
A REST AREA ALONG THE- HI FIVE
NINETY NINE. OR WE CAN WALK
AROUND HAVE ACTIVITY SOMETHING
TO DO WHILE YOU MAY BE ABLE TO
BE IN CHARGE. AND THEN AND- PART
OF THE PROJECT HERE SAYS NE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
PROP NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND.
FOR CALLING SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION WE'RE NOT TAKING
ANY FUNDING FROM THE EDUCATION
THIS IS ADDING TO THAT. I THANK
YOU CAN COUPON WITH THE LEAD
GENERALISTS OFFICE SO THIS IS
FUNDING THAT WOULD BE PAID WITH
IN THE EXISTING- PART OF FUNDS
SET ASIDE FOR OUR SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. WE WOULD
NOTE THAT THAT FUNDING IS ONLY
AVAILABLE FOR ONE TIME
ACTIVITIES SO IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT COULD BE REDIRECTED TO. OUR
ON GOING IN COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS OR OTHER ON GOING
PURPOSES FOR SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND THEN A
FOLLOW UP. IN SCHOOLS FOR THE
RESIDENTIAL CHARGING STATION IS
THERE GONNA BE. IF WE BUY A BUS
DO I MAKE COORDINATED TO BE IN
THE CHARGING STATION. SO WE GET
THEM BOTH COORDINATED I DON'T
WANT TO HAVE A BUS WITHOUT
CHARGING OR CHARGING WITHOUT A
BUS. OR TRANSPORTATION VEHICLE
FOR ALL OUR TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES. RIGHT SO THE WAY THE
PROGRAM IS SET UP AS THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES THAT IS
THAT WOULD BE FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR EACH
BUS. WITH THE IDEA THAT FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND WOULD PAY FOR
THE BUS ITSELF. AND FIFTY
THOUSAND WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR
THE CHARGING STATION BOTH
COMPONENTS OF THE PROGRAM WOULD
BE ADMINISTERED. BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION SO IT WOULD BE ONE
GRANT PROGRAM TO PAY FOR BOTH.
PIECES OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU FOR THOSE QUESTIONS MISS
FRIEDMAN THANKS I HAVE A
QUESTION- ACTUALLY PROBABLY TO
QUESTIONS ABOUT FLEET
INCENTIVES. THE FIRST IS IF YOU
CAN JUST OUTLINED WHAT'S
AVAILABLE. FOR SMALLER FLEETS OF
WHO WANT TO CONVERT. DESERVES
AND SECONDLY WHY THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE INCENTIVES GIVEN TO
LARGE FLEETS AND THOSE GIVEN TO
SMALL FLEETS. AND HOW ARE YOU
LOOKING AT. FUELING TYPES AND
VEHICLE TYPE WITH FLEET
INCENTIVES. FIRST LET ME START
OUT ON THIS AND- THERE'S LESS
COMPLEX TO THIS SO WE CAN GO
BACK AND FORTH IS NEEDED. SO
GENERALLY SPEAKING- SEVERAL
DIFFERENT WAYS PLEASE CAN
ACCESS- FUNDING INCLUDING THIRD
WITH MY PROGRAM WHICH IS OUTSIDE
OF THIS HEARING AND THEN R. H.
V. I.P. PROGRAM. AND MEDIA.
YEAH FUNDS BOTH FUEL CELL. AND
BATTERY TRUCKS. GENERALLY
SPEAKING THE INCENTIVES ARE
ABOUT A HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. PER TRACK FOR BATTERY
VEHICLES INVOLVED IN A FIFTY
THOUSAND PER GRADE STRUCK. IT'S
ABOUT DOUBLE THAT FUEL CELLS
JUST REFLECTS THE TOTAL SCOPE.
ON THE DIFFERENCE ON COST BASE
WITH WHEELS OR TRACKS COST MORE
AS WE TRY TO MAKE UP THE
DIFFERENTIAL TO SOME DEGREE FOR
FLEETS. YOU CAN ACCESS THIS-
BASICALLY THROUGH THOSE VOUCHER
PROGRAMS WHICH THE BOARD DECIDED
IN NOVEMBER I'M TO FOCUS
STEADILY MORE HEAVILY. ON SMALL
FLEETS. IN TERMS OF OVERALL
ACCESSIBILITY. AND THE GOAL HERE
THE THINKING. IS THAT WE KNOW
THEY'RE A LOT OF FOLKS WHETHER
IT'S OUR SMALL BUSINESSES OR
SMALL MINORITY OF BUSINESSES
THAT ARE REALLY FOCUSED. ON THE
TRANSITION BUT MERRY NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO CAPITAL SO WE'RE
TRYING TO BE SMART IN TERMS OF
WHERE WE ALLOCATE THIS CAPITAL.
AN INMATE AT FOLKS WHO WE KNOW
DEFINITELY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
BROADER CAPITAL POOLS FOR THE
WEEKEND. THAT ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION ALL RIGHT- MISTER
BENNETT. THANK YOU AND AGAIN
THAT NUMBER QUESTIONS AND- IF
YOU CAN BE AS BRIEF AS POSSIBLE
ANSWERED APPRECIATED- ALL MY
QUESTIONS HERE DEAL WITH AB
EIGHT THE- DIRECTION TO BUILD
TWO HUNDRED HYDROGEN FUELING
STATIONS AN UNDER ABA CAN YOU
TELL ME HOW MANY HAVE BEEN BUILT
SO FAR. YES THIS ENERGY
COMMISSION AGAIN SO AB EIGHT
DIRECTION AT THE HUNDRED
STATIONS AND ON THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER THREE HUNDRED STATIONS AND
WE'RE CERTAINLY MARKING TOWARD
THAT TWO HUNDRED STATION MARC.
WE HAVE FIFTY FIVE OPEN STATIONS
NOW. THIRTY THREE STATION IN
DEVELOPMENT I WILL HAVE A
HUNDRED STATION DONE BY THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE- WITH THE
GENERAL FUND MONEY WE GOT LAST
YEAR WILL BE ABLE TO GET TO R.
TWO HUNDRED MARK BY ABOUT TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY TWENTY SIX.
K. AND CAN YOU TELL ME WHAT THE
TIMETABLE IS BETWEEN WHEN WE-
AWARD MONEY FOR OF A STATION AND
WHEN THE STATIONS ACTUALLY BUILT
AND. AND OPEN FOR- BUSINESS.
YEAH THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION- IT
COULD VERY QUITE A BIT BUT WE'RE
AVERAGING ABOUT TWO YEARS. AND
WE ARE EXPERIENCING SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEMS IN TERMS OF SIMPLY
GETTING ADEQUATE AMOUNTS OF
HYDROGEN TO THOSE STATIONS- HAVE
YOU SEEN ANY SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
IN THAT EQUATION- IN THE IN THE
RECENT MONTHS. SOME GOOD
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT PRODUCTION IS
INCREASING AND- ON THE ENERGY
COMMISSION SIDE OR INVESTMENTS
HAVE ALSO BEEN GOING TOWARD FUEL
PRODUCTION. WE AWARDED THREE
MORE FUNDING GRANT EARLIER THIS
YEAR FOR CLEAN AND RENEWABLE
FUEL PRODUCTION. AND THEN HOW
MANY OF THE STATIONS THAT WE
HAVE OF THAT THE OF THE SIXTY
FIVE THAT HAVE GONE IN SO FAR
HOW MANY OF CONSERVE BOTH MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY AS WELL AS LIGHT
DUTY VEHICLES. DON'T HAVE A
NUMBER FOR WHAT ALREADY BEEN
DEPLOYED BUT BETWEEN WHAT THE
DEPLOYED AND WHAT WE'VE ALREADY
FUNDED WHICH IS UNDER
DEVELOPMENT WILL HAVE THIRTEEN
ONE THREE SECOND ALSO THIRD
MEDIUM DUTY HEAVY DUTY. I'LL
NOTE THAT WE'RE GOING TO LAUNCH
OF PETITIONS- THIS YEAR AS WELL
TO ENCOURAGE THE MARKET TO DO
THOSE THAT ARE DUAL PURPOSE.
LIGHT DUTY PASSENGER WITH MEDIUM
DUTY HEAVY DUTY SO WELL OVER A
CENTURY YOU BROUGHT UP THE DUAL
PURPOSE- HOW WHAT'S THE
TECHNOLOGY THERE HOW HOW EASY IS
IT IS IT THE SAME NOZZLE OR DO
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A DIFFERENT
NOZZLE BETWEEN HEAVY DUTY AND-
AND LIGHT DUTY. OF CAN WE YOU
KNOW LIKE THE DIESEL IT USED TO
BE ABLE TO. PULL UP WITH YOUR
CAR AND THEN YOU YOU COULD GET
DIESEL OF YOU KNOW WHAT. TO AT
THE TRUCK STOP CAN YOU OF. IN
LIGHT NATIONAL BIT INTO OF HOW
COMPATIBLE WILL HEAVY DUTY AND
LIGHT DUTY. HYDROGEN FUELING BE
. I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THAT SO LET ME GET BACK TO YOU
ALL KNOW THAT THE ONE WHO
DECLINE NOW TYPICALLY HAVE TWO
SIDES TO IT BUT THERE MAY BE A
FAN LINE OR SOMETHING WHERE A
TRANSIT AGENCY ACCESS AND IT ON
ITS SIDE. OF THE FENCE LINE WITH
A CONSUMER FACING FIVE ON THE
OTHER I DON'T KNOW IF THE NOVELS
ARE INTERCHANGEABLE BUT A LOT OF
THAT POOR INFRASTRUCTURE MORE
THAN THIRTY ABOUT LET ME FIND
OUT ABOUT THE NOVELTY. SO THE
BUT THE CORE INFRASTRUCTURE SO
GENERALLY COULD WE COULD WE HAVE
ALL OF THEM- IN THE FUTURE BE
ABLE TO SERVICE BOTH. MEDIUM AND
HEAVY AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES.
AND LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES AT THE
SAME TIME. HERE RADICALLY I
THINK YES- MY ONLY COPY OUT IF
WE DO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT ITS
THIRD THAT PLEASE OFFICIALLY FOR
THEIR OPERATION. AND STILL HAS A
GOOD CONSUMER EXPERIENCE FOR THE
CONSUMER NOT. TRYING TO DODGE-
CAN'T ABOUT THE- GREAT STRUCTURE
I THINK THEORETICALLY YEAH BUT
WE WANT TO THINK THROUGH SOME OF
THE PACIFIC. SO IF WE WERE ON
THE INTERSTATE WE ARE AT A BIG
TRUCK STOP WE COULD MAKE SURE
THAT ALL OF THOSE AT THAT TO ALL
THE HYDROGEN STATIONS PUT AT A-
AT A- AT A LARGE TRUCK STOP
WHERE THERE'S- THERE'S- A- LARGE
AMOUNT OF SQUARE FOOTAGE OF
DEVOTED TO- FUELING- IN THOSE
SITUATIONS WE COULD CERTAINLY.
HAVE THOSE ALL BE DUAL- DO
PURPOSE. HYDROGEN STATIONS
CORRECT. I BELIEVE THAT'S THE
CASE BUT LET ME CONFIRM I DON'T
WANNA GIVE YOU WRONG INFORMATION
BUT I BELIEVE THAT IS CORRECT
I'LL GET BACK TO YOUR OFFICE OR
NOT THANK YOU- AND THEN- JUMPING
DOWN TO THE THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
THREE MILLION THE FEDERAL FUNDS
RESERVE INFRASTRUCTURE SO WE
WILL SEE THIS WELL THAT FUNDING
BE AVAILABLE FOR SOME OF THESE
HYDROGEN STATIONS ALSO ON THE
INTERSTATE THAT'S OVER AND ABOVE
THE TWO HUNDRED- THAT- WE NOW
HAVE AS A GOAL FROM THE GOVERNOR
. FEDERAL COMPONENT HAS TO START
THE FEDERAL FUNDING HAS TWO
COMPONENTS. THE SECTION YOU'RE
TALKING TO IT FROM THE FIVE
BILLION TOTAL. CALIFORNIA GETS
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY FOUR MILLION. ON THAT
HAVE TO BE FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. THANK YOU ALTHOUGH
THERE THE TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
COMPETITIVE. WHICH COULD GO TO
LECTOR KERR HYDROGEN. WE DON'T
HAVE FEDERAL GUIDANCE ON THAT
YET BUT WE'RE GONNA TRY TO BRING
THAT CALIFORNIA TO. OKAY THANK
YOU ALMOST FINISHED YOUR FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS SUPPORT
ELECTRIFICATION- AS- AS I'VE
BEEN TALKING TO PORT OF HUENEME
. INVENTOR COUNTY HERE COUNTY I
REPRESENT- THEY ARE OF REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CHALLENGES.
OF THE PLANNING AND EVERYTHING
THAT IS GOING TO TAKE TO
ELECTRIFY AND A PARTICULAR
CONCERNED ABOUT ENOUGH ENERGY
COMING. FROM THE GRID AT
ANALYZING THAT WITH THAT WITH
THE I. O. SEASON SO WILL SOME OF
THE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION BE
AVAILABLE. SO THAT THE PORTS CAN
COORDINATE WITH THE I. O. USED
TO ENSURE THE PROPER PLANNING-
OF BRINGING IN THE ELECTRICITY
PROPER PLACEMENT OF THE
EQUIPMENT EXCEPT FOR. WORDS ARE
GOING TO BE DEVOTED ONLY TO THE
EQUIPMENT ITSELF. UNDER THAT THE
ATTACK THE QUESTION ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE- WE CAN ALSO
FUND UP PLANNING BLUEPRINT GRANT
WE'VE DONE THAT IN THE PAST. THE
CANDIDATE AND HIS MOTHER SO WE
COULD ACTUALLY FIND PLANNING
BLUEPRINT FOR THE FUNDING OF
WHILE- I JUST GOT A TEXT FROM MY
COLLEAGUES YOU CAN FEEL. HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES WITH A LIGHT DUTY
NOVEL IT'S JUST A LITTLE BIT
SLOWER. GREAT SHOW CAN BE DONE
EXCELLENT- AND SO IT AND IT'S
STILL UNANSWERED SO PLANNING FOR
INTEGRATION- AND GRID
UTILIZATION WILL BE. A ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THE PORTS CAN
USE A FOREIGNER MILLION DOLLARS
FOR. CAN'T WAIT FOR THE CAR
BESIDE BUT YET ON THE ON THE
ENERGY COMMISSION INFRASTRUCTURE
SIDE WE COULD FIND- THE- GREAT
THE CARD AND I CAN SPEAK FOR THE
CURBSIDE IN ABSOLUTELY SO WE'LL
FIGURE THIS OUT THE EXACT
PARAMETERS OF THIS PROJECT THE
PUBLIC PROCESS BUT WE'VE HAD A
GOOD RELATIONSHIP TWENTY ME. WE
KNOW IN GENERAL THAT FOR ALL THE
COURTS THEY NEED TO THINK ABOUT
THESE IMMIGRATION ISSUES AND I
HAVE A HARD TIME THINKING AND-
THE ANY PUBLIC PROCESS WOULDN'T
TURN OUT A CLEAR NEED TO THINK
ABOUT PLANNING INTEGRATION GIVEN
THEIR NEEDS. GREAT THANK YOU UP
JUST ONE AND WITH THE WITH TWO
COMMENTS AND ONE IS THAT- AS
WE'RELOOKING AT THE HYDROGEN
ELECTRIC FEELINGS DID YOU
RECHARGING AND SORT OF THE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE OUT THERE.
THEY'RE REALLY JUST BOTH OF THEM
HAVEUNIQUE ADVANTAGES TO- YOU
KNOW- WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
BATTERY TECHNOLOGY YOU KNOW
PEOPLE HAVE ELECTRICITY IN THEIR
HOMES I CAN PLUG THEIR CARS IN
THEIR HOMES THEY DON'T HAVE
HYDROGEN FUELING STATIONS AT
HOME. ON THE OTHER HAND- AS- MY
COLLEAGUE POINTED OUT THAT. JUST
IMAGINE THE BACKLOG ON HEAVY
TRAVEL DAYS HELLO. THIS
THANKSGIVING THE WEDNESDAY IN
THE SUNDAY OF THANKSGIVING
WEEKEND AND EVERYBODY TRYING TO
CHARGE THEIR VEHICLES AT A AT-
CHARGING STATIONS ON THE
INTERSTATES YOU KNOW AS ARE
DRIVING GO EAT IT. IT IN BUT
HYDROGEN COULD BE TREATED JUST
LIKE GASOLINE YOU COULD HVE
MANY HYDROGEN TANKS YOU HAVE
LOTS OF PEOPLE COME IN FUEL UP
IN IN FIVE MINUTES. SO I'M
COMPLETELY SUPPORTIVE OF BOTH OF
THESE I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE
OR SOME GREAT VALUE TO HAVING
BOTH OF THEM AVAILABLE. TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS THAT ARE OUT
THERE- AND WITH WITH THE
HYDROGEN I THINK THERE THERE'S
MORE FLEXIBILITY IN MANY WAYS-
WITH ELECTRIC BATTERIES THERE IS
TO IT. YOU CAN HAVE- DATE TO
CHARGING TAKING PLACE IN IN IN
PEOPLE'S HOMES- AND SO I JUST
HOPE THAT WE THAT WE WILL BE
TRULY BE COMMITTED. TO TRYING TO
MAKE BOTH OF THESE TECHNOLOGIES
I'M UNLESS SORT OF SAYING I'M
I'M TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL AND MORE
SAYING I'M PRO MAKING SURE WE
HAVE AT LEAST TWO AVENUES GOING
FORWARD- IF NOT MORE AS. BETTER
TECHNOLOGY COMES COMES FORWARD
AND THEN FINALLY AB WE HAD A
SHORT COME. ARE PART THE
INTEREST BY BOTH OF US IN AND-
TEN MILLION I WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN MUCH MORE THAN TEN
MILLION. FOR THE BATTERY
REPLACEMENT ONLY BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S SO MUCH BETTER OF AN
INVESTMENT. YOU DON'T HAVE TO
HAVE THE COST OF BUYING A IT-
ARE BUILDING A WHOLE NEW VEHICLE
AND ALL THE CARBON. ADMISSION
THAT GOES OUT THERE AND DIS
ALECTRA VEHICLE SEEM TO BE
HOLDING UP REALLY WELL OUTSIDE
OF THE BATTERY SO. HOW TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE COULD BE MORE
THAT I REALLY APPRECIATE-
YOU'RE- A STRONG. INTEREST IN
AND COMMITMENT OF THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CHAIR. THANK YOU
MISTER BENNETT WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE TOO. THAT'S
THE- TWENTY TWENTY TO CAP AND
TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN- OF TWO
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION. IT'S A
TWO HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLAR
REQUEST. FOR COMMUNITY AIR
PROTECTION INCENTIVES. DO WE
HAVE FOR A. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME- IF YOU COULD SPEAK UP A
LITTLE BIT IT SOUNDS LIKE
BECAUSE OF I MIGHT BE A LITTLE
BIT LONGER. SISTEMAS FLETCHER
THIS IS MISS FLETCHER OKAY I CAN
SPEAK UP WITH THAT BETTER MUCH
BETTER THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT AND
I WILL GIVE AN IDEA OF WHAT I
SAW I WILL KEEP- MY CAMERA OFF
SO WE DON'T HAVE THAT. THAT
DISTORTED VIDEO. THANK YOU
UNFORTUNATELY I THINK THAT'LL BE
HELPFUL- AND WE'LL TRY TO
IMPROVE- AT OUR NEXT HEARING
WHERE I'M HOPING WE'LL BE ABLE
TO- HAVE THE- IN PERSON
PANELISTS AS OPPOSED TO- REMOTE.
SO UP- I WELCOME PLACE PLEASE
BEGIN AS FLETCHER. ALL RIGHT
WELL GOOD MORNING SHOULD MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
SHOULD NOT FLETCHER I MET DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE OFFICER AT THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD AND I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT OUR PROPOSAL ON THE
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION
PROGRAM. SO BEFORE I START I
WANTED TO NOTE THAT NEARLY ONE
THIRD OF CALIFORNIANS
PREDOMINANTLY PEOPLE OF COLOR
LIVE THE OVER FOUR HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY SUFFER FROM
DIRTY AIR. SO IF YOU ARE ONE OF
THOSE CALIFORNIANS THAT LIVE IN
A COMMUNITY THAT SUFFERS FROM
DIRTY AIR ON AVERAGE YOU WILL
BREATHE AIR THAT HAS TWICE THE
AMOUNT OF CANCER CAUSING DIESEL
PARTICULATES AND SOMEONE THAT
LIVES IN A MORE FLUID COMMUNITY.
WITH CLEANER AIR SO THIS BURDEN
ON WHO SUFFERS FROM DIRTY AIR
AND WHO DOESN'T IT DIRECTLY. I
GOOD YOUR OF IT NOT WHAT IT WAS
WHEN YOU BURKE YEAH WE'VE HEARD
THAT IT DIFFICULT ABOUT- AND I'M
NOT SURE ABOUT YOUR AND ARMENIA
- IF YOU COULD TRY TO WE GOT
THIS. BIT MORE. LIKE YOU WERE.
OF OKAY IS THAT BETTER. ALL
RIGHT. I TURNED. UP ON MY- RIGHT
SO ALL JUST I'LL START RIGHT
HERE- INSTEAD BUT I'M- SO THIS
BURDEN ON WHOSE FOR DIRTY AND
DOES. IT'S A DIRECT OF THE LAW
HISTORY OF RACE SPECIFIC AND
RACISM CONCENTRATED POVERTY AND
YEARS OF HISTORIC DISINVESTMENT
AND I COLLECT IN THESE
COMMUNITIES. TO ADDRESS THIS
DISPARITY. THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED AND THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX ONE SEVEN
WHICH DIRECTED CARBON IN
CONJUNCTION WITH LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS TO PARTNER WITH
PRESIDENT OF HEAVILY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES AND FOLLOW THEIR
GUIDANCE TO ADDRESS LOCAL
CRITERIA AIR POLLUTANT AND TOXIC
AIR CONTAMINANT SOURCES OF
CONCERN TO A VARIETY OF
STRATEGIES. THREE WHICH I WILL
DISCUSS TODAY. SO THE FIRST
CHART A G. IF THE COMMUNITY AIR
PROTECTION OR CAP INCENTIVES
WHICH FOCUSES ON ADDRESSING
CONCERNS FROM THE COMMUNITY THAT
CONTINUES TO SUFFER FROM
DISPROPORTIONATE CUMULATIVE
EXPOSURE BURDENS IN THE CREATION
OF YOUR MONITORING PLANS. AN
EMISSION REDUCTION PROGRAMS.
THESE COMMUNITIES ARE SELECTED
TO PARTICIPATE IN AB SIX ONE
SEVEN. THE OUTCOME FROM THE
CAPTAIN CENTERS ARE REAL
SUPPORTERS HAMPEL WE'VE SEEN.
OVER TWO THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
ENGINES REPLACED WITH CLEANER
ALTERNATIVES STATEWIDE. AND
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS INCLUDING
OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND TONS OF
OXIDES OF NITROGEN JUST KNOCKS A
HUNDRED TONS OF REACTIVE ORGANIC
GASES IN SEVEN HUNDRED TONS OF
PARTICULATE MATTER OR PM. SO
THIS B. C. P. REQUEST A HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION IN INCENTIVES TO
CONTINUE THIS IMPORTANT WORK.
THE SECOND STRATEGY REQUIRED BY
EIGHTY SIX ONE SEVEN ITS
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS. FIFTIETH P. ALSO
FIFTY NINE INTO TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY. FOR AIR DOES
IMPLEMENTATION. TO CONVENE
COORDINATE AND SUPPORT COMMUNITY
STEERING COMMITTEES WITH THIS
AUTOMATION STIPENDS LANGUAGE
ACCESS AND MEETING MATERIALS.
DEVELOPED AIR MONITORING PLANS
AND EMISSION REDUCTION PROGRAMS
WITH THE COMMUNITY STEERING
COMMITTEES. EMPLOYEE MAINTAIN
THEIR MONITORING WITHIN
COMMUNITIES. AIRPORT CRITERIA
TOXIC AREAS CAN CONTAMINATE
REPORTING AND IMPLEMENT BEST
AVAILABLE RETROFIT CONTROL
TECHNOLOGIES THAT SPARKED
REQUIREMENTS. THE THIRD STRATEGY
OUR COMMUNITY AIRCRAFTS WHICH
ONE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND CALIFORNIA
TRIBES THESE GRANTS HELP
AUTHORITIES DEEPEN THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN THE EIGHTY SIX
ONE SEVEN PROCESS AS WELL AS
BILL CAPACITY TO ACTIVELY
IDENTIFY EVALUATE AND ULTIMATELY
REDUCE AIR POLLUTION AND
EXPOSURE TO HARMFUL EMISSIONS IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES. IN THIS B. C.
P. REQUEST TEN MILLION TO
CONTINUE THOSE EFFORTS. NUMBER
OF YOUR- EXACTLY AT THE END OF
YOUR PRESENTATION THAT IS THE
AND THEN THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WEHAVE A QUESTION
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION-
I NOTICED IN YOUR BUDGET-
THERE'S TEN MILLION ALLOCATED-
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
CAPACITY BUILDING GRANTS. ARE
FOR YOU KNOW COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHERS. TO
SUPPORT THEIR PARTICIPATION IN
AB SIX ONE SEVEN- WHERE WILL
YOU. TARGET ARE DO HAVE TARGETED
COMMUNITIES OR HOW WILL THESE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
RECEIVE. OF THIS INFORMATION
THAT THERE'S FUNDING FOR THEM
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. THAT'S
A GREAT QUESTION AND SO WHILE
OUR EIGHTY SIX ONE SEVEN
PROGRAM- WE DO YOU HAVE SELECTED
AB SIX ONE SEVEN COMMUNITIES AND
THAT'S WHAT WE TALK ABOUT THE
STEERING COMMITTEE FOR THE
COMMITTEE THE AIRCRAFT'S PROGRAM
IT IS STATEWIDE. AND SO WHAT WE
DO IS WE WORK CLOSELY WITH- ART
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN CARP AND WITH
OTHER STATE AGENCIES TO SHARE
OUT THAT INFORMATION AND MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S REALLY GETTING
ACROSS ALL OF I THINK- THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND THE TRIBES SO THEY ALL HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS INFORMATION. WE
HAVE TEN MILLION AND SO ONCE WE
KIND O SHARE THAT INFORMATION
AGAIN WE'RE WORKING WITH OTHER
STATE AGENCIES WORKING WITH A
TRIBAL LIAISONS AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT KIND OUT
INFORMATION- THAT'S KIND OF HOW
WE DO IT BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE REALLY GET THIS
RESOURCE OUT TO AS MANY
COMMUNITIES. AS POSSIBLE GIVEN
AGAIN I THINK THE AMOUNT OF
COMMITTEES ARE. SUFFERING WITH
AIR POLLUTION. S. R. I. I. GREW
UP IN COMMUNITY I REPRESENT
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE SUFFERING
FROM AIR POLLUTION WHERE
CHILDREN. I HAVE TO GO HAVE TO
GO TO SCHOOL RIGHT BY SEVERAL
FREEWAYS AND SUFFER FROM ASTHMA
YOU KNOW THE- ASTHMA RATES- IT
FOR CHILDREN IN MY COMMUNITY ARE
VERY HIGH BECAUSE OF. THE
PLAYGROUNDS ARE RIGHT. UP NEXT
TO THE INTERSTATE FREEWAYS SO AT
YOU KNOW LOTS OF COMMUNITIES WE
WANT. TO IMPROVE THEIR AIR
QUALITY AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR. YOU TO DO THIS
OUTRAGE- THEY WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THESE PROGRAMS.
BUT I'VE ALSO HEARD FROM AT
LEAST. SOME AIR DISTRICTS
INCLUDING SOUTH COAST. ON THAT-
YOU KNOW THIS PROGRAM IS. THERE
MAKE POTENTIALLY DON'T WANT TO
ACCEPT MORE COMMUNITIES TO
PARTICIPATE IN. AB SIX ONE
SEVEN- BECAUSE OF FUNDING OR THE
ROUTE THEY SAY THEY'RE LOSING
STAFF- BECAUSE OF THIS PROGRAM-
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT OR
WHAT ARE YOU DOING- TO SUPPORT
THEIR DISTRICTS. TO IMPLEMENT
THIS PROGRAM AND POTENTIALLY
ACCEPT MORE COMMUNITIES INTO
THIS PROGRAM. I AM SO GLAD THAT
YOU ASKED THIS QUESTION- I
DEFINITELY THINK WE HAVE BEEN A
CONVERSATION WITH SOUTH COAST
I'M HONESTLY ALL OF THE-
DISTRICTS REALLY THINKING ABOUT
HOW DO WE BASS TO SUPPORT THE
COMMUNITIES AND SUPPORT THEIR
DISTRICTS AND THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIS PROGRAM- I WOULD CALL
OUT THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT A
PROGRAM RESET TO THINK ABOUT
OTHER WAYS THAT WE CAN DO THIS
WORK OUTSIDE OF THAT CURRENT
MODEL AND SO PART OF WHAT I
THINK FOR US IS SO IMPORTANT
ABOUT. FIFTY P. THINK HE COMING
IN FRONT OF ALL OF YOU TO DATE
IS REALLY THINKING ABOUT HOW CAN
WE LOOK AT AND LEVERAGE OTHER
MODELS I THINK WE TALKED ABOUT
GRANTS PREVIOUSLY AND THINKING
THROUGH CAN WE USE THOSE AS WAYS
TO REALLY HELP AND I THINK A
POWER COMMUNITIES AND ALSO THINK
ABOUT HOW WE CAN EXPAND. AND
RESET THIS PROGRAM TO LIKE THINK
ABOUT HOW DO WE CAN ACCESS WITH
OTHER PLACES SO WE ARE MOST KIND
OF ARMOR CASE CALM CONVERSATIONS
WE AREN'T ADDRESSING NOT WITH
THEIR DISTRICTS AND KIND OF A
GUY HAD REALLY COLLABORATING
WITH THEM TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
MAKES SENSE. HOW DO WE USE THESE
PLANS AND THE BEST WAY POSSIBLE
THAT YOU CAN PROVIDE THAT
SUPPORT TO COMMUNITIES AND ALSO
BECAUSE YOU POINTED OUT SO THAT
COMMUNITIES ARE ACTUALLY
RECEIVING THESE FUNDS IN
pCOMING OUT FOR THEM. BECAUSE IN
AND OUR NOTES HE IT SAYS-
IMPERIAL. REVOKED AN APPLICATION
DUE TO LACK. OF IMPLEMENTATION
FUNDING- AND SO. I DON'T KNOW.
YOU DON'T. WHAT WHAT THE FUND
YOU KNOW IF THEY DON'T WHY THEY
DON'T FEEL THEY HAVE ENOUGH
FUNDING IS THAT SOMETHING WE CAN
ADDRESS. OR WILL BE ADDRESSED IN
THE PROCURE PROPOSE FUNDING HERE
FOR THIS PROGRAM. I WILL BE
COMPLETELY CANDID AND THIS IS
WHERE I WISHED YOU WERE IN
PERSON SO THAT YOU CAN SEE MY
THINGS WHEN I SAY THIS- YES.
THERE'S A REFERENCE FOR THIS IF
YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT WE CAN
FOLLOW UP WITH THIS I'VE YOU
KNOW I'VE I DO I JUST HAVE
CONCERNS THAT AS WE WORK TO
INCREASE THIS LIKE YOU SAID
THERE'S MANY COMMUNITIES ACROSS.
THE STATE RIGHT THAT MAY WANT TO
PARTICIPATE- IN THESE AIR
QUALITY PROGRAMS BUT ARE YOU
KNOW AS FAR AIR DISTRICTS ARE
DENYING THESE APPLICATIONS OUT
FOR DISCOURAGING- COMMUNITIES TO
APPLY- YOU KNOW THAT'S THE
CONCERN THAT I HAVE. IN THAT
WHAT ARE WE DOING- TO PREVENT
THAT FROM HAPPENING TO THEIR
DISTRICTS NEED MORE RESOURCES-
OR JUST. YOU KNOW WHAT CAN WE DO
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
COMMUNITIES THAT. WANT TO
PARTICIPATE ARE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE. WHO- I WILL IN I
TURNING ON MY CAMERA AND TRY TO
SPEAK S. AS POSSIBLE. THE
LEGISLATURE THANKS THE AMOUNT
FOR THE AIR DISTRICTS- IF THERE
IS A CONVERSATION TO INCREASE
THAT AMOUNT AND THAT WOULD BE
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL YOU ARE RATE
THAT IMPERIAL- WE TOOK A PAUSE
ON THAT APPLICATION- I'M A PART
OF IT IS RESOURCE AND- I THINK
THE SAME CHALLENGES SOUTH COAST
HAS ALSO PROBABLY BROUGHT UP I
MEAN. WE'RE MORE AND MORE
COMMUNITIES ARE WANTING TO BE
SIX ONE SEVEN COMMUNITIES AND
QUITE FRANKLY FUNDING IS FLAT.
SO YOU WILL HEAR ASKING YOU FOR
IT AND IF I'M JUST BEING. AND
TRYING TO TALK SLOWLY. WE ARE
ASKING YOU FOR THE SAME AMOUNT
AND YET WE ARE THINKING IF
ANYTHING- COMMUNITIES THERE'S
OVER FORTY COMMUNITIES THAT WANT
TO BE A PART OF THAT'S AN R. P.
THINK IT'S EXTREMELY SLOW
BECAUSE OF THAT SO. IF THERE CAN
BE A CONVERSATION AROUND AN
INCREASE OF RESOURCES WE WOULD
GREATLY WELCOME IT BECAUSE EVEN
THOUGH WE ARE THINKING ABOUT
RESETTING THIS PROGRAM AND ARE
HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH
BOTH THE COMMUNITIES AND THE AIR
DISTRICT. IT DOESN'T NEGATE THE
POINT THAT WE HAVE FAR MORE
COMMUNITIES AND WE ACTUALLY DO
RESOURCES TO DO THIS IMPORTANT
TYPE OF WORK. OKAY I'M
INTERESTED IN HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION AND I HOPE THAT
THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE OR- YOU
KNOW. ONE ON ONE OF WE CAN HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU.
IT LET ME HAVE MY VOICE TO THOSE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SEE- THE- THIS
FUNDING AT A HIGHER LEVEL OF
THIS IS A SUCCESSFUL. PROGRAM
AND- I GREW UP THE AS A YOUNG
CHILD TO AND EARLY ADOLESCENT
AND A COMMUNITY THAT WAS
HEAVILY. AFFECTED BY AIR
POLLUTION THE- IN THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY- AND I REMEMBER-
SUMMERS- A WHERE WE WERE HAVING
TO CUT BACK ON OUR ACTIVITIES-
WHERE YOU COULD FEEL THE
POLLUTION IN YOUR IN YOUR- CHEST
TO. THE EARLY OF SYMPTOMS OF-
WHAT GOD- COULD BECOME ASTHMA IN
LATER YEARS- THIS IS AN AN ISSUE
THAT HAS BEEN WITH US FOR
DECADES NOW. AND WE- HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL WITH SOME- AIR
POLLUTANTS AND UNSUCCESSFUL WITH
OTHERS. A WE NEED TO REDOUBLE
OUR EFFORTS IN THESE KINDS OF
PROGRAMS- THAT ARE. HELPFUL IN
THE COMMUNITIES THAT MOST NEED.
A HELP THEM AND SO I STRONGLY
SUPPORT ARE LOOKING FOR WAYS TO-
INCREASES FUNDING IN- THEREBY
INCREASE THE RELIEF- AT A
NOMINAL LEVEL ROWLEY- BUT SOME
RELIEF THE COMMUNITY SAID- CAN
RECEIVE. THE- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- OF YOUR PRESENTATION IT
STRIKES ME THAT- WE- WENT TO
QUESTIONS EARLY DIDN'T LIKE. WE
ACT NOT HEARD FROM- DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- OR MISTER BROWN HAS
BEEN. PATIENTLY WAITING. CAN WE
CAN WE HAVE THAT TESTIMONY TO
HELP QUESTIONS AND THEN WE'LL
GET TO MISTER BENNETT SORRY TO
HOLD YOU UP. YES SERGIO ACCURATE
DEPARTMENT BY IT- IT JUST KIND
OF GIVE GIVE US A COUPLE
COMMENTS OUT. OF THE FUNDING
JUST KIND OF YOU KNOW THE
REMINDERS OKAY- NOW. DID THEY
BECOME TEAM PROGRAM I HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY FUNDED OUT OF. B.
YOUR DISCRETIONARY PORTION OF
THE YEAR AT THE CAP AND TRADE
FUNDING. AND REALLY KIND OF ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS DEPENDING ON ON
THE LEVEL OF. REVENUE THAT ARE
TOO THAT THEY DID YOU KNOW
WORKING. WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ULTIMATELY. DETERMINE WHAT GETS
PRIORITIZED THAT FUNDED WITHIN
THAT BUT THERE ARE YOU KNOW
ANNUAL CHANGES IN THE LEVEL OF
MONEY THAT. WE HAVE TO BE COMING
INTO THE FINANCIAL THAT DOES
CHANGE. THE ANNUAL. UP WITH A
FUNDING. THE ONE POINT THAT I
THINK WOULD BE A- ON. BLACK YEAR
- TWENTY ONE A MALE. YOU KNOW AS
AS THEY WERE. THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE OUT BY ACT IT INCLUDED
BASICALLY TO. OR OF CAP AND
TRADE FUNDING. FOR THE- PORTION
. BECAUSE THEY'RE WAS NOT A CAP
AND TRADE PLAN THAT WOULD.
ADOPTED FOR TWENTY TWENTY. AND
VOTE THAT MONEY BASICALLY ALL
ROLLED OVER. AND THERE WERE
LARGER INVESTMENT BECAUSE THERE
WAS MORE MONEY AVAILABLE BECAUSE
THEY WILL TWO YEARS WORTH OF
DISCRETIONARY REVENUE AND AT. SO
THAT'S WHY NOW WE'RE GOING BACK
TO THE PEOPLE YEAR WORTH OF
REVENUE SO THERE IS A LITTLE BIT
OLDER. LOWER OVERALL AMOUNT I
WHICH WHICH YOU KNOW THAT'S WHY
YOU SEE THE CHANGE FROM LAST
YEAR TO THIS YEAR. THE
REFLECTION OF. THIS YEAR THE ONE
YEAR AMOUNT VERSUS LAST YEAR
WHAT THE TWO YEAR ABOUT BUDGET
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT THAT
CLARIFYING- JUST MADE. I JUST
GATHER OTHER POINT I'LL MAKE TO
IT WHEN IT COMES THE
DISCRETIONARY- WORKING. AT THIS
YEAR WE HAVE TO DO A LOWER.
INCOME EARNERS BUDGET A LOWER
AMOUNT TODAY WE'VE SEEN IN
PREVIOUS YEARS- PARTIALLY
BECAUSE THERE ARE MORE THINGS
NOW THAT COME OFF THE TOP. AS A
RESULT- THANK YOU VERY CHANGES
WHERE IT HURTS- IN PROGRAMS THAT
AT FOUR WEEKS. YEAH INTO A
FUNDING AMPLE THAT MEANS THERE'S
A LOT OF MONEY AVAILABLE THE
ROOM OF THE- AFTER THAT JUST NOT
ANOTHER- ACT THERE BY. ANY
LAUGHING ON IF. WE ARE OR WILL.
LOOK AT THE- YOU KNOW LATER-
CABINETRY ARE TO. WHAT NO
REVENUE. WILL BE ABLE TO COUNT
OR THE MAY REVISION ENERGY.
COMING OVER IN THE MAY REVISION
WITH WITH AN UPDATED OUTSIDE OF
REVENUE THAT. BEAT IT-
EXPENDITURES TO ACCOUNT FOR ANY
. POTENTIAL REVENUE INCREASES.
THAT WE THOUGHT THIS LAST OPTION
WILL BE A OF MAY REPAIRS. AND
REVIEW VALUE. AT THE WITHOUT A
OKAY GOOD NIGHT THE MONEY. THANK
THANK YOU HAVE A FOR THAT AND- I
KNOW IT SAID. BUT THIS IS A
PLACE WHERE WE MIGHT TO COME
SOME CHEN FUND DAHLE SO I'LL
JUST THROW THE OUT THERE- AND-
THE BROWN. LMAO ARE YOU OF A YES
YEAH THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON
BROWN WITH L. A. L. I'M GONNA
KEEP MY CAMERA- GIVEN SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE WE'VE
YOU BEFORE BUT- WE JUST WANTED
TO. WE DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC
COMMENT ON KIND OF THE SPENDING
ITEM OF AB SIX SEVENTEEN OF
COURSE THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS-
CONSISTENTLY FUNDED OUT OF ITS-
ARE UP- CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN OVER THE YEARS.
WE WANTED TO JUST PROVIDE SOME
VERY BRIEF COMMENTS ON THE GDR
UP REVENUE PICTURE- AND THE
SHORT STORY IS THAT- REVENUE IS
TRACKING ABOVE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ASSUMPTIONS
THAT WERE BUILT INTO THE JANUARY
BUDGETS. AND WE DO THINK THAT
REVENUE IS LIKELY TO BE HIGHER
THAN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ASSUMPTIONS- OF COURSE AS THE
COMMITTEE OF THE WHERE THERE'S
A- LOT OF UNCERTAINTY AROUND CAP
AND TRADE REVENUE AND THERE'S
VERY GOOD REASON TO BE CAUTIOUS
AND TAKING A CAUTIOUS BUDGETING
APPROACH. HOWEVER EVEN WITH THAT
SAID WE DO THINK THAT THERE WILL
LIKELY BE YOU KNOW SEVERAL
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS MORE
AVAILABLE FOR DISCRETIONARY
SPENDING THAT KIND OF
CONDITIONS. REMAIN THE WAY THEY
ARE- AND OF COURSE- WE WILL
UPDATE THE LEGISLATURE LATER
THIS SPRING IS MORE INFORMATION
ON KIND OF MARKET CONDITIONS.
BECOMES AVAILABLE AND THE MADE
RESULT RESULTS FROM THE MAY
AUCTION ALSO BECOME AVAILABLE
SO. NOT ONLY IN MY COMMENTS
THANK YOU- THANK YOU UP- MISTER
BENNETT NEIER THE ONLY- MEMBERS
ARE STILL ON THE DICE HERE BUT
WE ARE. QUIETLY CELEBRATING
GOOD- THAT ADDITIONAL- GIUGIARO
OF THAT WE HOPE WILL BE HER.
JUST BITE MY QUESTION WAS GOING
TO ASK ABOUT THE JUSTIFICATION
FOR THE CUTS IN AND I REALIZE
IT'S BECAUSE OF- AS THE G. G. R.
F. FUNDING. AND I WOULD TO.
SUGGESTED OVERALL ON BUT
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS THAT WE
SHOULDN'T TIE- THESE PROGRAMS
TWO. VARIABLE FUNDING LIKE WE
GET FROM THE CAP AND TRADE OF
SALE- BY A PROGRAM THAT THEY'VE
IS FREE AFTER VIEW THESE THINGS
AND I KNOW- THAT'S BEEN REFERRED
TO THAT IT'S WE'VE DISCOURAGES
GENERAL FUND- FROM BEING
INVOLVED IN THIS BUT- I THINK
THAT THIS IS APPROPRIATE
PARTICULARLY IN TIMES OF SURPLUS
LIKE WE HAVE. RIGHT NOW- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU AND-
WITH THAT WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE THREE. THAT IS A
CENTRALIZING AND EXPANDING
COMMUNITY MONITORING AND TO
BELIEVE WE HAVE- I ET CHIANG THE
DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE
A RP. TO PRESENT ON THAT. I DO
I'M GONNA TURN ON MY CAMERA JUST
NOW TO SAY HELLO I EXIST AND I'M
GOING TO TURN IT OFF JUST TO
MAKE. IT EASIER. OKAY WE HAVEN'T
SEEN YOU YET. HELLO HI OKAY HERE
ALL RIGHT. SINCE THE STATE'S
OKAY THANK YOU SO GOOD MORNING
KAREN AND MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
MY NAY IS EDIE AND I'M HERE
PRESENT PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
COMMUNITY AIR MONITORING. KARPUS
REQUESTING THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDS TO
HIRE CONTRACTORS TO USE
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGY AND MOBILE
MONITORING APPROACHES TO
DETERMINE AIR POLLUTION IMPACTS
IN COMMUNITIES STATEWIDE WITH A
FOCUS ON AIR TOXICS. AIR TOXICS
POSE A THREAT TO COMMUNITIES AND
THIS POLLUTION MAY NOT BE
MEASURED BY THE EXISTING FIXED
MONITORING STATIONS THAT WE AND
THE AIR DISTRICTS CURRENTLY
OPERATE. MOBILE ONITORING CAN
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE DATA
COVERING MORE COMMUNITIES WHICH
MAY ENABLE FURTHER INSIGHT INTO
REMAINING SOURCES AND AIR TOXICS
AND LEAD TO A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE STEPS THAT
ARE NEEDED TO REDUCE THESE
BURDENS. THIS WOULD BE A LIMITED
TERM CONTRACT OVER TWO YEARS
DURING WHICH THE CONTRACTORS
WOULD ENGAGE IN OUTRAGE WITH
COMMUNITIES TO BE MONITORED.
CONDUCTS APPROXIMATELY EIGHTEEN
MONTHS OF MONITORING. AND THEN
HELP COMMUNITIES UNDERSTAND AND
INTERPRET THE RESULTING DATA.
THE DATA WOULD ALSO BE
INTEGRATED INTO EIGHTEEN VIEW
WHICH IS CARDS PORTAL FOR AIR
MONITORING DATA. THIS PROPOSAL
AUGMENTS THE EIGHTY SIX ONE
SEVEN COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION
PROGRAM THAT WE WERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT MY INCLUDING
COMMUNITIES ALL ACROSS THE STATE
RATHER THAN ONLY THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN SELECTED TO PARTICIPATE IN
AB SIX ONE SEVEN. THIS WILL HELP
INCREASE UNDERSTANDING OF
COMMUNITY EXPOSURE. HELP
IDENTIFY POTENTIAL SOURCES
SENATE TAKE FOCUSED COMMUNITY AN
AGENCY ACTION AND HELP
PRIORITIZE LOCATIONS FOR AN
ESTABLISHMENT OF COMMUNITY SCALE
POLLUTION MONITORING IN THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU AND I CAN
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO WE HAVE-
ANY- ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
REPORT FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DR DRIVE OUR PARTY
FINANCING ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
THAT BUT HAPPY TO HELP WITH ANY
QUESTIONS RIGHT THANK YOU AND TO
ALEJO. ROSS BROWN AGAIN WITH THE
L. A. O. SO THIS IS THE THIRTY
MILLION IS REALLY THE ONLY OF
NEW PROGRAM THAT'S PART OF THIS
YEAR'S. PROPOSALS PART OF THE
CAP AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN-
IN CONCEPTS WE DO THINK THAT
EFFORTS TO IMPROVE THAT BOTH THE
SCOPE AND QUALITY OF AIR QUALITY
MONITORING SETUP MERIT AS THERE
ARE SOME GAPS IN THE EXISTING
AIR QUALITY MONITORING NETWORKS
NETWORKS- PARTICULARLY AT THE
NEIGHBORHOOD LEVEL. HOWEVER
BASED ON OUR INITIAL REVIEW IT'S
UNCLEAR WHY THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE
MONITORING APPROACH AND RAISES A
LOT OF QUESTIONS FOR US SO AS
THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDERS THIS
PROPOSAL IN WAYS THAT AGAINST
OTHER SPENDING PRIORITIES. SOME
QUESTIONS THAT MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER INDIRECT ADMINISTRATION
TO REPORT ON INCLUDE. WHY IS.
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED TO
STOP A NEW MONITORING APPROACH
INSTEAD OF EXPANDING EXISTING
MONITORING EFFORTS SUCH AS THE
EFFORTS THROUGH AB SIX SEVENTEEN
WHICH YOU JUST DISCUSSED. WHAT
IS THE ADVANTAGE TO USING MOBILE
MONITORING COMPARED TO OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES SUCH AS STATIONARY
MONITORS THAT CAN MEASURE
POLLUTION AT A SPECIFIC LOCATION
. TO THE STATE INVEST IN A ONE
TIME **** SNAPSHOT OF AIR
POLLUTION RATHER THAN IN A
SYSTEM THAT CAN HELP. THE STATE
TRACK CHANGES IN AIR POLLUTION
OVER TIME- I WILL THE FUNDING BE
USED TO INFORM FUTURE AIR
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT ACTIVITIES
SO FOR EXAMPLE. WHAT THE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION IS
COLLECTED FROM THE SEPARATE HOW
WILL THAT INFORMATION BE USED TO
INFORM FUTURE REGULATORY OR
SPENDING DECISIONS. AND THEN
FINALLY- THIS IS A ONE TIME KIND
OF ALLOCATION AS PROPOSED BUT-
AND A GOOD QUESTION FOR US AS
WELL THE STATE HAVE ANY ONGOING
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH.
UNDERTAKING THIS EFFORT- KIND OF
ONCE THE RESULTS THAT THE
INITIAL RESULTS ARE. ARE ARE IN
INTO THE KIND OF CREATE AN
EXPECTATION OF KIND OF AN
ONGOING EFFORT. SO WE THINK
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON THESE
QUESTIONS REALLY COULD HELP THE
LEGISLATURE OF VALUE WAIT THE
OVERALL MERITS OF THE PROPOSAL.
WITHOUT THAT ADDITIONAL DETAIL-
WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT
WANT TO CONSIDER REDIRECTING
THIS FUNDING TO OTHER EXISTING
PROGRAMS THAT ARE HIGH
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES SO. AND
THAT COMMENTS THANKS. THANK YOU
MISTER BROWN- MISS JANGANLAH ME
ASK YOU- A FOLLOW UP TO THE
QUESTIONS THAT- THE ALEJO- WAS
POSING- WHY WHAT WHY WOULD WE
WANT TO INVEST THIS MONEY AT
THAT IS THAT'S IN A PROGRAM.
THAT IS ESSENTIALLY A ONE TIME
SNAPSHOT AS OPPOSED TO SOMETHING-THAT IS MORE COMPREHENSIVE AND
SYSTEMATIC THAT ATTRACTS CHANGES
IN AIR POLLUTION OVER A LONGER
PERIOD OF TIME. SO IN THIS
PROGRAM WOULD ALLOW ITS TO GET
KIND OF THIS BASS. FOR EMISSIONS
IN COMMUNITIES AROUND THE ENTIRE
STATE AND YOU HEARD MS FLETCHER
TALK ABOUT HOW WE ARE STARTING
TO. REIMAGINE THE EIGHTY SIX ONE
SEVEN FOR GRAHAM. I DON'T THINK
ABOUT HOW WE PROVIDE BENEFITS
NOT JUST TO THE COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN SORT OF FORMALLY
SELECTED INTO THE PROGRAM THE
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE STATE.
AND SO WHAT THIS PROGRAM WOULD
DO IS ALLOW US TO PROVIDE ALL
THE COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE THE
SNAPSHOT OF WHAT THEIR AIR
QUALITY LOOKS LIKE AND A VERY
FINE SORT OF DETAILED LEVEL AND
SO THAT THEY HAVE THAT
INFORMATION IT'S TRANSPARENCY
FOR ALL OF THESE COMMUNITIES.
AND GIVES THEM A HEAD START I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
AIR QUALITY IN THEIR COMMUNITY
IS- DEPENDING ON WHAT WE SEE IN
THAT MONITORING IT MIGHT GIVE US
SOME CLUES ABOUT SOURCES THAT WE
WEREN'T EXPECTING TO SEE IN
THOSE AREAS. AND TO HELP US
TARGET ADDITIONAL TOXIC
MONITORING THAT MIGHT BE YOU
KNOW A LITTLE BIT MORE DETAILS
OR AND IN IN A SORT OF A SPECIAL
MONITORING PROGRAM TO LOOK AT
THINGS THAT WE CAN EXPECT WELL I
UNDERSTAND- THE VALUE THAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO WHAT I'M
ASKING IS IF THERE WERE TO BE A
MORE- AMBITIOUS. AND ROBUST AND
LONG TERM- A PROJECT THAT
INCLUDED THE- CREATING A
BASELINE BUT- YOU KNOW MIGHT BE
MORE EXPENSIVE BUT- IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT IF WE WERE ABLE TO GET-
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. PLUS
A LONG TERM- ADDED THE- A
BENEFIT. WHY WOULD WE NOT DO
THAT AND I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT
EXISTS BUT- MIGHT. YES THERE ARE
I MEAN I THINK THAT PART OF THIS
IS LOOKING AT SORT OF WHAT IS
THE GOAL THAT WE ARE TRYING TEN
TO ACHIEVE AND SO IN ANY AIR
MONITORING PROGRAM THE GOAL YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE TO BE VERY CLEAR
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU'RE EXPENDING YOUR RESOURCES
IN THE RIGHT WAY AND SO AS I
SAID- WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE ALL
COMMUNITIES WHERE THIS ONE TIME
SNAPSHOT OF WHAT THEY'RE WHAT
THEY'RE- AT AIR QUALITY IS RIGHT
NOW. IF THIS PROGRAM IS
SUCCESSFUL WE WOULD LOOK FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO COME
BACK AND MONITOR AIR QUALITY SO
THAT WE CAN COMPARE THAT AGAINST
THE SNAPSHOT SO LET ME ASK MY
QUESTION A DIFFERENT WAY BECAUSE
I. DON'T THINK WERE- A
COMMUNICATING HIS WEALTH I'D
LIKE TO- SORRY IS THERE ARE WIDE
YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S PROBABLY
THE WAY I'M ASKING MY QUESTIONS.
I'M IT IS THEIR TECHNOLOGY- OUT
THERE OR THAT'S PROPOSED THAT-
COULD PROVIDE. THE INFORMATION
AND BASS LINE AND ALL THE THINGS
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. BUT
BE MORE INCLUSIVE OF OTHER
INFORMATION AND- MONITOR- LONG
TERM CHANGES MID. NEAR MID TERM
AND LONG RIGHT- CHANGE YEAH.
YEAH NO I APPRECIATE THIS THE
QUESTION. SO WE HAVE A NETWORK
OF ABOUT FOURTEEN TOXICS
MONITORING SITES RIGHT NOW
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THESE ARE LONG TERM SITES
THAT WE HAVE BEEN AT WORK
DECADES QUITE HONESTLY. AND SO
WE CAN USE THOSE SITES T
EVALUATE THEIR- VERY
SOPHISTICATED. MONITORING IN
TERMS OF THE KINDS OF- OF
SUBSTANCES THAT WE CAN DO TAX-
AND WE CAN LOOK AT TRENDS AT
THOSE SITES SO OVER. THE AND
OVER THE YEARS WE CAN SEE WE'VE
SEEN REDUCTIONS IN PRETTY MUCH
ALL TOXICS AT ALL OF THOSE
SITES. SO BUT THEY ARE ONLY
FOURTEEN SITES AROUND THE WHOLE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE ALSO DO
PROGRAMS WHERE WE TO YOU WHAT I
WOULD CALL SPECIAL MONITORING.
SO THAT THE PROGRAM THAT THE
LEGISLATURE FUNDED THAT WE CALL
SNAPS. AND IT'S A PROGRAM THAT
MONITORS AND IT'S THAT SORT OF A
SPECIAL STUDY WHERE WE GO TO
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE DOWNWIND
OF- HOPE PETROLEUM PRODUCTION.
AND WE SET UP IT IS A TEMPORARY
MONITORING BUT IT IS IT'S BEEN
OVER THERE FOR ABOUT A YEAR. SO
GAIN WE SET UP A STATIONARY
SITE BUT IT'S TEMPORARY WHERE
THERE FOR A YEAR WE LOOK AT THE
COMMUNITIES ON WHERE WE SHOULD
CITE THE MONITORS. AND SAID THAT
PROVIDES. US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SEE OVER THE COURSE CITY YOUR
HOW EMISSIONS CHANGE. PERHAPS
SEASON BASE CIRCUIT BECAUSE
THERE'S DIFFERENT ACTIVE HAPPEN
AND YOU KNOW IN THAT PRODUCTION
FACILITY. ARE IT ALSO PROVIDES
US WITH ENOUGH INFORMATION THAT
WE CAN WORK WITH- A WE HOT ON
THE OFFICE AT ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH HAZARD ASSESSMENT TO DO
HEALTH RISK ASSESSMENTS BASED ON
THAT DATA BECAUSE PREPARE. FOR A
LONGER PERIOD OF TIME. IN
DEVELOPING THIS PROPOSAL- DID
YOU- EVALUATE OTHER APPROACHES.
WELL I EIGHT IF THEY SAID- IF
THE INTENT IS TO TRY TO PROVIDE
ALL COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
WITH A BASELINE OF WHAT THEIR
AIR QUALITY LOOKS LIKE AND THIS
IS REALLY THE FASTEST WAY TO DO
IT SO. GRANTED YOUR DID YOU
EVALUATE OTHER. PROPOSALS THAN
THE ONE. THAT YOU'RE PUTTING
FORWARD HERE TODAY. I WOULD SAY
THE ISN'T ANOTHER WAY TO PROVIDE
THIS SNAPSHOT IN THIS QUICKLY IN
THIS QUICKLY AND PROBABLY FOR
THIS COST- I'D JUST THE YOU KNOW
PROGRAM THAT I WAS TALKING AT
ABOUT WERE BEACH YOU AND IN
ORDER TO KIND OF GO SOMEPLACE
FOR A YEAR AND YOU KNOW THAT'S
ONE SMALL COMMUNITY THAT WE DO
AND IF WE DID THAT AROUND THE
ENTIRE STATE THAT WOULD TAKE.
THAT WOULD TAKE A FEW YEARS TO
GET TO EVERY COMMUNITY I SEE
OKAY- THANK YOU FOR THAT
INFORMATION. OF FOR YOUR
RESPONSES. MISTER BENNETT- HE- I
JUST TO WANT TO WEIGH IN BUT
OVERALL. I'VE HAD A FAIR AMOUNT
OF EXPERIENCE WITH THE- LUCIEN
MONITORING DONE IN VENTURA
COUNTY THE APPLICATION OF THE
PESTICIDE SO WE HAVE ONE OF
THOSE FOURTEEN- AREAS- AND
THERE'S CONSTANT REQUEST FOR
OTHER COMMUNITIES TO HAVE THERE
ARE TESTED- SO I CERTAINLY SEE
THE ADVANTAGE- THAT THE STAFF.
IS JUST TRYING TO REFER TO IN
TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO GET TO A
COMMUNITY AT LEAST SAY ONE TIME
YES IT THERE IS A PROBLEM HERE
THERE'S NOT A PROBLEM HERE SO I
THINK THESE ARE IT'S GOOD FOR US
TO BE TRYING TO EVALUATE THIS-
IF THERE. IF WE ONLY HAVE
FOURTEEN AT THIS POINT TIME THE
IDEA THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO A BLANK AT THE STATE AND IN
TERMS OF MORE PERMANENT
INFRASTRUCTURE- US A STEP IN IN
MY MIND A STEP BEFORE YOU DO
THAT IS YOU. GO OUT AND YOU TAKE
THE SAMPLES TO FIND OUT WHERE
YOU MIGHT WANT TO LOCATE THOSE
SO- SO OVERALL I APPRECIATE-
JUST FROM OUR COMMUNITIES ASK
OUR AND REQUEST OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRY TO HAVE A
MOBILE OF TESTING SO I COME IN.
AND MAYBE I DON'T KNOW HOW LONG
THEY WOULD STAY A COUPLE OF DAYS
MAYBE TO CHECK DIFFERENT TIMES
OF THE DAY- BUT I SEE SOME SOME
SIGNIFICANT ADVANTAGES THERE- IF
THERE'S SOME OTHER WAYS TO TRY
TO GET MORE BANG FOR THIS- BUT
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR IT BUT I DO-
GENERALLY SEE SOME REAL
ADVANTAGES TO THE- ABILITY TO
GET. LOTS OF PLACES IN THE STATE
TEN AT LEAST BEGIN THE PROCESS
OF FIGURING OUT WHERE WHERE WE
MIGHT WANT TO PUT. PERMANENT
STATIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THE ADD A COMMENT- AND THAT-
CONCLUDES THE ISSUE THREE. AGAIN
WERE- TAKING NO VOTES ON THAT-
AND THE ISSUE TODAY BUT- THIS IS
THE POINT AND- IN THE MEETING
WHERE I GET TO ASK IF THERE'S
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ABOUT
NON DISCUSSION ITEMS. SEEING
NONE WILL MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IS THERE ANYBODY IN THE
ROOM THERE APPEARS TO BE
VIRTUALLY NOBODY IN THE ROOM
OTHER THAN THAT TO SERGEANTS- SO
I'M GONNA ASSUME THERE'S NOBODY
IN THE ROOM WHO WANTS TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT- HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND- WILL- ASK OF
OUR OPERATORS OUT THERE AND
AVAILABLE OPERATOR. ARE YOU WITH
US. I AM. GREAT AND FOR THOSE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO AHEAD. LET
ME HAVE A REPEAT THE A PHONE
NUMBER TO CALL IN ON AND THAT'S
877-692-8957 ACCESS CODE. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR SEVEN
AGAIN EVERYONE WILL HAVE UP TO
ONE MINUTE TO SPEAK. AND THE
OPERATOR BACK TO YOU. YOU IF
YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT'S
THE ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. GO TO OUR FIRST LINE IN Q.
IT'S NUMBER NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD MORNING ROBERT HALF OF
THIS YEAR CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT.
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
CALIFORNIA AND THAT MORE THAN A
THIRD OF THE STATE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS AND MORE THAN 75%
OF THE- THANK YOU. FOR YOUR MAY
ISSUED YET ANOTHER DIRE. ABOUT
THE CLIMATE CRISIS. AND THE
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS
CONTINUE TO LIVE IN AREAS THAT
ARE OUT OF ATTAINMENT WITH
FEDERAL AIR QUALITY STANDARDS.
THE LEGISLATURE BACK SECOND
WAGER LOCK UP YOUR. ARTICLE
CLICK HERE MESSAGE TRY. INTO
ESSENTIAL CHART INFRASTRUCTURE
IN ORDER TO. WE CAN NO LONGER OR
HALF MEASURES SO ME YEARS HERE
OUT COMBUSTION VEHICLE. WE LIVE
PARTNER GOVERNOR'S BY BUT A
WORKING IT TOO MANY THEM THAT
ARE OVER THE DECADE RIGHT THAN
BEING GUARANTEED AND YEAR.
COLLEDGE SHOULD A LOAN MORTGAGE
BACK IN THE COME BUDGET WHEN WE
KNOW THE STATE WILL HAVE FUNDS
AVAILABLE. WE ARE CLOSE REPORT
DIRECTLY. BUT CHAO HAD.
INCLUDING ONE FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR FELL. MISSION
FUNDING. THANK YOU VERY FOR THAT
TO. THANK YOU FOR. NEXT WE HAVE
LINE TWELVE. HI GOOD TERRIFYING
FROM THE COW HIGH TO ACCOUNT
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON THE
HEARING TODAY I JUST LIKE THE TO
A PUB THE PROBE THAT EACH FIFTY
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK FUNDING
UNDER THAT PACKAGE BIRTH OF THE
CLEAN FOR. SECOND CLEAN REBATE
PROJECT AND THIRD H. B. I. P.
FOR THE COR PROJECT ALL THOSE
PRO WE'D LOVE TO SEE INCREASE IN
FRONT HAS BEEN VERY UP IN OVER.
THE PLEA CONSIDER INCREASING THE
FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM. THE
REMAINDER OF THIS ATTACK WE ARE
LUCKY SUPPORT BUT THE GOVERNOR
BACKPACK. HOWEVER WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE PARITY IN FUNDING FOR ALL
OF THE AT FUND. ERA MISSION
VEHICLES INCLUDING THE THOUSAND
DRAYAGE TRUCKS IN TRANSIT BUT
THE- ALONG WITH THE SUPPORTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE BUS TRUCK
OFF ROAD. AS WELL AS THE
EMERGING OPPORTUNITIES AND THE
PORT ELECTRIFICATION IS THE
CENTRAL THE HYDROGEN AND FUEL
ELECTRIC VEHICLE TECHNOLOGIES
ARE INCLUDED IN THE FUNDING. AND
ARE ADMINISTERED WITH PARITY
MEANING HALF AND HALF BETWEEN
THAT. AND FEEL POLITICAL. MAN
FINALLY WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF ADDING A PIECE IN THE- BUDGET
PORT HYDROGEN REFUELING IN THE
LIGHT DUTY FACE OF A LOT OF
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT DAY AND
I REALLY MUCH APPRECIATE. THAT
THE QUESTION HOWEVER AT THE
UNTIL THE HYDROGEN DOES GET THE
FEELING INFRASTRUCTURE FUND. TO
SUPPORT THE GROWING NUMBER OF
FIELD DR DRIVERS LIKE MYSELF.
THANK. YOU FOR YOUR TIME. NEXT
WE LINE TWENTY SIX. HI MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
MARKER PRIOR I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF- CHARGE POINT. CHARGEPOINT AS
YOU KNOW AS A CAMEL BASED
CALIFORNIA COMPANY AND HAS BEEN
A LEADER IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE EEVEE CHARGING EQUIPMENT AND
NETWORKED SERVICES WE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
AND IN PARTICULAR. ITS FOCUS ON
SEVEN VESTMENTS AND
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES. AS THIS COMMITTEE
CONSIDERS THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE BUDGET WE RECOMMEND
THE COMMITTEE TO ALSO LOOK AT
THE FEDERAL FORMULA FUNDS IN
COMPETITIVE GRANTS THAT ARE PART
OF THE- TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE. FINALLY WE ALSO BELIEVE
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO BE AWARE OF STE
STATE OF THE STATE BALLOT
MEASURE WHICH WOULD- PROVIDE FOR
FUNDING FOR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE PROGRAMS AND WILD-
WILDFIRE RELATED ACTIVITY.
CHARGEPOINT BELIEVES THAT WITH A
THOUGHTFUL AND COLLABORATIVE
BUDGETING PROCESS AS WELL AS
FOUGHT FOR PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT
AT THE CDC. CALIFORNIA MAY USE
THESE FUNDS IN AN EFFICIENT AND
EQUITABLE MANNER TO ENSURE THAT
NO CALIFORNIAN IS LEFT BEHIND IN
THE STATE'S TRANSITION TO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR HOLDING THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WE
HAVE COMMENT FROM LINE THIRTY
SEVEN. A GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STEVEN MYERS ON BEHALF OF
THE ELECTRICAL VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION OR A COP AT THE NOT
FOR PROFIT ORGANIZATION
COMPRISED OF LEADERS THROUGHOUT
THE VALUE CHAIN OF THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING INDUSTRY THAT
ADVANCE THE GOAL OF THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IN WHICH
THE MARKET FORCES OF INNOVATION
COMPETITION AND CONSUMER CHOICE.
DR BE EXPEDITIOUS AND EFFICIENT
ADOPTION OF MEETINGS AND THE
DEPLOYMENT OF P. B. TARGET THE
STRUCTURE SO WE'RE EXTREMELY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED ZERO EMISSIONBUDGET
PACKAGE AND WE THINK THE
ADDITIONAL SIX POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS AND A STRONG MARKET
SIGNAL THAT CALIFORNIA IS
COMMITTED TO REVOLUTIONIZING THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. AND
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY FUNDING
FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE WE NEED
TO MEET OUR AMBITIOUS CLIMATE
AND HE'D. BE AN OPTION GOALS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK NEXT
WE HAVE LINE. THIRTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON- IF YOU CARE MEMBERS
JULIE NONALCOHOLIC BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION FIRST
CAO ET EVEN LIKE THAT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP. IN THE LAST
YEAR'S STATE BUDGET THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION LED THE NATION
WITH THE LARGEST COMMITMENT OF
PUBLIC DOLLARS TO ZERO EMISSION
TRANSPORTATION FUTURE EVER MADE
IN ANY STATE. BUDGET ALSO
COMMITTED A MULTI YEAR
INVESTMENTS AND MANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS FOR THE FIRST TIME
WHICH PROVIDED MARKET CERTAINTY
AND CREDIBILITY AND SUPPORTED
PROGRAM THE FACT THAT THAT.
KELLY FIFTY ALONG WITH COLD OF
KERR IN ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING THE PRIVATE SECTOR
INVESTORS. NEEDS BUILDING OUT
THEIR MISSION TECHNOLOGIES NON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS AND
CONSUMER GROUPS STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL CONTINUE
AND EXPAND THE PROGRAM WE HAVE
THREE EDITIONS THAT WE FEEL
SHOULD BE PART OF THE FINAL
BUDGET FIRST DIRECT CAR TO ALLOW
MEDIUM AND LARGE FLEET. CHOOSING
TO PICTURE BATTERY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES TO COMPLY FOR H. THAT.
THE CHANGES MADE TO THE PROGRAM
IN THE FALL ELIMINATE THESE
INCENTIVES FOR BATTERY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES THROUGH MEDIUM AND
LARGE FLEET. WE SUPPORTED IN A
MECHANISM PRIORITIZE SMALL
FLEET. OWNER IT'S JUST MUCH TOO
EARLY IN THE MARKET TO ELIMINATE
THEM FROM BATTERY ELECTRIC AND
MEDIUM AND LARGE BY NEED TO ASK
YOU TO RUN AGAIN. IF YOU COULD
JUST COVER YOUR OTHER TO
PLANNING VERY QUICKLY. YEAH AND
THEN WE ASK YOUR R. P. THE
CHANGE MADE THEIR- B. RO BACK A
WELL WE'VE CUT OUT THE MIDDLE
CLASS. EIGHT THAT NEED TO BE.
NOW BY BRINGING WITH THAT THANK
YOU THANK VERY MUCH. NEXT WE
HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE FORTY
SIX. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL ON
BEHALF OF THE PACIFIC MERCHANT
SHIPPING ASSOCIATION HERE TODAY
TO VOICE OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS IN PORTLAND
EDUCATION. WANNA HIGHLIGHT THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS SUGGESTS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONSIDER
ADOPTING TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO PROHIBIT PORTLAND EDUCATION
DOLLARS FROM BEING USED ON
TECHNOLOGY THAT COULD BE
AUTOMATED. HISTORICALLY THIS
PROHIBITION IT SERVED AS AN
IMPEDIMENT TO POINT ACTORS
ACCESSING THESE DOLLARS WHICH IS
ULTIMATELY STIFLE THEIR
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES REQUESTED THE
LEGISLATURE ENGAGE WITH IMPACTED
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING PMSA- ON
THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE IT'S
FINALIZED IN THE BUDGET BILL.
THAT WOULD BRING THESE DOLLARS
ONLINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY SEVEN. HELLO TO THE
STATE AS BEING AN OVERLY
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE COMPATIBILITY
WORKING WITH COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE MONTH CALIFORNIA REGARDING
ITEM ONE WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
SHOOTING MAN WANT TO BE SURE
THAT INVESTMENT INTO CLEAN
VEHICLE THAT COUPLED WITH
INVESTMENT IN CLEAN ELECTRICITY
STARTS AT NON RENEWABLE ENERGY
SOURCES THAT UNDERPINS SO MUCH
OF OUR GENERATED ELECTRICITY
PERPETUATE RACIAL INJUSTICE
DISPROPORTIONATE HARMS LOW
COUNTRIES OF COLOR. TO THE
EXTENT OF THE STATE AND HYDROGEN
IT MUST BE GREEN HYDROGEN
PRODUCED WITHOUT THE USE OF
PUTTING COPPERFIELD OR
BIOMETHANE PRODUCED LIKE A DUTCH
AFTER PUTTING LOW CARBON BRIDGE
FUEL SIMPLY DO NOT CUT IT FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH AND CLIMATE
REALITIES MOVING TO ITEM TWO WE
SUPPORT INCREASING FUNDING FOR
THE EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN PROGRAM
HOWEVER THERE MUST BE
PROGRAMMATIC AND PREVENT
ATTACHED TO THE FUNDING JUST
THIS MONTH. MANY OF OUR MARKETS
NOT PROVIDED NUMBER OF HOW MUCH
FUNDING THEY CAN PUT TOWARDS
EMISSIONS MEASURES FOR THEIR OWN
COMMUNITY THE AFTER YEARS OF
PARTICIPANTS THROUGHOUT THE
SEVENTEENTH. ASKING DISTRICT
COURT OF IN ORDER TO BE EQUAL
PARTNERS IN THE PROCESS. THE
COUPLE THE MOST IMPORTANT BUT TO
BE TO THE FRONT OUR- YOU READY.
MY AND ON A- POLLUTION THE- TO
THE KEY DOWN AREA. INCENTIVE
PRIMARILY AND DIRECTLY BENEFIT
RECORD BOB. AND TRANSPARENT AND
PER. BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. A LINE FOR
EIGHT. SHE MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE CAN THAT THE BALLOT OUT WITH
THE BAY AREA ERIC MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT AT THE LA HAVE NOTED-
DISTRICT INCENTIVE PROGRAMS SUCH
AS THE FARMER PROGRAM CARL MOYER
PROGRAM IN THE SEVENTEEN
INCENTIVE PROGRAM OUR HEADS AND
TAILS THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
PROGRAMS IT REDUCING NITROGEN
OXIDES PARTICULATE POLLUTION AND
TOXIC DIESEL PARTICULATE MATTER
IN OUR IT IS ALSO PRIMARILY
TARGETED IN COMMUNITIES WITH
HIGH POLLUTION BURDEN
UNFORTUNATELY FARMER IN THE
SEVENTEEN INCENTIVES ARE SLATED
FOR REDUCTION COMPARED TO
PREVIOUS YEARS AND THE MOYER
NINE TWENTY THREE PROGRAM WHICH
SUNSET NEXT YEAR HAS NOT BEEN
PRIOR TO. PRIORITIZE FOR RE
AUTHORIZATION WE ASKED THE
FARMER IN THE SEVENTEEN
INCENTIVES BE INCREASED AND THAT
THE CALL MORE NINE TWENTY THREE
PROGRAM BE PRIORITIZED THE RE
AUTHORIZATION REGARDING EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION
PORTION OF FUNDING THAT STAFF
NOTED THE BAY AREA HAD THAT AT
THE NEW COMMUNITY THE NEW
COMMUNITY TO OUR PROGRAM BALK AT
SAME TIME EXPECTING TO READ
RECEIVE A CUT IMPLEMENTATION
FUNDING FROM PREVIOUS YEARS
MEANING OUR COMMUNITIES WILL
RECEIVE 50% LATIN SUPPORT.
COMPARED TO PREVIOUS YEARS THAT
FLAGSTAFF REPORT LET'S
MONITORING AND LET THE BILITY TO
MEET THE GOAL AB SIX SEVENTEEN
IT WOULD BE HIGHLY SUPPORTIVE OF
EFFORTS BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR SIX
SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION AS WELL
AS LOOKING AT THE COULD PAINT
MULTI YEAR FUNDING PROGRAMS
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. LINES. FIVE OH. THIS IS
VOA CRAB OUT BECAUSE THEY CAN DO
JUST COAST REGION STATES UNDER
CHILD REDUCE CARE AND CON WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH MESSAGES
COMMUNITIES THAT'S THE ISSUE TO
BE WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE WITH
STAFF AND NUMBER COMMENTS THAT
THE EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN PROGRAM
INCREASE FUNDING WE APPRECIATE
AB SIX SEVENTEEN INTIMIDATION
FUNDING AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR AIR DISTRICTS BUT THE
PROGRAM IS SEVERELY UNDERFUNDED
WE ASK THAT YOU PROVIDE
INCREASED AND SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING TO COVER ACTUAL PROGRAM
COSTS. NEVER COMMUNITIES HAS
GROWN AND AIR DISTRICTS ARE
WORKING AT A DEFICIT TO
IMPLEMENT IT. EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN AT THE FUNDING BEING.
HOWEVER IT'S POINTED OUT BY. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAS REDUCE IT
WE HAVE TO PROVIDE INCREASE THE
STATE FUNDING TO A PRIOR. A
MEASURE ACTIONS THAT PROTECT THE
HEALTH OF THE STATE'S
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AND
FOR ISSUE ONE SIGNIFICANT
SUSTAINABLE AND FOR THE FUNDING
IS CRITICAL FOR MEETING HEALTH
BATES FEDERAL AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS EXHILARATING SORELY
NEEDED NEAR TERM EMISSION
REDUCTIONS. WE SUPPORT PUTTING
HEAVY DUTY ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY FOR MATH THE PLAN IN
THE FUTURE HOWEVER GIVEN OUR
NEED TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
NOW WE SUPPORT FUNDING TO
REPLACE HEAVY DUTY DIESEL TRUCKS
WITH NEAR ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS
WHICH ARE LOWER COSTS MORE COST
EFFECTIVE AND PROVIDE MORE
IMMEDIATE AIR POLLUTION AND GHG
EMISSION REDUCTIONS. FINALLY WE
SUPPORT WE OPPOSITION OF KARL
MOYER EIGHTY NINE TWENTY PROGRAM
FUNDING FOR AIR DISTRICTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. CONNECT COMMENT
OF MINE. NUMBER TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SHARED LIMON
MEMBERS ALCHEMY GRAHAM OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
WE SUPPORT THE CATEGORY OF
INVESTMENT IN THE IT
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSED MORE
APPEARED ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
PACKAGE BUT STRONGLY ENCOURAGED
THE LEGISLATURE TO GO FURTHER TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THEIR
MISSION TRANSIT BY SEVEN FIVE
AND WORKING UP WHICH EIGHTIES
AND RELATED INFRASTRUCTURE THE
CONTACTS TRANSIT AGENCIES ARE
REQUIRED BY THE REGULATION TO
CHECK TRANSITION TO COMPLETELY.
THERE WAS ABOUT THREE BY TWENTY
FORTY AND THIS FUNDING IS
CRITICAL TO REDUCE THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE
TECHNOLOGIES INTO AVOID. AGENCY
LEVEL TRADE OFF. YOU OUR STATE
RAIL AND VERY AGENCIES WILL ALSO
BE SUCH TO ZERO TRAINED
REQUIREMENTS UNDER AIR REGULATE
. THAT WILL CREE NEW IMPACTS FOR
THE- RELATIVE TO THE L. A. OKAY.
I WILL. THAT AIR BE REGULAR.
TRANSIT EIGHTY AGENCY ARE
WORKING TO DEVELOP TRANSITION
PLANS. THAT DETAIL THEIR PROCESS
AND TIMELINE FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
BUILD OUT TO SUPPORT THEIR THEIR
MISSION PLEASE. WE BELIEVE THIS
JUSTIFIED MAINTAINING FUNDING
FOR ZERO EMISSION INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR TRANSIT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE HAVE A LINE FORTY
FOUR. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BRIAN
WHITE ON BEHALF OF CATALINA
CHANNEL EXPRESS IT IS A
PRIVATELY OWNED COMPANY
REGULATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION OF
THE CALMING CARRIER IN OPERATES
A FLEET OF EIGHT HIGH SPEED
PASSENGER FERRIES THAT PROVIDE
RELIABLE AND AFFORDABLE SERVICE
TO AND FROM CATALINA. BUT THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS A YEAR
RECORDS AND AS OUR MAIN ECONOMY
IN THE AREA SPEAKING ON THE
OTHER GOVERNOR ZERO MISSION
FUNDING PACKAGE THAT WE KNOW
EXPRESSED SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
REQUEST FOR TWENTY MILLION TO
INVEST IN DEMONSTRATION AND
PILOT PROJECTS FOR ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES. AND ENGINES AND
HIGH CARBON EMITTING SECTORS
UNFORTUNATELY A ZERO EMISSION
ENGINES ARE NOT A NEAR TERM
OPTION FOR CALAVERAS CHARTER
EXPRESS AT THE TECHNOLOGY DOES
NOT EXIST FOR OCEAN GOING
VESSELS OF THIS SIZE AND SPEED
THAT IS NECESSARY TO CARRY
PASSENGERS. AS SUCH WE WOULD
LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER
PROVIDING ONE TIME FUNDING OF AN
ADDITIONAL THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE GENERAL FUND FOR
THE CAR MOTOR PROGRAM THAT WOULD
HELP IMPLEMENT KARPPINEN
COMMERCIAL HARBOR CRAFT RULES
WHICH ARE SCHEDULED FOR ADOPTION
NEXT WEEK. THESE RULES ARE
DESIGNED TO RESULT IN LESS
EMISSIONS WHICH WE SUPPORT BUT
WE UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO MOVE
IN THIS DIRECTION AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
CALIFORNIA EVERY SUPPORT TO DO
THAT. HOWEVER WHERE THE ONLY
FERRY SERVICE IN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S REGULATED BY THE CTBC AND
WE CARRY THREE HUNDRED NINETY
PASSENGERS PER TRIP AND WE'RE
AFRAID THAT THESE NEW RULES WILL
CUT OUR A PASSENGER. AND A HALF
WE CANNOT PASS THESE COSTS ONTO
PASSENGERS AND WE NEED STATE
FUNDING TO HELP US MEET THE GOAL
THANK BY PROVIDING ADEQUATE
FUNDING FOR CURRENT LAWYER. OKAY
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN FORWARD TO
WITH YOU ON THE LEGISLATURE ON
THIS IS. THANK YOU. NEXT TO HAVE
A LINE EIGHTEEN ONE EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS HEIDI HARMON AND I REPRESENT
THE ROMERO INSTITUTE FLAT SCREEN
CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE AND IN
SPEAKING OUT IN SUPPORT OF
PROTECTING THE GOVERNOR'S BOLD
BUDGET INVESTMENTS IN POLLUTION
FREE ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION BUT
WE MUST RECOGNIZE THAT CLEAN CAR
PROGRAMS THAT FOCUS ON LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ARE
CHRONICALLY UNDERFUNDED.
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES SUFFER
MOST FROM AIR POLLUTION AND THE
RECENT INCREASE IN GAS PRICES
ARE DISSEMINATING. FAMILY BUDGET
. MEETING PEOPLE ME MY PRIOR IN
BACK. INCENTIVES IN WORKING
FAMILIES AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR COLOR. WHICH TO ELECTRIC
CARS TRUCKS AND BUSES THAT ARE
POLLUTION FREE AND CHEAPER TO
OWN AND OPERATE. IF DONE RIGHT
CALIFORNIANS EQUITABLE CLEAN CAR
PROGRAMS HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
BE A RELIABLE SOURCE OF SUPPORT
TO EMPOWER WORKING FAMILIES AND
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR TO SWITCH
TO CLINTON POLLUTION FREE
TRAVEL. THAT IS WHY I'M CALLING
ON YOU TO SUPPORT THE INVEST. IN
CLEAN AIR CHARGE AHEAD
COALITION'S RECOMMENDATION
SUPPORTED BY NEARLY FIFTY
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION. THAT
INCLUDE AT LEAST ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN EQUITY FOCUS
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS
AND ALSO INVESTED TWO BILLION
DOLLARS FOR ZERO EMISSION
CHARGING TO SUPPORT. TO ENSURE
EXPANDED ACCESS TO CHARGING
STATIONS ESPECIALLY IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AND
ASK FOR NEAR. MULTI FAMILY HOMES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUH.
RAIL LINE. TWENTY SEVEN. ON
BEHALF BLUEGREEN ALLIANCE A
PARTNERSHIP OF ORGANIZED LABOR
AND ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
WORKING TOWARD A CARBON
EQUITABLE ECONOMY. IF YOU BY
EIGHTY SIX THAT IS REFLECTIVE OF
THE PROGRESS NEXT STEPS
CALIFORNIA MUST TAKE TO ENSURE
HIGH GROWTH TRANSITION TO A
CLEAN ECONOMY THAT SUPPORTS GOOD
JOBS FOR DISADVANTAGED
CALIFORNIANS AND EQUITY PER
COMMUNITIES WORK FIND A BEST
TAKE PLACE. IN THE CENTRAL STATE
FUND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF WORK
FOR STANDARD THAT INCLUDES A
PROCUREMENT ON CLIMATE SPENDING
WITH RESPECT TO ISSUES- WE
SUPPORT PROVIDING THE RESOURCES
PURSUANT TO AB. SEVEN EIGHT CARD
- TO DEVELOP THE AND IMPLEMENT
PROCESSES FOR APPLE GOAL PROGRAM
WHICH ABILITY TO POLITICS FOR.
AND LABOR LAWS AND THE THEIR
EVERY. THANK YOU FOR OPPORTUNITY
PROVIDE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE SEVEN TWO- YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAPLAIN MEMBERS BOB
MY NAME IS LAURA LANE AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PORT
AUTHORITIES ARE KAPPA WHICH
REPRESENTS CALIFORNIA'S ELEVEN
PORT CHAPLAINS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THE FUNDING DISCUSSION ISSUE ONE
AS PART OF THE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE PACKAGE CALIFORNIA'S
GOVERNOR THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND SPENDING
FOR THE PURCHASE OF OFF ROAD
EQUIPMENT- AT OUR PORT. AS WELL
AS FUNDING SUPPORT
ELECTRIFICATION THESE FUNDING
SOURCES WILL PROVIDE INVESTMENT
REPORTS TO ENSURE THAT THE
EQUIPMENT USED BY AIRPORT TO
MOVE CARGO WITHIN OUR FACILITIES
WITH MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND
THERE'S SUFFICIENT
INFRASTRUCTURE CALIFORNIA'S
PORTS ARE STRIVING DAILY TO
IMPROVE AIR QUALITY TO
FACILITATE WATER QUALITY
PROTECTION AND TOOK FAN WILDLIFE
AND HABITAT CONSERVATION
INVESTMENTS LIKE THIS THIRTEEN
SURE THAT WE CAN MEET OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS WILL ALSO
REMIND REMAINING ECONOMICALLY
COMPETITIVE APPRECIATE YOUR.
CONSIDERATION OF THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE LINES. AND A LET ME JUST
SAY I THINK ASK WE COULD YOU CAN
SECOND- AS SOON AS YOU'VE
CONCLUDED YOUR COMMENTS WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A BRIEF BREAK
UNFORTUNATELY I'M THE ONLY ONE
WHO'S ON THE DIETS HERE AT THIS
TIME AND IT'S GOING TO BE
NECESSARY TO HAVE A- COUPLE
MINUTE BREAK. PLEASE PROCEED SO
OKAY LOOKING THAT. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS THE
OPERATOR BROKE THE ON VICE
PRESIDENT OF PROJECT DEVELOPMENT
AT PLUG POWER PLUG POWER IS-
BUILDING CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
GREEN HYDROGEN PRODUCTION PLANT
IN FRESNO COUNTY THIS PROJECT
AND THE ASSOCIATED THREE HUNDRED
MEGAWATT SOLAR PROJECT
REPRESENTS OVER FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A PRIVATE
INVESTMENT AND IT WILL DELIVER
GREEN HYDROGEN AT PRICE PARITY
TO DIESEL AND GASOLINE IN THE
CALIFORNIA MARKET. I URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE
XCELERATED BUILD OUT OF BOTH
LIGHT DUTY AND HEAVY DUTY
HYDROGEN FUELING STATIONS THE
GROWTH OF THESE NETWORKS PROVIDE
THE DEMAND SIDE SIGNAL THAT
DRIVES PRIVATE INVESTMENT IN
HYDROGEN PRODUCTION PROJECTS
SUCH AS OURS IT IS A LARGE
MULTIPLIER EFFECT AND- ON THE
BUILD OUT OF ZERO CARBON
INFRASTRUCTURE INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE STATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU WE WILL TAKE A AS I
MENTIONED A BRIEF BREAK NOW AND
TO BE. BACK IN A THREE TO FIVE
MINUTES. THE TWENTY YES TWENTY
SPEAKERS WERE SO. BUT PLENTY OF
TIME TOGETHER.
FIVE ONE RENDON DOUBLE
BORDERLINE PARK. FOR A
PARTICULAR. I PART OF PRETTY
MUCH.
ALL RIGHT HOPEFULLY EVERYBODY
STILL THERE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME A COUPLE OF MOMENTS-
OPERATOR ARE YOU READY TO
PROCEED. I AM EXCELLENT NEXT UP
ON THE THIRTY DAYS FOR PUBLIC
TIME. HI JEREMY ANOTHER OPTION
THE NATION YEAH- FOR THE OVERALL
. TIME THEIR ON THE. YOU FOR.
OUR FREEDOM FOR THE CHARTER AND. THE PROGRAM. UMBILICAL AND
THAT HAS SECTOR THIS AMERICAN
LEGION HOLDING OUT THAT WOULD BE
MOVIE PROBABLY PARDON ACT. HE
FIFTEEN WITH THE NINE WHOLE
COUNTRY. I REQUEST.
THE ONLY PEOPLE HAS ALREADY.
HARMFUL READ JUNIOR TRY WE ASK
THAT THE LATEST LEGISLATURE
INCLUDES FOR SMALL OFF ROAD
ENGINES TO ENVISION LANDSCAPING
SMALL GENERATORS TO YOUR MACHINE
ENGINE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE ALL
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCE THE
BENEFITS OF THEIR EMISSIONS AS
RAPIDLY. AS POSSIBLE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT TRIP FONG. FORTY
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
AND THE FROM ABOUT THAT LOOK AT
THE ACCOUNTS WITH THE GREEN I
MEAN IF THE TO PROVIDING
COMMENTS ON ITEM ONE ON BEHALF
OF GREEN LIGHTING AND THE
CHARGER HEAD COALITION WILL FIND
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR THAT ACTED
IN A TRUCK COMMITMENT TO EQUITY
BY PRIORITIZING FUNDING FOR THE
CAPITATION EQUITY PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY IT CAN CARD FOR
ALL. THE CLIP THAT THE PROGRAM
IN THE MOBILITY EQUITY PROJECT I
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE. AND OF
COURSE THE TRUCKING BUT PROGRAM.
OKAY PROVIDE A QUICK ROLE IN HOW
REDUCE. POLLUTION BY. DIRECT
MEANINGFUL BENNETT HELLO
HOUSEHOLDS. AND EVEN THOUGH THE
GOOD START WE ARE. A NEED FOR A
- INVESTMENT IN PROGRAM TO HELP
. MEANINGFUL IMPACT JUST ABOUT
AND WE COMMUNITIES. OUR WANTED
TO QUICKLY ADDRESS THE L. A.
ENOUGH AND I CAN. ABOUT THE
UNCERTAIN LAW THE TRAFFIC.
ACROSS PROGRAM IN ACHIEVING
EQUALITY. WE BELIEVE THAT WE
WILL NOT NEED ANY OF OUR STATE
KILEY MAY I D. B. POLICY GOALS
WITHOUT PRIORITIZING INVESTMENTS
AND ARE MOST IMPACTED COMMUNITY.
WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO SOLELY
BASED BENEFITS AND PROGRAMS.
SPECIALLY EVERY PROGRAMS AND
COST EFFECTIVENESS TECHNOLOGY
DEPARTMENT MARKET TRANSFORMATION
OR TRICKLE DOWN BENEFITS. ARE
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROGRAM
THE PROVIDING MULTIPLE SOCIAL
ECONOMIC AND ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS. AND THE FACT THAT THE
DOES NOT BEING RECOGNIZED
DEMONSTRATE THAT THE CONNECTING
COMPLETE DISREGARD FOR THE LIVES
EXPERIENCES OF OUR IMPACT THE
COMMUNITY. THE STATE AND ITS
LEADERSHIP MUST BE INTENTIONAL
AND APPROACH AND NOT TO TALK
ABOUT EQUITY. BY MAKE EQUITY
REAL BY OPERATION IDEA AND
PUTTING IT INTO PRACTICE BY
PRIORITIZING THE DEVELOPMENT IN
OUR FUNDING COMMUNITIES OTHER
CLEAN AS THEY CONTINUE TO BY.
THE BRAND OF POVERTY AND
POLLUTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY. BLIND TWENTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS- AND IT'S
WORKED WITH TESLA WE APPRECIATE
THE LEGISLATURE LEADERSHIP IN
ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE
TOUGHEST EVOLVING THE TESLA SEMI
TO PROVIDE A COMPELLING
INTERNATIONAL TURNED A PROTEST
MOVEMENT MY COMMENTS THEY RELATE
TO THE H. THE PROGRAM FIRST- WE
DISAGREE WITH CARDS RECENT
DECISION TO EXCLUDE LARGE FLEETS
FROM A TRIP STARTING IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE IN ATHLETICS WE CAN
BE REMOVED LARGELY TO CRITICAL
EARLY MOVERS WELL POSITION COME
GRAYSON THAT TRANSITION BUT IT
WOULD BE A MISTAKE TO ASSUME
THEY'LL DEFINITELY VEHICLES OUT
SUPPORT NEAR TERM. IN BUILDING A
TRIP FUND CONCURRENT EARLY
ACTION BY LARGELY METICULOUS THE
GREEN MANY WILL HAVE NO
COMPLIANCE OBLIGATIONS OF THE
END OF THE DECADE OTHERS ALSO
VERY CONCERNED OF HOW IT'S BEEN
TENANTS ARE STRUCTURED WE CAN
RESULT IN DEMAND FAR EXCEEDING
THE SUPPLY FUNDS AS A RESULT H.
IT CANNOT BE FACTORED INTO
INVESTMENT DECISIONS UNDERMINING
PROGRAMS ADVOCACY TEMPLE
COMMITTEE COMMENTS THE CARD
LAYING OUT. TURNED AWAY
DESTRUCTION SENTENCE. I CAN
IMPROVE THE PROGRAM. AND THAT
ARE LINED UP WITH THE GOAL
REDUCING. I'D BE HAPPY TO. THE
IS. A AND I PRETTY THAT THE- BY
TESLA'S. TODAY AND HOPE I CAN.
THE LETTER APPROACH AND
CONDITIONS FOR. FUNDING TO THE
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. WE HAVE LINE TWO. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BRANDENBURG ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER SMALL THIRTY FIVE LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS WE APPRECIATE THE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FUNDING
FOR AGRICULTURAL DIESEL
REPLACEMENTS AND UPGRADES.
ACTUALLY ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
PROPOSED FIFTY MILLION FOR A
DISTRICT IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
SB SIX SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY ARE
PROTECTION PROGRAM HOWEVER
DESPITE ADDITIONAL COMMUNITIES
BEING ADDED TO THE PROGRAM. THIS
IS THE SAME AMOUNT AS IN
PREVIOUS YEARS AND WE CONTINUE
TO NOTE THAT AMOUNTS HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN INSUFFICIENT
TO MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
STATE MANDATED PROGRAM.
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING GOES FOR
AIR MONITORING COMMUNITY
OUTREACH DEVELOPING COMMUNITY
EMISSION REDUCTION PLANS AND THE
OTHER IMPORTANT ACTIVITIES. ALSO
NOTE THAT COMMUNITY PROTECTION
AND SENATORS HAVE BEEN REDUCED
FROM TWO HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION WHICH
IS AN OVER 30% CUT TO A PROGRAM
THAT IS ALREADY UNDER FUNDED.
LAST YEAR'S. ADAPTED BUDGET.
ALSO INCLUDED FUNDING FOR THE
WOOD SMOKE REDUCTION PROGRAM
WHICH PROVIDES VOLUNTARY
INCENTIVES FOR REPLACING
INEFFICIENT AND UNCERTIFIED WOOD
HEATING DEVICES AT HOMES WITH
CLEANER DEVICES. THE PROPOSED
BUDGET DOES NOT INCLUDE FUNDING
AND WE ASK YOU TO INCLUDE
pLASTLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO READ
AUTHORIZED THE HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL. AND COST EFFECTIVE
COLUMN WHERE AN EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY THREE LOCAL INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS TO AVOID DISRUPTION AND
HELP US MEET OUR CLEAN AIR ACT
OBLIGATIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU. LINE.
FIFTY FIVE. AN AFTERNOON HEARING
MEMBERS AND WITH THE HELP OF
TRANSPLANT CONSULTING ON BEHALF
OF NEXT GEN READY DURING THE
PARKING THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
THEIR EMISSION VEHICLE BUDGET
AND AT THAT THEIR MISSION
VEHICLE EQUITY PROGRAMS BE
IMPROVED AND EXPANDED WE ALSO
WANT TO ENCOURAGE FOR
LEGISLATURE TO BUILD UPON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WITH
ENHANCED FUNDING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND AT THE
PROGRAM. AND LASTLY WE SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL TO CREATE THE
OFFICE OF RACIAL EQUITY WITHIN
CARP AND URGED LEGISLATURE TO
SUPPORT EFFORTS TO EMBED RACIAL
EQUITY AT THE FOREFRONT OF
GOVERNMENT A GOVERNMENT POLICIES
AND. PROGRAMS ACROSS THE BOARD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE.
FIFTY THREE. MISTER CHAIR
pOF THE TEAMSTERS PORT DIVISION
AND I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE SIX WHICH IS
FUNDING FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
SEVEN NINE FOUR- WE WERE CO
SPONSORS AS EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY
FOUR WHICH WAS A GROUND BREAKING
LAW TO LINK PROGRESS TOWARD
CLIMATE GOALS WITH LABOR
STANDARDS AND IT ENSURES THAT
PORT DRAYAGE AND SHORT HAUL
TRUCKING FLEET OWNERS FOLLOW
STATE LAWS REGARDING THIS
CLASSIFICATION AS ONE OF THE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS TO
RECEIVE PUBLIC CLEAN TRUCK
SUBSIDIES FROM CARPETS. AND
FLOOR REQUIRES CARP TO
COORDINATE WITH OTHER AGENCIES
AND IMPLEMENT NEW STANDARDS ON
SUBSIDIES AND SO THE SUCCESS OF
THIS LAW REALLY DEPENDS ON
EFFECTIVE IMPLEMENTATION AND ON
CARP GAINING THE NEW EXPERTISE
IN LABOR AND SAID THAT THEY WILL
BE ABLE TO ADD TO FIX
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED AND SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AND THAT THE PROPOSAL
FOR FUNDING FOR IMPLEMENTATION.
THANKS SO MUCH THANK YOU. WIND.
FIFTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS IS
MARK FENSTER MAKER ON BEHALF OF
JUSTICE WANT TO REGISTER AND
STATIC SUPPORT FOR THE INCREASE
FUNDING LEVELS OF YOUR MISSION
TRUCKS INFRASTRUCTURE AS
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES TO REJECT ANY
REQUESTS FOR SO CALLED NEAR ZERO
FOR MAPPING BURNING RUCKS. WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IS THAT CONTINUED
INVESTMENTS AND COMPASSIONATE
ESPECIALLY THE TRUCKING SECTOR
IS NOT A VIABLE STRATEGY TO MEET
OUR STATE WIDE TARGETS FOR
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS NEEDED TO RETAIN
FEDERAL AND STATE CLEAN AIR
STANDARDS AND WE CANNOT CONFIRM
EVERYTHING NOW SEATS FOR ABOUT
THE SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AS WELL AS
BY CARD. WE KNOW THIS IS THE
PATHWAY FORWARD AND WHAT
ENCOURAGE THAT YOU REJECTED.
REQUEST THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. LINE. NINE GOOD
AFTERNOON GENTLEMEN MEMBERS
NATALIE BACK NOT BE HAPPY TO
HELP START CHARACTER IT MEMBER
BASED NONPROFIT DEDICATED TO THE
ACCELERATION OF THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY WE WANT
TO REGISTER OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED ZERO
EMISSIONS VEHICLE BUDGET PACKAGE
THE FUNDING WILL INCUR
CALIFORNIA AT THE TRUE LEADER
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROVIDE
MARKET CERTAINTY THAT WILL ALLOW
GALA NECESSARY THE ONE
RECOMMENDATION WITHOUT THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER IT
CONSIDERING ADDITIONAL MULTI
YEAR FUNDING FOR THE CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATE PROGRAM OR C. B.
R. P. ON TOP OF LAST YEAR'S
ALLOCATION. WITH EXISTING
PROGRAM PROVIDES. CRITICAL
DEBATE THAT EQUITY. BY THT SIX
ACCEPTABLE MARTHA INCOME
FAMILIES. BEGINNING THE R. P.
THE BUT DIRECTLY THE CLIMATE IS
THAT BOTH BY HELPING TO GROW THE
THAT CAR. QUICKLY IF. WHICH OFF
THE TELEVISION EVERYBODY YOU THE
MARKET THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HELLO LINE SIXTY. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THAT SUPPORT
MANAGER WITH CLIMATE CENTER
ABOUT THE ONCE SECRET DEDICATED
TO ACHIEVING DECARBONISATION AT
SPEED NOT SCALE WE APPRECIATE
THE STRONG BROKEN ON CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS AND
WOULD LIKE TO URGE THE
LEGISLATION THE ADMINISTRATION
TO INCREASE THOSE INVESTMENT AS
PER THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
TRUCK HAD COALITION EIGHT
INCLUDE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
FOR THE TRANSPORTATION EQUITY
PROGRAMS FOUR POINT EIGHT
BILLION FOR HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES.
AND TWO BILLION PER CHARGE
SUPPORT THESE INVESTMENTS ARE
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT AS HE BEATS
WILL PLAY AN INCREASINGLY
IMPORTANT ROLE IN ENERGY
RESILIENCE GRIT POWER OUTAGES AS
WE EXPERIENCE MORE CLIMATE
DRIVEN EXTREME EVENTS RANGING
COMPETE WITH THAT STRAIN ENERGY
CAPACITY TO MATHIS NO TRUMP
RECTIFICATION LINE THE PROJECT
WILL BE DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES BROUGHT POWER LOCAL
LEVEL IS MORE MARC PARENTS GIVEN
THAT EAT EAT EAT OUR BATTERIES
ON WHEELS THEY CAN PROVIDE
FAMILIES AND BUSINESSES WITH A
BACKUP POWER SUPPLY IN THE EVENT
OF A BLACKOUT. OR OTHER GREAT
EMERGENCY. I WE WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE SEEKS TO THAT BUT ARE NAY
IN. HI DID IT FIRST. WE WOULD
INCUR THAT. BE SOLELY FOR WE'RE
NO. GREEN ELECTROLYTIC. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. A LINE SIX ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MANY IS
CHRIS OF CULTURE FOR CLEAN AIR
SPEAK NOT ITEM ONE WE ALONG WITH
CHARTER HAD CAL INVESTOR CLEAN
AIR CAMPAIGN SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S POSITION AFTER THE
LEGISLATURE TO GO EVEN FURTHER
TO BUILD OFF OF LAST YEAR'S
HISTORIC INVESTMENT IN CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION IT AND ABOUT SOME
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION FOR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROJECTS
FOUR POINT EIGHT BILLION
PROCUREMENT CONTRACT. BUTTON
OPERATE APPOINTMENT AND TWO
BILLION FOR THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM ZERO
MISSION CHARGING SUPPORT IF AND
THAT'S A PRIORITY FOR US FURTHER
WE OPPOSE CHANGING THE EQUITY
DRIVEN PROVISIONS IN CARP CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING PLAN
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSPORTATION
EQUITY PROGRAMS ARE CLEANING
TRANSPORTATION RECONNECTING
COMMUNITIES AND IN MANY CASES
CORRECTING HISTORIC INJUSTICES.
GET THE FUNDING SINCE THESE
PROGRAMS ARE OVERSUBSCRIBED WE
ALSO NEED TO INVEST IN CLEAN A
MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS
CARCINOGENIC DIESEL PARTICULATE
MATTER IF THE PREDOMINANT CARE
TOXIC CONTAMINANTS IN OUR AIR-
OUR TRUCKS ARE MASSIVE%
CONTRIBUTOR TO SMOG FORMING A
GREENHOUSE GAS POLLUTANTS AS
WELL THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. WELL I SIX TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAPLAIN MODEL TALK TO
YOU AND YOUR FAMILY THIS IS
JENNIFER APPEARING ON BEHALF OF
MEALS ON WHEELS CALIFORNIA AND
OUR MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
MEALS ON WHEELS SAN FRANCISCO
ARE MAKING PLANS NOW TO
ELECTRIFY THEIR FLEETS OF
PRIMARILY CLASS TO BE CARGO VAN
THAT ARE USED TO DRIVE MANY
MILES DAY SHORT TRIPS DELIVERING
HEALTHY KNEELED STOOD ON A
BOOKING YOURS WE FLAG TODAY AT
THE DIRE TO ENSURE THAT- SUCH
AMBITIONS ARE ARE ELIGIBLE-
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE THESE ARE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS JUST
MAKE SURE THAT THE PROGRAM
GUIDELINES ARE CLEAR THAT
NONPROFITS ARE ELIGIBLE. FOR THE
STATE TO THAT PROGRAM AND THAT
THERE IS SUFFICIENT FUNDING
INCLUDED IN THAT CATEGORY THAT
SUCH VEHICLES ARE PART OF- WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
THE SENATE THE ADMINISTRATION.
AROUND THE PRIORITY THANK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BLIND. FORTY
FIVE. HI THIS IS BEVERLY DAY
SHOW AND THE PRESIDENT
ELECTRICAL TO ASSOCIATION
ACTUALLY JUST CHANGE YOUR NAME
TO ELECTRIC VEHICLE ASSOCIATION-
I WOULD LIKE TO URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER NOT FUNDING HYDROGEN SO
MUCH FOR ONE THING RIGHT NOW 95%
OF IT IS PRODUCED BY NATURAL GAS
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS THE
FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRIES WAY OF
STAYING IN THE GAME- ALECTRA
THREE IS ALREADY AVAILABLE IN
PEOPLE'S HOMES THEY CAN PLUG IN
OVERNIGHT IF THEY HAVE A DRYER
PLUG THEY CAN HAVE A LOT LEVEL
TWO CHARGING STATION IN THEIR
HOME. AS THE- BATTERY BATTERIES
ARE IMPROVED THE- THE DISTANCE-
IS- EXCUSE ME THE RANGE
INCREASES THE TOTAL SUM LIVES
HAVE SUFFICIENT RANGE THE
ARGUMENT HAS BEEN THAT HYDROGEN
IS NECESSARY FOR LONG DISTANCE
AND THE TOUGHBOOK SEMIS AND
OTHER- MANUFACTURES SEMIS WILL
HAVE SUFFICIENT RANGE TO MEET
WHAT. SOMEBODY COULD DRIVE IN
ONE DAY. I'M IN CHARGE OF. ALL
THE COST IS PRO FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR HYDROGEN AND-
THE WATER USAGE MUST BE
CONSIDERED FOR CALIFORNIA'S
DROUGHT CONDITIONS WE ARE TOLD
BY ONE OF THE WATER DISTRICT
PEOPLE IN THE IN THE SOUTH THAT-
IT WOULD DRAIN LAKES TO BE USING
SUFFICIENT WATER TO PRODUCE A
SUFFICIENT HYDROGEN- WRAP UP
PLEASE. OKAY I WANT TO KNOW IF
THE CALL AIR QUALITY IS BEING
MONITORED. OFF ON FARMS BECAUSE
OUR CHILDREN ARE BEING SPRAYED
WITH IT THE THERE BEING SPRAYED
AND HAVING COGNITIVE
DIFFICULTIES AND THE TEACHERS
ARE QUITTING BECAUSE THEY'RE
SEEING THE CHILDREN AND THEY
THEMSELVES ARE BEING AFFECTED
BY. THE PESTICIDE PESTICIDE
SPRAYING NEAR THE SCHOOLS THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
. MY NUMBER SIXTEEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT CHAIRMAN BLOOM
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS NATE SO
LOVE ON BEHALF OF THE PORT OF LA
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE
MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF FUNDING REPORT
ELECTRIFICATION AND ZERO
EMISSION DRAYAGE OPERATIONS TO
HELP US MEET OUR CLEAN AIR
ACTION PLAN GOALS OF ALL ZERO
EMISSION DRAYAGE OPERATIONS BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER- JUST WANTED TO
NOTE THAT THERE ABOUT THIRTY
THOUSAND DRAYAGE TRUCKS. SERVING
THE STATE'S POOREST AND WE ONLY
HAVE- ACHIEVE YOUR MISSION FOR
UNDER ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS SO
FAR SO WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A COMBINATION
OF LOCAL FUNDING AND STATE
FUNDING IN ORDER TO MAKE THAT
TRANSITION HAPPENED ALSO WANTED
TO KNOW THAT WE'RE SUPPORTIVE
OF. ENSURING THAT FUNDING-
SHOULD BE FOR- HUMAN OPERATED. A
QUICK MINUTE AS PART OF THE-
PORT ELECTRIFICATION FUNDING
THAT- CONSISTENT WITH OUR
COLLABORATION WITH I'LL W. THAT
LANGUAGES THAT INCLUDE AND PASS
BUDGETS- ALSO WANTED TO NOTE ON
THE SEPARATE CLIENT THE SAN
FRANCISCO BASED VERY THE SFA'S.
AREA WATER EMERGENCY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY. WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DEMONSTRATION- FUNDING
SINCE WE ARE THE LARGEST PUBLIC
CARRY OPERATOR IN THE STATE.
IT'S GOING TO COST US A LOAN
OVER A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
YOU TRANSITION. TO ZERO EMISSION
FERRY THAT NINE CLOSE PURCHASING
NEW FERRIES- RETROFITTING
FERRIES AND ALSO SHORE SIDE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE. AS AS
PART OF THAT TRANSITION WE ALSO
NEED THIRTY SEVEN MILLION IN
FUNDING FOR THE MISSION BAY
FERRY TERMINAL SO THAT WE CAN
IMPLEMENT A ZERO EMISSION. HIGH
FREQUENCY THIRTY LIVE TO SERVE
MISSION BAY TREASURE ISLAND IN
SAN FRANCISCO WITH WHICH WILL
BENEFIT. RESIDENTS FROM
THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA SO
CLICHE YOUR CONSIDERATION. OF
THOSE ITEMS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. NEXT WE HAVE A COMMON FROM
LINE. SEVEN FORMER PLEASE ONE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE START OVER.
SURE I THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DAN MERKEL ST
AND I WORK FOR A RIVAL A U. K.
AND US MANUFACTURER OF
COMMERCIAL ELECTRIC VEHICLE WE
HAVE A TEN THOUSAND BAN ORDER
FROM UPS AND ARE LOOKING FORWARD
TO OUR EDIE'S TRACKING LINE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT EARLY AT THE
END OF THE YEAR. AND THE GLOBAL
COMPANY WE APPRECIATE THE MANY
MARKET SIGNALED THAT
CALIFORNIA'S BAN YEP POLICY
ABOUT THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
POTENTIAL FOR THE EIGHT STEP
PROGRAM TO FEED AND ACCELERATE
PENETRATION OF THE VEHICLE.
HOWEVER WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH
AARP MOST RECENT FUNDING PLAN
FOR EACH FACT WHICH WILL
PROHIBIT LARGER FLEETS COMMUTING
VOUCHERS FOR PURCHASE PURCHASING
BATTERY EV'S WE WORRY THE
PRESCRIPTION WOULD NEARLY THAT
DEPLOYMENT OF COMMERCIAL ET
STATEWIDE INCLUDING AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHERE
LARGER FLEET HE WOULDN'T BE
OPERATE. WE FURTHER ARE
CONCERNED WITH THE
SUSTAINABILITY OF THE PROGRAM
OVERALL EFFECT RAPID DESCRIPTION
NEED WE HONOR HER UNABLE TO PLAN
FOR ANY INCENTIVE FUNDING IN
PURCHASING DECISIONS AT THE
THOUGHT OF OUR JOINT COMMENT
LETTER WITH MEDIAN AND HAVE FUN
WE SUPPORT ALTERNATIVE
APPROACHES STRUCTURING AGE THAT
THE HELP MINIMIZE EMISSIONS. AND
ENSURE THAT WE OPERATE-
INCLUDING OUR CUSTOMERS ARE ABLE
TO PLAN AROUND INTENDED AS THEY
DEPLOY A NEW EP THANKS. MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU. BACK TO HAVE LINE
SAID. GOOD CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ERZERUM AT ALL AND OF CLEAN AIR
NOW OR VALLEY CAN'T VALUE FIVE
OH ONE SEE THREE PUBLIC CHARITY
COMMITTED TO QUANTIFY ED LEE
REDUCING AIR EMISSIONS IN
CALIFORNIA BUT PARKING VALLEY
THE REGION WITH THE WORST AIR
QUALITY IN THE UNITED STATES. WE
ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
PACKAGE ESPECIALLY THE CLEAN CAR
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM
VALLEY CANADA AND APPROXIMATELY
FOUR THOUSAND VEHICLE
REPLACEMENT AND HAVE
APPROXIMATELY THREE THOUSAND
MORE CUSTOMERS IN THEIR PIPELINE
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
CONTINUED. FUNDING IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT THIS RECORD NUMBER OF
PPLICANTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. LINE SIXTY FIVE. HI THIS IS
BEEN GOING TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE CHARGE AHEAD
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN TO INVEST IN
CLEAN AIR IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE
GET THE MOST POLLUTING CARS OFF
THE STREET THAT CAN AS WE CAN AS
WE ALL KNOW AIR POLLUTION IS
DETRIMENTAL TO OUR HEALTH AND
THE HEALTH OF OUR PLANET.
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR IS THE MAIN CONTRIBUTOR
TO OUR STATE POOR AIR QUALITY WE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED INVESTMENT
AND ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND CLEAN
CAR CHARGING STATIONS HOWEVER
THIS INVESTMENT IS JUST THE
START AT THE AGENCY THAT MAKE
WILL NEED ONE POINT TWO MILLION
CHARGING STATION TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S GROWING POPULATION
OF ELECTRIC VEHICLE USERS. IN
ADDITION TO INVESTING IN CLEAN
CARS AND CHARGING STATIONS OFTEN
THAT CAN CLEAN COAL BUCKET
TRUCKS AND TRAINS GERMISTON
VEHICLE THAN CLEANER
TRANSPORTATION ARE ESSENTIAL TO
SECURING. CLEANER AIR FOR
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. LINE SIXTY SIX. HI THIS IS
GREG TURNER WITH THE
SPORTFISHING ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE GOLDEN GATE
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATION FIRST OF
ALL I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR BROAD
SUPPORT AND ON SEPT THREE
PARTICULARLY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BENNETT. WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH HARD TO PROTECT ECO TOURISM
IN OUR COASTAL COMMUNITIES STATE
WIDE BUT STARKLY HE PROGRAMS
HAVE NOT DONE SO. THE NAME OF
THE SPORT BAKING WHILE WATCHING
AND OTHER ECO TOURISM BATTLES.
THE BATTLE THAT ALSO CONDUCT
MARINE LAB RETIRED TITLE ONE
SCHOOLS AND NONPROFITS INCLUDING
PROVIDING PROMISE YOU THEIR
FIRST EXPERIENCE ON THE OCEAN.
IN ADDITION LICENSE SALES
SUPPORT DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION PROGRAMS.
STATE FUNDING FOR CONTINUED
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS IT'S
CRITICAL NOT GENTRIFY OUR OCEAN
ACCESS. IT IS NECESSARY TO
PROVIDE THE STATE FUNDING A KEY
OCEAN ACTOR AFFORDABLE ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND WE- LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE SUBCOMMITTEE IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN ENSURING THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE
FORTY ONE. THAT AFTERNOON- TABLE
MEMBERS ITS ROLE UNDER BRAND
IT'S KIND OF A KNOCK IN THE
NATION. YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
AND FOR COMPETING AT THE TWO
DIFFERENT SO THEY OF ENTITY WHO
THE HAVING SAID THAT. I BELIEVE
THAT THE LEGISLATURA WOULD BE IN
A BETTER POSITION TO PRIORITIZE
FUNDING IF YOU HAVE METRICS
COMPARING THE AMOUNT OF ENERGY
REQUIRED TO GENERATE AND
DISTRIBUTE HYDROGEN. TO THE
AMOUNT OF ENERGY REQUIRED TO
RECHARGE BATTERIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BLIND. TWENTY EIGHT.
BUT YOU CARE TO MEMBERS AND YOU
HAVE THREE ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY- WE
WILL EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF
FUNDING- AND THE GOVERNORS OF
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE PACKAGE
ARE ABOUT WHAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED THAT WE GET THAT MARY
VICE MERIAL- WE PARTICULARLY
SUPPORT. THE FACT PACKAGE FOR
BOTH- YOUR MISSION- TRANSIT
BUSES ONLY METRO THE COMMISSION
TO CHANGE OVER TO SLEET ZERO
MISSION. ABOUT TEN YEARS BEFORE
MANDATED BY THEIR RESOURCES
BOARDS LIKE TWENTY THIRTY. AND-
THE STATE'S. AND ARE ON NATURE
OF. MULTI YEAR COMMITMENT IS
CRUCIAL TO PLANNING- FOR
POLITICAL METRO ALSO SPORTS- THE
ELEMENT OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
THAT WOULD PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS. MEASURE M.
MONEY- DEDICATED TO- SERVICES
TRUCKS ELEVEN ALONG THE SEVEN
TEN FREEWAY CORRIDOR SO THAT IS-
A PROGRAM WHERE THE NATURECOULD
BE A FUNDING PARTNER WITH THE
STATE'S EXPENSE FUND MADE
AVAILABLE. FOR THAT QUARTER AND
IN GENERAL PRESERVATION TRUCKS
AND THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
CLASSIFICATIONS AND FOR THOSE
REASONS- I WITH- URGE AN AYE
VOTE AT THE RIGHT TIME. THANK
YOU. LINE. SIXTY NINE. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SYLVIA SO LEAST
SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE BAND
ENERGY ECONOMY OR AP EIGHT
SUPPORTS THE PROPOSED BUDGET
SEVEN VESTMENT PACKAGE THAT
FOCUSES ON MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
INVESTMENTS AND EQUITY PROGRAMS-
WE BELIEVE THAT RELIABLE MULTI
YEAR FUNDING IS THE ESSENTIAL TO
PROVIDING CERTAINTY FOR THESE
PROGRAMS CLOSING THE GAP ON
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED
TOGETHER WITH FULLY FUNDING
EQUITY FOCUSED VEHICLE INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS REMAINS IMPERATIVE TO
ACCELERATING WIDESPREAD THAT
ADOPTION AND ACCESSIBILITY. WE
ARE ALSO ENCOURAGED TO SEE DOES
HAVE INVESTMENT PACKAGE DEDICATE
NEW FUNDING TO PROGRAMS THAT
EXPAND AFFORDABLE HOME CHARGING
AND CHARGING STATION ACCESS FOR
LOW INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION TO SPEED THE
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
SCHOOL BUSES STATEWIDE WE ALSO
ASK THAT THAT THESE DOLLARS
FUNDED MANY DEATHS BUT THERE'S
AS POSSIBLE WHERE NEEDED MOST AS
WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSED STRUCTURE FOR THE GRANT
AMOUNT AND LIMITATIONS ON THE
NUMBER OF BUSES THAT CAN BE
SUSPENDED PER DISTRICT WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE LOOK
AT PROVIDING TECHNICAL.
ASSISTANCE TO THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT DO NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO NAVIGATE THE CURRENT
STATE PROGRAMS YOU CAN'T READY
TO WORK WITH YOU THE
ADMINISTRATION. ON THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU. WE HAVE. TWENTY NINE.
CAN'T MEMBERS MARTIN ATAN ATTIC
APPLE INTERNATIONALIZE SHOWER
HOUSE UNION ON THE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT FOR
THAT WHAT ARE WE SUPPORT BACK WE
DO REQUIRE AT. THE DESIGN WHICH
INCLUDED TOOK MY USED FOR
AUTOMATION FOR THE PAST FIVE
YEARS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
LIMITED TIME SO THEY'RE NOT YOU
TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT CAP
AND TRADE FUNDS SB ONE THOUSAND
AND FEDERAL FUNDING. THIS IS A
WIN WIN STRAIGHT WEEK FIND
TWENTY QUID. IN KEEP AWAY OUR
EMPLOYED I EMPLOYERS HAVE MADE
RECORD PROFITS AT THE EXPENSE OF
CALIFORNIA FARMWORKERS. FARMERS
AND WORKERS ARE WE ASK FOR THAT
LANGUAGE TO BE INCLUDED TO
PROTECT OUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. WEBER CALLING FROM NINE THIRTY
THREE ZERO. HI IT'S ME. YES YOUR
LINE IS OPEN WAS IT YOU OKAY.
PLEASE PLEASE PROCEED ALL ABOUT
YOUR- BUT- CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE
CAN HEAR YOU WELL. OKAY HI MY
NAME IS THE THOUGHT THAT YOU'LL
GET THAT I WOULD LIKE TO POINT
TO WHAT THE OP ONE **** UP TO
FIFTY THAT. ARE THE BIG PROBLEM
WRITING ENERGY ARE. WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA WOULD REQUIRE
SOMETHING LIKE THAT HEARTBEAT
THAT A LOT A LOT OF ENERGY
STRATEGY WHAT SIX MONTHS. OUR
HYDROGEN WILL PART. OR THE OTHER
THE MONEY THAT YOU ARE CHEAPER
WOULD YOU HAVE DONE. AB ARE NOT
FOR. SO I THINK CREEK ARE. OUR
HOW DO YOU MUST BE INCLUDED IN
THE FUTURE SOLUTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AT THIS TIME THERE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN Q. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR FOR
pUS TO THE CONCLUSION OF OUR
HEARING. AND WE WILL STAND
ADJOURNED THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION.